you're probably wondering why we need
another python course on this channel
well Anil has an interesting approach to
teaching python this beginner's course
will help you learn python by thinking
and types this course teaches basic
programming Concepts instead of just
focusing on language syntax it's always
helpful to learn from different
perspectives and this may be just what
you need to Learn Python hi guys my name
is Anil kulkani and welcome to this
course modern python where no one
thinking and types
now if you wanted to Learn Python if you
are complete beginner or if you have
been struggling to Learn Python for a
time then this course is for you let me
share my journey of learning python it
took me a pretty long time to understand
python rather many months or rather a
couple of years to understand Python and
finally when I started to learn more
about python I could understand that I I
was struggling to Learn Python because I
was not able to think in types
you know python is a dynamic type
language so sometimes you are at lost to
understand what goes well and where we
have to use a particular variable or a
data type or a data structure so this
course is obviously designed for the
people who are totally new to python or
if you have or if you are struggling to
Learn Python for a while now
throughout this course I'll be taking
you through a smaller Journey we will
start by thinking at types and we will
end in thinking in layers so thinking is
in layers is like an architectural
pattern I will I'll help you to
understand what goes behind creating a
production level application before we
can go ahead and write python we need to
do a couple of things the first thing is
obviously we need to install Python and
we also need to set up our development
environment
but before that I would like you to meet
my friend Lewis now Lewis is going to
help us throughout this course for
learning python
before you can do anything else I want
you to go ahead and download all of the
source code for this entire tutorial
what I want you to do is just go to this
link github.com octilium slash modern
python101 and this is where you can find
the entire source code for this entire
tutorial
you can just click on code and just
click on download zip to download all of
the files in a zip format or if you are
using GitHub you can simply use this
link to to clone the repo after you have
downloaded all of the files this is how
it's going to look so let me open up my
readme and just let me open up in my
preview mode
okay so this is how all of the files and
the folders would look like now please
keep in mind that on my machine I could
have a couple of more additional folders
just for the sake of helping me
throughout the tutorial
but overall this is how it's going to
look in your machine as well at any
point in the future if you want to
compare your code with mine you can
simply click on this folders for example
if we just click on this folder type
system you can see there are a couple of
files which I have already written
for example just click on this file
variables and you can see all of the
code is right over here if you want to
see the sequence in which we are going
to learn all of these files then you can
simply click on readme and here you can
find the sequence
for example in this one the first file
would be your variables the second one
would be variable rules which is right
over here
and so on
well that's it for this video in the
next video we are going to download and
install python on your machine
before installing python I thought it
would be a very nice idea to give you a
small tour of python
for this I want you to open up your
favorite web browser and I want you to
search for
python online compiler
and I want you to click on this link
this is for repair id.com
and as you can see we have a working
python environment ready for us
so right on this line I want to print
out modern python 101 so just replace
hello world with
modern
python 101
and just click on the Run
so as you can see we have the output of
modern python 101
let's try one more simple example and
this time I want to print out my name
and my name is
octallium on this line instead of
printing modern python I want to print
out my name
that's it just hit the Run button one
more time and you can see we have the
output of octallium as you can see right
in Python is as simple as writing your
plain English and from the next video we
will see how to install Python and how
to set up our development environment
you can just go to the website
python.org
from here let me just zoom in first okay
from here just go to downloads and as
you can see since I'm using Mac OS so
that's why it's showing as Mac if you're
working on Windows most probably it will
show you on Windows and at the time of
recording the latest version is 3.10.5
so I just want you to click on this and
it will start the download you just have
to install python just as you would
install any other program just click on
this it will open up a installer dialog
so just click on continue continue
okay agreement I agree
and install now since I already have
python installed I won't be installing
but in your case if you don't have
python installed just go ahead and click
install
after the installation is done I want
you to open up your terminal if you are
working on Windows just make sure you
open up your Powershell
and let me just try to zoom inside this
as well
so once you have your terminal open I
want you to type python
hyphen and capital V
so as you can see it's showing the
python installed version in my case it
is 3.10.5 just make sure you have a
version which is more than 3.10 3.9 will
not work because I will be showing you a
couple of new features which I have been
introduced in the version 3.10 and if
you are watching this video in the
future you don't have to worry because
all of the functionality that I'm going
to show in this tutorial all of those
things are going to work in the future
as well the next thing that I want you
to do is install Visual Studio code
so I want you to go to this website
code dot Visual studio.com and I want
you to download video Studio code and
install it
so just click on this since I'm using a
Mac it's showing Mac if you are using
Windows make sure you click on the right
button
so just click on this
it will again download the installer and
you just have to install Visual Studio
code as you would install any other
program after installing Visual Studio
code I want you to open it up
so this is my visual studio code on the
left you can see there is a small bar
and I want you to click on extensions
let me take it up right over here and I
want you to search for python
the first thing that pops out right over
here this is the python extension by
Microsoft I want you to click on install
now I do have a couple of more extra
dependencies these are optional but I
would highly recommend you to install
all of those so just open up a terminal
if you're working on windows open up
your Powershell
and there is a command which is called
this pip now pip actually ships with
python I want you to type pip
install
IPython
my pi and black and just hit enter so
this are a couple of extra dependencies
that I would like you to install now
since I have already installed it's
showing me as
already satisfied but in your case it
will go ahead and install all of the
dependencies
and that's it now we can start writing
python code on our machine if we have
some doubts then you can open up this
readme file so this is the code that we
downloaded from GitHub
so inside my folder number one
introduction just click on readme and
you can see I have provided the links
for everything
there are a couple of more optional
dependencies for example this one code
Runner
this one we would see in some of the
future videos and if you want to have
the exact same theme like mine so you
can use this theme I'm using a theme
which is called as Pitch Black theme
and now if you are working on a Mac and
if you have issues while typing this
command so suppose you are you are
typing python slash V and if you are not
getting this output then just make sure
to watch the next video where we would
see how to rectify it sometimes on a Mac
you may not get the desired output
suppose you are typing python slash NV
if you are not getting this output then
maybe you can try typing Python 3
hyphen and V
now this is because Mac already comes
with a pre-installed python but most of
the times it is not going to be the
latest version you can use this syntax
python 3-3 all the time and if you want
to use pip then also you need to type
pip 3 and then you can say pip3 I want
to install my
IPython mypai and black this is also
going to work
but typing Python 3 and pip3 all the
while becomes slightly boring
so what I'm going to do is I am going to
set up an alias
for setting up an alias first thing that
I want you to do is I want you to go to
your home directory you can go to your
home directory by typing CD and that's
it let me clear up my terminal by typing
control and L
now if you type LS
Dash A L that means I want to list all
of my files and folders inside my
current directory and I also want to see
some of my hidden files as well
so as you can see it's a pretty long
list but the file that I am interested
is this one
it's called as dot
zshrc that's the file where we will set
up an alias I want you to go ahead and
open up that file inside your code
editor you can open up the same file
inside virtual Studio code by typing
code
followed by the name of the file don't
forget to put the dot before and now
just press enter
if you are not able to open up this file
from your terminal then inside your
Visual Studio code I want you to
type shift command and P and it will
open up a new window and I simply want
you to
type code and you can see the pop-up
shell command install code command in
the path I want to click that and after
clicking that you can simply
close and open up your terminal once
again
and
let me just Zoom inside
and now we can see I want to open up my
DOT zshrc file inside my code editor
just hit enter
for now just ignore all of the stuff
which I have inside my zshrc that's
because I'm using a lot of fancy setup
the thing that I want you to add inside
your zshrc are just these two lines
so what we are doing is we are just
setting up an alias that means whenever
we are typing python inside our terminal
at that time we actually need to type
Python 3 and the same thing goes with
Pip whenever we are typing pip I want my
system to invoke pip 3 instead so this
is what our Alias is going to do
just save your zsh RC filing again go
back to a terminal I again want you to
close and open up your terminal one more
time again let me Zoom inside it and now
this time if you're typing python
hyphen and V it should give you the
right output now that we have python
installed on our system it's time to
write our very first hello world program
but before we can write our hello world
program I would like you to create our
very own directory structure so that we
can organize all of the code in a much
better way
so for that I would like you to open up
your your finder or if you're on a
Windows just open up any window and
navigate to to the place where you want
to create the folder so I am just going
inside my home directory and here I'm
going to create a folder by the name of
modern
python
101
you can create this folder wherever you
want after this I am just going to open
up my visual studio code and I'm going
to drag this folder inside my visual
studio code
okay so here we are here I am going to
create one more folder and I'm going to
name it as 0 1
introduction
let me spell it right
and inside this folder let's create our
very first Python program so let's
create a file inside of this and I want
you to name the file as
hello world dot py always make sure that
we have the extension as dot p y so dot
py stands for a python file and right
now what we are going to do is we are
simply going to print hello world to our
terminal
a couple of lectures ago we have seen
how to do it online by using a python
online compiler but in this video let's
try to do it on our local machine
let me just collapse my sidebar
the first thing that I want you to write
here is an inbuilt function by the name
of print so basically what we are trying
to do is
we want to tell python hey python I want
you to print
hello world
and that's it now I want you to open up
your terminal and inside this terminal
let us see how we can execute this file
I'm inside my directory of modern python
101
from here I want to go to my newly
created folder 0 1 introduction and once
inside this folder I can simply run my
file by typing python followed by the
name of the file and just press enter
and here you can see we have the right
output of hello world
if you want to change this from Hello
World to hello octallium
let's do it let us save the file again
go back to the terminal
let me clear up my terminal let us try
running the file by typing python
followed by the file name one more time
and we have the desired output of hello
octallium
now typing Python and hello world.py all
the time becomes a little boring in
order to automate this task we are going
to install one more extension and this
time the name of the extension is called
as code Runner
so I want you to go to your extensions
Tab and I wanted to search for
code Runner
this is the plugin make sure you install
this plugin
once we have this plugin in place we can
simply run the file I'll just show you
how to do it
let me close my terminal let me close
all of this
so once we have the plugin installed you
can simply click on this play icon right
over here and that's going to execute
your file
so as you can see the code on extension
actually exuded my file and I have the
output of hello world on the screen so
this video was just to give you a small
feel of writing python on our local
machine from the next videos python is
going to get much more interesting and
we will start to learn all of the basic
fundamentals of python
now let's actually start learning Python
and the first concept that we are going
to learn in Python is all about
Understanding Variables
but before we can understand variables
we need to go on a picnic with Lewis yes
let's go on a picnic and then let's see
what variables is all about
so Lewis is planning for a picnic and he
is going to pack a slice of pizza in his
Tupperware
you don't want to go hungry on a picnic
do you Lewis also wants to pack some of
his clothes inside a bag and also a
bottle of water now let's try to
visualize this concept A Little More
technically
so you can imagine your Tupperware bag
and bottles to be your containers
and what this containers are going to
hold
is this slice of pizza clothes and water
so you can imagine all of these things
to be values so the containers are going
to hold all of the values now let's try
to see all of these things in the world
of python
so here we have three containers
Tupperware bag and bottle and we have
three values slice of pizza cloves and
water
so essentially what's happening is your
containers are just like your variables
because your variables are going to hold
some data you can translate this concept
in Python by typing like this on the
left you can see Tupperware is a
variable and the variable of Tupperware
is holding a value of slice of pizzas
this equal to is also called as the
assignment operator that means we are
assigning the value on the right to the
variable on the left and the same thing
goes with bag and bottle as well now
it's time for us to create some more
variables
so I'm inside my folder number two type
system so this is the code that we
downloaded from GitHub
and this is the folder that we created
remember we've created a folder called
as modern python 101 so this is where I
am
here I am going to create one more
folder
and I'm going to name it as 0 to type
system
and inside of this I want you to create
one more file by the name of
variables dot pi
and this is where we are going to create
some of our variables
here is the scenario Lewis wants to go
for a party and he has three items with
him he has balloons he has some crackers
and he has some hats but he has only a
single box
so let's see what he is going to do
let's create a variable called as box
here we are going to create our variable
called as box and let us assign the
value of
balloons to the variable of box please
remember to put this inverted commas
because this is the value that has been
assigned to our variable of box on the
next line we simply want to print out
our variable so as you already know we
can simply say hey python I want you to
print out my variable and the name of my
variable is box
that's it just save a file and let's try
to run the file
now there are two ways of running the
file if we have code Runner installed
you can simply click on this and this is
going to run your file and here you can
see we have the output of balloons or
you can also run the file from a
terminal in order to run the file from
the terminal first we need to go inside
in the right folder
as you can see right now I am inside the
folder modern python 101 and I need to
navigate inside my folder which is 0 2
type system once inside this folder you
can run the file by typing python
followed by the name of the file in my
case the name of the file is simply
variables dot pi and hit enter
so as you can see we have the output of
balloons
let me put up a small Command right here
all of these lines that you can see over
here which starts with a hash sign this
actually means a comment and these lines
are actually going to be ignored by
python while executing your file now the
suppose Lewis wants to take crackers
instead of balloons so let's see how we
can reassign the value to our variable
let me put up a command
and here we can simply reassign by
saying that
for the variable of box I want to
reassign the value to a new one and the
new value is going to be called as
crackers
let me get the spelling right
and we can again try to print it out so
let's try to print out
the box one more time
let me run the file
and here we have the output so you can
see the first output is balloon and this
output is coming from from right over
here from line number seven
and on the next line I have the output
of crackers this output is coming from
this line line number 11. at line number
11 the variable of box no longer holds
the value of balloons because we have
reassigned the value on our line number
10. the new value that the variable of
box holds right now is just crackers
now for the last time if Lewis wants to
change his mind and this time he wants
to take hats so let's see how we can
reassign the value for the last time let
me put up some comments before we can do
that so for the last time we are going
to reassign the value of box and this
time the new value is going to be hats
and as usual we simply want to print out
the value inside our variable so we can
say hey python I want you to print my
variable of box that's it just save your
file and try to run it for the last time
so as you can see we have the output of
hats and sorry we can see the output of
hats
now this output is coming from our line
number 15. the current value that our
variable of box is holding is hats the
previous values of crackers and balloons
all of these values are now replaced and
the only existing value Inside the Box
variable is hats
till now we have seen how to work and
create variables now let's have a look
at what's happening behind the scenes
so this were the variables that we
created last time we created just one
variable called as box but we assign the
value of balloons crackers and hats to
the same variable now let's see what's
happening behind the scene and how
python is treating all of these
variables
just imagine this is the memory of your
PC and let's see now how python is going
to handle your variables
in Practical terms how python handles
the memory would be very different in a
practical scenario
but right now just have a look at this I
have simplified things so that it's much
more easy for us to understand
so just imagine all of the green area is
the memory of your PC now let's see
what's happening python would read all
of your source code
and as soon as it comes across this line
box is equal to balloons what python is
going to do is python is going to create
a variable called as box inside the
memory and python would look at the
right hand side and it's going to find
balloons so it's going to assign the
value of balloons to the box and all of
these things are happening inside the
memory
so on the next line when you are trying
to print out box you get the output as
balloons
but what happens when python goes to the
next line that is this one where you are
reassigning the value of box to crackers
at that time the value of balloons is
actually taken out and a new value of
crackers is been assigned to the Box
so after your line number six this is
how your box is actually going to look
like so box is going to hold just the
value of crackers that's why online
number seven when we are trying to print
out the value of box we get the value of
crackers
now the same thing is going to continue
on the next line as well when python
comes across this line box is equal to
hats it's going to remove the value of
crackers inside the memory and it's
going to assign a new value of hats and
box would be equal to hats inside the
memory and that's the output that we are
getting from line number 10. till now we
have a much better understanding of
variables and this time we are going to
see what you don't have to do while
creating a variable
you can't just arbitrarily name your
variable there are certain rules for
declaring your variables and that is
what I am going to talk in this video
this is the code from GitHub and I
wanted to click on this file variable
tools I don't want you to waste your
time just watching my type so I'm just
going to copy this file from my GitHub
folder
to my modern python 101 folder and let
me just paste it right inside my zero
two type system
so here is the file and now let me try
to explain what's happening
the first thing that we are going to
talk is something about declaration
Styles there are different styles in
which you can declare a variable
the first style that you can see over
here this is called as camel case the
first alphabet would be in small case
and the next words would start with the
alphabet so this is called as camel case
the next is your Pascal case in Pascal
case as you can see all of the words
they would start with the capital
alphabet
the next one as you can see right over
here on line number 11 this is called as
snake case
online number 12 this is also a variable
but this is used to declare a constant
I'll be talking about constants in the
future
this is also a valid variable and
normally you would use the syntax with
an underscore whenever you want to
declare a private variable I will be
explaining what is a private variable as
well in the future this is also a valid
variable where you can have a number at
the back
and you can mix your numbers with your
snake case or your
camel case or Pascal case or any other
case that you want so till now what I've
done is I have declared a couple of
variables and let's try to print them
out and see how they look on our
terminal let me just run the file
and oh let me first try and clear my
terminal
now let me go back to the file and let
me run it once again so here we can see
we can use different variable styles to
get our output now let's have a look at
the different rules for not declaring a
variable
as you can see online number 29 you
cannot declare a variable which starts
with the number if I just uncomment this
file
it's going to show me an error
similarly on line number 30 let me just
comment this back
so similarly on 30 if we have a hyphen
it's not going to work if we have some
special characters like a comma it's not
going to work if you use a dollar sign
at the front it's also not going to work
and if your variables has a space in
between so that 2 is not going to work
so whenever you are creating or
declaring variables always keep these
things in mind when it comes to your
style you just have to be consistent in
whatever style that you are choosing
as a normal convention whenever we want
to declare any variables or the name of
the functions we would use snake case
but that's just the convention it's not
required
and whenever you want to declare the
name of a class at that time we would be
using the Pascal case
and whenever we want to declare a
constant at that time we would use
everything in uppercase now we have been
making very good progress with our
variables
we have seen how to assign values to our
variables but we have seen how to assign
only a single type of value to our
variables
you can see over here balloons crackers
and hats all of this data types are
called as strings
so whenever you are working with your
Python Programming you always have to
work with some sort of a data and this
data can be classified into different
categories
the first category that we are going to
see is something called as a primitive
data type
so what do I mean by a primitive data
type it simply means that these data
types are already present inside python
the first data type we have already
worked with it's called as a string and
you can see it's always inside a code
for declaring a string you can use
double quotes or you can use a single
code both of them are valid syntax the
next one is called as an integer so you
can see we have whole numbers so 45 is a
kind of integer the next one would be a
float whenever you have some decimal
places it's called as a float inside
python
and the last one is called as a Boolean
Boolean can have only two types either
it can be true or it can be a false
now let's go back to our code editor and
create some of this basic primitive data
types
so let's create a new file inside my
folder 0 to type system I am going to
create a new file and I'm going to name
it as primitive data types Dot
p y
let me add some comments as well
now let's start creating our variables
first let us create a variable for
holding our string and I'm going to call
it as my string that's it so my string
is my variable and it's going to hold
the value of Lewis
let me spell it right
the next variable would be my integer my
end for short it's going to be 45
next one would be my
float it would be 3.14 the next one
would be my bull it stands for my
Boolean data and this time I am going to
assign it the value of true
make sure you always use the T with the
capital T
and that's it we have declared our
variables and we have assigned the
variables with the primitive data types
now let's try to print one by one so I
want to say first I want to print my my
string let me just copy and paste it now
the next thing that I want to print
would be my integer
next let me print out my float
and the last I want to print out my
Boolean value
just save the file and let me run the
file inside my terminal and here we have
the output Lewis 45
3.14 and true the last thing that I want
to discuss in this video is about your
styling
for example you can see right here
single quotes is also a valid string and
if you use double quotes
it's also a valid string so which style
should you use basically you can use any
style but you have to make sure that you
are consistent throughout your code base
in order to avoid such situations when
you're working in a large team the
python Community has come up with some
of the style formatters and one of the
style format is called as black
so if you remember at the beginning we
have installed a couple of optional
dependencies and one of the dependency
was called as black if you have not
installed then you can simply open up a
terminal
let me clear all of this
and you can install the dependency by
simply typing pip
install and black
and this will install the optional
dependency
black is a code formatter and we are
going to use black to format our code so
that it is consistent throughout
the first thing that I want you to do is
I want you to open up the settings for
visual studio code on a Mac you can do
that by typing command and a comma I
think on our Windows it should be
controlled and a comma
so this is my settings file and I want
you to type
save
and the first option that I can see over
here is called as format on Save I want
you to select this now again go back
search for black
so here you can see the first option
python formatting black path make sure
you have black right over here
and that's it
just close your settings file
and
let me save this file it's saying that
format autopape is not installed install
no I don't want to use that one I want
to use black so I'm just going to click
on this one use black
and that's it now if I come back to this
and if I put a single quotes
now just watch what happens when I save
my file
it automatically formats from a single
code to a double quote black is a really
useful utility and we would be using
black so that all of our styling is
similar
since we know a little bit more about
strings let's try and see how we can
output the string in our desired format
this is also called as string formatting
let me create a new file inside my
folder
and I'm going to name the file as string
formatting dot pi
let me put up a comment at the top what
I want to show in this video is how we
can have a desired string output
don't worry if the concept sounds a
little strange it will get cleared in
just a couple of seconds suppose I want
to print a statement saying that hello
and followed by a variable
and that variable can hold a name for
example you can say hello Lewis or you
can say hello Chico or some of the name
so let me first create a variable called
as name and let me assign it a value of
Lewis
now let's see how to format this string
and get an output as hello Lewis
let me
collapse my sidebar and here I can say
print
and I can put my codes but before my
quotes I need to add one more alphabet
called as F that means I want to have a
formatted string and here I can say
hello and I want to print the name over
here
so I am going to use curly brackets and
inside the curly brackets I can place my
variable so I can say name let's save
the file and try to run it
and here we have we have the output as
hello Lewis
there is one more format of doing this
we can simply say print and then we can
say
hello
you can put a comma followed by the
variable that you want to print so I can
say name
just save a file and let me run it one
more time
so as you can see we have the same
output
but normally you will see me using a
formatted string so let me just take out
the second example I'm not going to use
this kind of syntax
now let's see how we can output a string
saying that Lewis is Dash and dash years
old and dash and dash has to be filled
by an variable
so I can create a variable called as age
and I can say age is 13 and here I want
to print Lewis is 13 years old so I can
use a print statement again I am going
to use a formatted string so F and
quotes then inside my curly brackets the
first variable that I want to print is
the name so name goes over here
so Lewis is then I want to place the age
right over here is 13
years old
that's it just save your file and try to
run it one more time and we have the
output Lewis is 13 years old
let's do a couple of more practice over
here
suppose Lewis has a dog and then let me
spell it right
and the name of the dog is Chico
and this time we want to print out Lewis
has a dog named Chico so you can say
print again your formatted string your
curly brackets your placeholder for your
name so Lewis
has
a dog named
and the dog variable goes right over
here
and that's it
let us try to run the file
and we have the output Lewis has a dog
named Chico
let's do it for the last time suppose
Lewis also has a cat
and the name of the cat is Coco
so let me copy and paste this line
and I can say Lewis
has a cat name and the variable of cat
would go right over here
let me save the file and let me run it
for the last time
and here we have the output Lewis has a
cat named Coco
we are making really good progress but
this time I want to make a program that
would have a bug inside it
so let me create a file inside my folder
and I'm going to name the file as my
first bug Dot py
bug actually means that we have some
sort of an undesired behavior in our
program
so let me put up some comments okay now
let's get started with this one
let's create a variable called as box
and let's assign the value of balloons
to it
and let me print out a formatted
statement saying that
box contains
and the variable of box goes right here
let me just run this file and we have
the output that the box contains
balloons
now just watch closely what happens I
can also say box
is equal to 10.
now this really doesn't make any sense
why would I want to store 10 inside
balloons balloons is a string 10 is an
integer
but if you try to print this we are
going to get an output
let me copy and paste this line from
here
just blow this let me save it and let me
try to run the program
and we have the output box contains 10.
and this is because python isn't
dynamically typed language and this was
the point where I really struggled when
I was learning python
but you don't have to worry about this
you can easily solve this problem by
thinking in types in this video I am
going to introduce to you a concept
which is called as type hinting let me
put up a command so what type ending
really means is we always want to
associate a type with our variables
and this will really help us to create
robust programs and to take care of all
of the bugs before we can actually run
the program now let's start thinking in
types let's create a variable called as
food
and let us assign it a value of milk
now I want to tell python that food
should always contain the value of a
string it cannot contain any other value
and the way to do it is by using a type
hint
you can write a type in right over here
let me take it a little
you can add a type and try to here so
after the name of the variable just put
a colon then we can see this variable
has to be of the type of a string and
this you can write Str so Str means
food variable is of the type of a string
and that's it and let us print out a
statement saying that
let us do a formatted string we can say
Lewis is going to drink inside the curly
brackets we can see food
and I'll just save it and run your file
and we have the output Lewis is going to
drink milk
we can reassign the variable food from
milk to
and then we can say
Lewis is going to eat
let me save the file and let me try to
run it and we have the output Lewis is
going to eat eggs
now this time if I say food is equal to
false
let me just copy and paste this line so
let me just paste it right over here
save the file and let me run it for the
last time
but watch this
we still have the output it's saying
that Lewis is going to eat false false
and doesn't make any sense over here so
this is what we call as a bug this is an
undesired Behavior we don't want to
assign faults to our food
the way to take care of this is by using
one more plugin which is called as my pi
first thing we need to install my Pi I
hope you installed my Pi in the
beginning where I was discussing about
the optional dependencies
if not you can just open up your
terminal
let me clear all of this
and you can install my Pi by saying pip
install follow followed by my pack and
that's it
after installing my Pi I want you to
open up the settings again you can open
up the settings by
by pressing command and comma on a Mac
it should be Ctrl and comma on Windows
and here I want you to type Wi-Fi
and I want you to click on this python
linking my Pi enabled
just click on this one
and that's it now you can see the code
editor is highlighting false and it's
saying that we have some sort of issue
over here if you just hover over false
it's going to say incompatible types in
assignment
expression has Type Bool variable has
Type string what it means is variable
has a type of Str so if you refer the
line number 20 we have assigned the type
of string to our variable that's what
this error is trying to tell us we have
declared the variable as string but in
the expression we are trying to assign
it a value of Boolean that's why it's
not going to work
or rather it's going to work because
python isn't dynamically typed language
but at least in your code editor is
going to show you that something is
wrong so you can see on the top as well
it's showing an error right over here as
well
but if you see the file and if you try
to run the file one more time
it's going to execute
you can see we are executing our Python
program
so this is the thing with python python
is in dynamically typed language and
it's not going to enforce the data types
on the runtime
that is why to prevent such kind of bugs
we are going to use my pie and we are
going to use type hinting everywhere
let's try to do some more practice with
our primitive data types
so let's create one more program right
over here
and let me create a file and the name of
the file is just practice.py let me put
up some comments as usual
and let me collapse my sidebar
now this as you can see Triple codes
these are also a valid comment and
normally you would use triple quotes
whenever you want to write some kind of
a documentation inside the string but
the thing about this triple chords is
you can also create strings and you can
also do a string formatting by using
triple quotes we are going to see an
example of this right in this video here
is the situation Lewis wants to open up
a pizza shop and he needs to write a
program for accepting orders
now this is a very important tip before
you always start coding first you always
and always need to visualize now let's
just try to visualize our pizza shop and
let us try to think what all variables
we would require
the first and the most obvious is we
would require a variable for customer
that's the place where we would save the
customer data
the second variable could be a pizza
base maybe you would like to have a thin
base or a base filled with cheese or
whatever you prefer
the next variable could be for storing
the pizza size maybe it's like a 12 inch
pizza or maybe it's like a 14 or 16 inch
pizza so we would require a variable for
storing the size as well if it is a
pizza it also needs to have some kind of
a topping so we would need one more
variable for topping one more for cheese
and one more for the price
so this is how we would first visualize
the entire program and only after
visualizing your program you would start
coding
I will come to this concept A little
later in detail but right now let's get
going and let's create some of the
variables let us create the first
variable called as customer
the type of customer is going to be a
string so let us try write Str and the
name of the customer would be CC
let me put CS Capital
the next variable would be for my pizza
base so I can say my pizza base
again the type is going to be string
this time I want to have a thin base the
next one would be for my
Pizza size
now I bought my pizza size to be an
integer suppose I want to eat a 12 inch
pizza so that's what this is going to
indicate
the next one would be for my topping
topping has to be a string and I want to
have some toppings of olives
the next one let us create a Boolean
saying that extra cheese
and let us create
the typing in so the extra cheese
variable is going to be of the type of
Bool so the customer can say yes they
want false if they don't want in case
they want extra cheese then we can say
true otherwise it's going to be false
the last one is going to be price
now since price is going to contain
decimal values so we can say price is
going to be a float and we can say this
is for 8.99 dollars
just save it and now let's try to print
all of these values in our terminal let
me put up one more comment over here
now since this program is for accepting
pizza orders let's try to write print
statements that would make some sense
so the first one I can say
received
order from followed by
the name of the customer
let me save it the next line we can
print some of the pizza details so we
can say print again for the formatted
string and then we can see
the pizza base would be the pizza base
then we can say size
is going to be Pizza size in inches
followed by
toppings
and I can write toppings over here
save this
now let us try to print if the customer
wants extra cheese or not so we can
again say is
extra
cheese required
and let us put the value right over here
extra cheese
and the last thing we want to print is
going to be the price so we can say
bill amount
is going to be the price so I can put
the price right over here
let me run the program and here we have
the output
received order from CC let me take this
a little down
and
and now we can start comparing
so you can see we have declared the name
of the customer as CC that's what we
have right over here
the base of the pizza is thin so thin is
what we want the size is 12 and the
topping is volumes
do we require extra cheese yes we
require and the total amount is 8.99
dollars
let us have a look at one more
alternative syntax of using formatted
string let me put up a command right
here
now this time I am going to construct an
entire string which will hold all of
these values
in order to save all of this data let me
create a new variable by the name of
order
details is going to be of the type of
string
and now this is the interesting part we
can create a formatted string outside
the print statement as well so I can say
F and I can put
my comma right over here
but I'm going to use triple quotes
because I want to create my string which
is going to be in multiple lines
so if you just compare your output you
can see we have multiple lines on the
first line we have the statement for
received order the next line has the
pizza details and so on so I want my
string to be multi-line that's the
reason why I'm using triple quotes right
over here now between these triple codes
let's start adding our values now this
is pretty simple I just have to copy
from above let me just
paste this inside
the same thing for this as well
please note that I am not copying the
inverted commas because I already have
them outside
let me put this line
this one as well
and this as well
so what we have essentially done from
line number 34 to line number 39 is we
have created an attached string and we
have saved that string to a variable and
the name of the variable is called as
order details
on the next line we can simply print out
the order details so we can say simply
print my order details
and that's it let's try to run this file
and we have the output
let me just comment all of this for a
moment so that the output is much more
clear
Let Me Clear My terminal again go back
and let me try to run the file
so now you can see our formatted string
is also working
let us have a look at one more very
simple alternative
we just saw that we can create a
multi-line string by using triple codes
and assign that string to a variable
but let us ask the question do we really
require a variable maybe not
we can simply print out the entire
statement so what I'm going to do is I'm
just copying all of this formatted
string
let me copy all of this let me go down
let me write print and inside my print
function I'm just going to paste
everything as it is
that's it let me just save the file
and let me run it
and as you can see we have the desired
output you can use any of the string
formatting style there is no right and
wrong method in this one
welcome to a new section
this section is all about decisions
decisions and more decisions
and we are going to learn how to take
Decisions by the use of flow control
mechanisms that means there are multiple
flow control statements such as if and
else while while and do and some other
statements so we will have a look at all
of this control flow statements
first thing that I want you to do is go
back to your code editor and let's
create a new folder right over here
let me name it as 0 3 flow control
and the first file that I am going to
create over here is called as driving
license Dot py
let me put up a comment as usual now
let's see what's happening Lewis wants
to drive a car and he wants to know if
he can apply for a driving license or
not
so first let me declare a variable
called as age is going to be of the type
of integer and let me assign a value of
13 to it the first flow control
statement that I am going to introduce
in this video is the if and else
statement suppose the legal driving age
in your country is 16. so right now we
can create a very simple if and else
blocks we can say if
the age
is less than 16
. in that scenario I want to print out
you are not
eligible for a
license
but what happens if you are more than 16
in that case you are eligible for
license
so on the next line we can simply say
else so that means you are actually more
than 16 years old
and let me copy and paste it right over
here
here I can say you are eligible for a
license
let's have a look at what's exactly
happening
python is going to read your file from
top to the bottom
on line number six it is going to create
a new variable called as age and it is
going to assign the value of third into
it
when python comes to line number 12 it's
going to try to evaluate this statement
right over here
what's happening in this statement
my age is 13 13 is less than 16 so this
condition on line number 12 is true
and since this condition is true python
is going to print whatever which is
inside the if block you can see the line
number 13 is indented towards the right
so this is a tab space so that means
this line belongs to the if log so
python is simply going to print out you
are not eligible for a license
and after printing this block python is
actually going to skip the else part
because it's not the case with us and
python will go to line number 16 where
it will exit from the program let me
just save the file and let me try to run
it
so as you can see we have the output you
are not eligible for a license
now let's try to imagine what happens
after a couple of years
so after a couple of years the age would
be 19. now let me copy and paste the
exact same flow control statement and
let me put it right over here
let me save it and let me try to run the
file
so the second time we get the output you
are eligible for a license
and this is the case because on line
number 21 you can see now Lewis is 19
years old
let's go back to our code
one thing that I want you to understand
is it's not necessary to have an else
block we can simply write an if block so
let me put up a comment
and let me just copy and paste this
block
right over here
let me
comment this let me
comment all of this
so the only thing we have in our file
right now is this variable age
which we declared as 13 online number
six and we reassign the value on line
number 21
and we have this if an else block now I
am going to take out the else block and
I'm going to
left indent this line
so that means we do not have an else
Block in this condition
this is just the if block and this is
the next line let's see what's happening
let me scale the file and try to run the
file one more time
ah so in this case I am getting the
output you are eligible for a license
now let's see what's exactly happening
when python comes to this line land
number 32 it's again going to evaluate
this statement
in our case the age is 19 so 19 is not
less than 16 and since this condition
will evaluate to false python is going
to skip the if Law And since we are
going to skip the if block python is not
going to print this line it will simply
move to the next line on the next line
that is on line number 35 we are simply
going to print out you are eligible for
a license and that's what we get on our
terminal you can check the terminal one
more time
let me
let me clear up all of these things let
me run the file one more time
and that's it you have the output of you
are eligible for a license you can also
chain multiple if and as blocks let me
show you an example for that
now suppose after too many years Lewis
is 100 years old
let me just go and copy the code from
above so let me just copy
this one
and
right over here
and let me uncomment all of this
here we can start chaining our if and
else blocks
so on the next line I can say else and
if in Python we write it as e l i f that
means else and if
so the next condition that I want to
check is my age
greater than 100
in that case I want to print out
you are too old to get a license
let me comment this one
now let me try to run the file
oh but what is this
we are getting an output saying that you
are eligible for a license but that's
not we want we want to print out you are
too old to get a license
and we have a small bug and that bug is
exactly on line number 45.
we are saying that if the age is greater
than 100
but right now our age is 100
so in order to make this statement true
we have to say if the age is more than
or equal to 100
now let's save it and let us try to run
the file one more time
and this time we have a proper output
saying that you are too old to get a
license
till now we have seen very simple if and
else blocks let's try to expand our
knowledge
and this time let me create a new file
by the name of alien license dot pi
here is the situation Lewis desperately
wants to drive a car and he hears that
in a planet called as zorton there is no
age limit for getting a license so let's
see how we can address this situation
let us create a couple of variables the
first one would be for age
of the type of integer age is 13
the next one for a planet
Planet the type would be string and let
me assign it to Earth initially
let me introduce to you a little more
complex statements by using and and or
statements
so let's start writing our compound if
and else blocks along with and and or
the first case would be if the age is
less than 16 and
the planet
is
Earth
in that case I simply want to print out
that you are not eligible for a license
on Earth here you can see I have double
equal to that simply means that this is
a comparison operator we assist and
compare if the value inside the variable
planet is equal to Earth or not
now let's move on to the next blog for
the else statement here we can say else
if
the age is greater than 16
and if the planet
is again Earth
in that case I want to print out that
you are eligible for a license on Earth
but what happens if both of these values
are false what happens if the planet is
zorton or what happens if the age is
less than 16 but you are trying to apply
for license consultant
let's try to create one more condition
over here let us write an if and less
block right over here so we can say else
if
if the age is less than 16
and if the planet
is zorton
in that case I want to print out
you can apply for resort in your license
because it's valid in the planet's Orton
let me save the file
and let me try running it and let us see
what output we are getting
so I am getting the output that you are
not eligible for license on Earth
so let's get back to the code and let us
evaluate what's exactly happening let us
begin with evaluating all of the if and
LC block
let's start with this one on line number
13 let me put up a comment over here
so this is how the evaluation is taking
place
python is going to compare is the age
less than 16 yes my age is 13 13 is less
than 16 so the first statement is going
to evaluate to true so that comes right
here
the next operator that we have is and so
and comes right over here
now python will go to the last statement
it's going to compare is planet equal to
Earth so as you can see on land number
seven we have assigned the value of
Earth to planet
hence this statement also evaluates to
True Earth is equal to Earth so that's
why we have a true over here and since
we have two truths this entire statement
on line number 13 evaluates to true so
we can print out you are not eligible
for a license on Earth and right after
this let me put up one more comment just
to explain what's happening and since
this if statement on line number 13
evaluates to true
the execution is going to stop right at
this point python is not going to go to
the next alternative block python will
directly jump to line number 22 and it
will exit from our program so that's
what is exactly happening so let me put
up some more comments right here
execution does not reach over here the
same thing for this one as well let's do
a small exercise
on line number 14 we have tried to
evaluate the statement
let us try to evaluate the statements on
line number 18 and line number 21 as
well let me put up a comment right here
now let's try to evaluate this statement
my current age is 13. as you can see on
line number six we have assigned the age
as 13
so the first statement age is 13 13 is
greater than 16 no it's not so we have
false right over here
the next operator is and so and comes
right over here
the next statement is planet equal to a
yes my planet is equal to what so we
have a true
but in this case we have one false and
one true
so this statement is going to evaluate
to forms let's see what's happening on
line number 22 let me put up a comment
right over here as well
so as you can see the age is 13 13 is
less than 16 so we have a true condition
over here
now the planet
the planet currently is Earth and Earth
is not equal to zorton so we have faults
over here
one true and one Falls is always going
to give you an false statement
we can actually try to improve our logic
at this time by introducing an or
statement remember insult and even if
you are less than 16 you are still
eligible for a license
so we don't have to check this condition
at all we can simply say if you are age
16
or if the planet is rotten in that case
you can apply for resort in your license
in this case the evaluation will be
different my age is less than 16 it's
true and right here instead of n we have
an or condition
the next is planet is resultant so
that's again going to be false true or
false
now this time whenever we have an or
condition and we have one true and one
false it's always going to evaluate to
True since we have an or statement the
true wins over the false
but since the first block is executing
we are not going to execute this block
and just for your reference let me put
all of the and and all tables right over
here
so these are all of the and and or
scenarios
but you can do much better
if you are in confusion
just open up your terminal and I want
you to open up the IPython shell
remember we have installed IPython at
the beginning of the series if you have
not installed you can simply install by
typing pip
installed
I python
what happens is python actually comes
with a shell you can simply type python
this takes you inside a python shell and
here you can start writing python
commands for example I can say OnePlus 2
and I get the output of 3.
you can exit this Shell by typing Ctrl
and D
now I python is a slightly better
version of this and it's slightly more
interactive so I prefer to use IPython
shell
just type IPython and go inside the
shell
let me clear up the terminal
and whenever you are confused what
statement evaluates to what you can
simply type right over here here you can
type what happens if I have one
condition which is true and the next
condition which is also a true
we get a true but what happens if I have
one true and one false condition
we have a false
what happens if I have one true
or false
then also we get a true
what happens if I have a false and also
false
we get a false
let us try to evaluate one last
condition
what happens if I have a false
and
false in that case it also evaluates to
false so you can always come back to
this iPad and shell and see how the
statements are being evaluated now
suppose Lewis migrates to zorton then
let's see what's happening
let me put up a comment now Lewis is no
longer staying on Earth he's staying in
Jordan
let me copy and paste all of this
and put it right over here
I am not going to change any of the
logic
let me just run the file as usual and
let us see what output we are getting
oh first I need to exit this you can
exit this by pressing Ctrl and D yes I
want to exit let me clear up my terminal
go back to the file
let me save it one more time and let me
try running it it looks like we have a
small bug and I exactly know what we did
wrong
at this point we did not reassign the
value of planet to zorton that's what we
need to do so we can say map planet now
is
certain that's it just save your file
and let us try to run the file one more
time
now we have the desired output
you can apply for resulting in license
now let's try to see how the statements
are being evaluated so let's see what's
happening on line number 48
this statement Planet equal to Earth
this time it's going to evaluate as
false
true and false is going to evaluate true
or false and so we are not going to
execute this block
let's go to the new block age is greater
than 16 no it's false Planet equal to
Earth no it's false because we are
staying in zorton
false and false we have a false so
python will go to the last condition
age is less than 16 true
Planet equal result and yeah it's also
true
true or true
equals to true and that's the reason why
we have this output as you can apply for
result Indian license let's try to see
the next Concept in the flow control
mechanism
and this time I am going to introduce
you A New Concept which is called as
looping we can iterate over things that
is called as looping and we can iterate
by using a for Loop let me create a new
file as usual and let me show what I'm
talking about
here I am going to create a new file and
I am going to name it as printmyname.pi
and let me put up a command
so this is the situation this time now
since Lewis is staying in Jordan
he has to do things in a shortening way
in zorton they don't print your name on
a single line
they want to print each and every
character of your team on a different
line so let's see how we can do that
first let me create a variable for name
and let me assign the type as string
the name is Lewis and this time let me
introduce you One More Concept which is
called as the for Loop and we are going
to use the for Loop to iterate over all
of the characters in Lewis it simply
means that we want to go from one
alphabet to another throughout this
string creating a for Loop is very
simple we can simply say
for
character inside my name I simply want
to print out
the character let me put up a comment
right here
so on each iteration we are just going
to print a character let me save the
file and let me try running it here we
have the output
we have each and every character on a
new line
and we are doing this by using a very
simple for Loop now let's see what's
happening inside each of the iteration
here we are saying for character in name
first time the character is L you can
see right over here we get the output of
L
you can write over here as well
the next character is o u i n s
so on each iteration we are printing a
single character on new line
let's try to move on and learn One More
Concept for flow control mechanisms
this time I am going to show you the
while loop
for this as usual let me create a new
file
and let me name it as guess Planet dot
pi
and this time this is the situation
now since Lewis has migrated to zodan
his friend from Earth they are a little
curious to know where he is so Lewis
decides to write a program that will
make his friends guess the name of the
planet for this simple program I am
going to create three variables
first variable would be as a Boolean so
I can say
correct guess this would be an Boolean
initially let me assign it the value of
faults
the next Boolean for
guess
so this is the place where we would be
storing all of the gases that his
friends are going to make initially it's
simply going to be a blank string and
that's it
the next one for the planet so I can say
planet of the type of string
this is going to be zorton
let us have a look at the first
alternative
the first thing that we want to do right
over here is we want to create a loop
and we want his friends to keep on
guessing till the time they get the
planet right
first let us see how we can get the
input from his friends
the way to get an input is by using
another inbuilt function by the name of
input so we can say input
and I can write a prompt over here
Lewis says that can we guess my planet
and I want to save the input inside my
variable of guess so I'm just going to
the left
the input has to be saved inside my
variable of guess so my guess comes
towards the left
let me save this and let us try to run
this and see what's happening
let me also print out the guess on the
next line
now let's try to run this file and see
what's happening
so as you can see I am getting the
prompt Lewis says can you guess my
planet
let me write as Mars and we have the
output
now this output of mass is coming from
this line from line number 15. if you
are having some issues while running
this file from the code Runner then what
we can do is I want you to open up your
settings
let me collapse my terminal
here I want you to write code Runner
and let us scroll a little down I want
you to
go a little more down
and I wanted to check this option run in
terminal so make sure that this option
is checked or what you can do is you can
simply use the python command
let's try to navigate inside the folder
now this time the folder was 0 3 so you
can go inside this folder and you can
say hey python I want you to run my
program which is called as guest planet
and we have the prompt and this time it
can be Pluto
and we have the output of Pluto let's
get back to our program
here we can create our event and else
blocks so we can say if the guess
is equal to my current planet
then I want to print out
all right guess Lewis is a Jordan
else we can say
that I want to print out
Lewis says it's a wrong choice I want
you to try again
let me see this and let us try to run
this one more time
suppose my planet is Mercury
and we get the output Lewis says wrong
choice try again let me clear up my
terminal and let me try this program one
more time this time I am going to write
as zorton what's this we still have the
output saying that it's a wrong choice
but that's not the case we have written
certain
the issue is this that we have written
zorton with a z which is in the small
case but we have saved planet with a z
which is in the upper case
the point that I want to convey is all
of the strings are going to be case
sensitive inside python your upper case
z is not equal to your lowercase z
let us see how we can handle this
situation
we can go back to our if block right
here
and we can actually convert from capital
Z to a lower Z in fact we are going to
convert the entire string to a lowercase
string and you can do that by using an
inbuilt function
now this function Works only with
strings and since we have two strings
guess and planet we can use that
function right over here so we can
simply say guess I simply want to lower
it and after this I want you to put
brackets so this means I want to invoke
the function of lower I will come to
functions a little future in the series
but right now just go with the flow so
what this statement is doing is
is going to take the guess and it is
going to convert it from whatever case
it may be to an lower case we want to do
the same thing for Planet as well so
here we can say lower along with the
brackets
just save it
and now let's try running this file
let me write zorton with a smaller case
z
and this time we have the output right
guess Lewis is at Jordan now let's try
to improve the logic even more we don't
want to exit this program
we want to ask his friends to keep on
guessing till the time they get the
guess right
and we can do this by wrapping all of
our logic inside a while block so let's
see how to do that
on line number 16 let me make some space
and uh
here I can say while
my
correct guess
is not true so that means till the time
we don't get a correct guess I simply
want to keep on looping so let me put a
colon over here
and after this I want to indent all of
this if and S blocks one tab space
inside
so now if an else blocks belong to the
while loop
let me save it
and let me try to run the file but we
have a small bug let me run the file
first and then you will understand
what's wrong with it
so here it goes
it's asking me for the name of the
planet I am writing marks
so what's this it's keep on looping
something's wrong with our program let
me stop it by pressing Ctrl and C
the issue is we are just keeping on
looping the first thing python will go
online by 18 it's going to see is my
Mars equal to my Jordan it's not so it
will go to the next line
it says that Lewis says wrong choice try
again so this is what we are getting
and since our wild condition is not true
as you can see on land number six do we
have a correct guess false
and that's the reason why python will
again go back to line number 18 it's
going to see Mars is equal to Zordon no
so it's again going to go on a line
number 21 and print out Lewis says wrong
choice try again the way to come out of
this while loop is we need to have a
circuit breaking mechanism that's why I
have created this variable called as
correct guess
so right over here after line number 19
since we have a correct guess this time
let us reassign the value of correct
guess
to true
now let's try running this file
oh let me
clear up my terminal now let's try the
file one more time
so it's saying that can you guess my
Planet let me see as Mars
oh no we again have a issue let's see
what's wrong this time
now the issue is we are not asking for a
new input after we get a wrong guess
that's why we never have a correct guess
in order to correct this let me take
this line let me cut it out and I want
to paste it right over here
let me indent
so we have a proper variable
we don't require this pin statement now
let me take it out
and let us see if we can have a running
program let me put the input as Pluto
is saying wrong choice now this time it
is again asking me for an input and is
actually waiting for my input let me
write Mars no it's not going to work
Earth no it's not going to work
let me write zorton
and that's it we have the right guess
let me add some comments so that it's
much more easy for us to understand
what's happening the first comment goes
right over here
so on line number 16 we are just asking
the users for their input the next thing
that we are doing which is right over
here
we are just lower casing all of the
strings so that we have a much more
correct comparison then as a circuit
breaking mechanism we are setting the
current guess variable to true so this
is what is happening right here
inside the else block if the condition
is false then we are going to print the
statement and just to give it a small
cosmetic touch I am going to put a line
just below this
just save a file and let me try running
this file for one more time
so my first planet would be Mercury
we have a very nice output saying that
wrong choice and then we have a line
below it
now this time it's going to be zorton
with a lowercase z
and we have the right output there is
one more alternative way we don't need
to declare this variable all the time we
can simply work directly with the while
loop let me put up a comment and then
let me show how it works let me copy and
paste everything from above so let me
just copy this
let me go right over here
let me paste it
I also want to comment all of this
once inside the while loop we have one
more alternative which can act like our
circuit breaker here online number 33 I
can simply say while true
this means that I always want you to
start the value because true is always
true
and on line number 40
instead of saying correct guess is equal
to true I can say
break
so that means as soon as we have a
condition which is right I simply want
to break out of the value
let me save it and let me run it and see
if it is working or not okay so my first
planet would be Earth
a wrong choice the next planet is zorton
and that's the right choice let's try to
learn the next flow control statement
and this time we are going to learn the
match statement so let me open up my
sidebar and let me create a new file by
the name of
match color dot py and let me put up a
comment
so this is what we want to do
volt Island Resort and Lewis he has
packed a lot of stuff and we want to
check if he has anything that matches
our favorite color
and we are going to do this by using a
match operator
now please keep in mind that match is a
brand new operator which was introduced
in the version 3.10 so in case if we
have any version below 3.10 it's not
going to work so please make sure you
have any version 3.10 or higher here
what we can do is we can create a
variable called as
my favorite color
and we can ask the user for an input so
we can say input
and here we can see
enter your
favorite
color
what's wrong with this
spelling okay so enter your favorite
color
now let's try to print
the favorite color
let's try to run this file and let's see
if it's working or not
so it's asking me for my favorite color
I say it's black
and I have the right output
now let's see how the match operator is
going to work we can write that I want
to match on my
favorite color
and the first case would be
in case if I get the input as black
in that case I want to print out a
statement saying something like
Lewis has a
black
t-shirt
now suppose the user input
is red then maybe in that case I want to
print something like
Lewis has a
red car
suppose my favorite color is yellow
the code the colons has to be outside
the codes
and I want to print out
Lewis has a yellow
shoes
now in case the favorite color is green
in that case I want to print out
blue is has a
green hat
but what happens if we don't get a match
so in that case
we can write like this case followed by
an underscore so that means the default
case would be this one in case we don't
get the favorite color right here we can
simply print out that
Lewis has
nothing in and let me put my color right
over here
followed by the word of color
just save it let me save the file and
let me try to run it one more time
let me give the input of green
it's working
let me try to run the program one more
time
This Time Again green
but you can see we are getting the
output as Lewis has nothing in the green
color
now this is again because I have entered
green where G is capital
while inside the match operator you can
see I am using a lowercase G and you
already know that strings are case
sensitive inside python let us tackle
this issue and it's going to be a very
simple thing
we can either write over here I want to
match my favorite color and I want to
lowercase it first and then I want to
match
or we can say
on this line I want to say that my
favorite color should be equal to my
favorite color but in the lower case
or even better what we can do is we can
write it right over here Dot
lower
and let me take out this line
and that's it if you're wondering why I
don't have a type annotation right over
here
and the reason is just hover over input
and if you read the documentation it's
saying that the output is of the type of
a string we will look at the syntax when
we learn a little bit more about
functions your my Pi plugin is smart
enough to infer that the variable
favorite color is of the type of a
string and since your favorite color is
a string we can apply the lower method
on our string you can always
write the type over here and it's not
going to hurt
so this is also a valid syntax let me
run the file for the last time and let
us check what's happening
now this time I am going to say red with
the capital r
now it's a match Lewis has the red car
till now we have learned a lot and I
think it's time for us to start writing
our game
so what I've done in the background I've
created a file by the name of game save
sort and underscore one you can see on
the tab right over here as well and I've
added a couple of comments
let us see now what we are supposed to
do inside this game
now as we remember Lewis is staying at
Jordan but this time zotan is under
attack Thanos has arrived and he is
going to attack zorton now fortunately
Lewis can call his Avenger French from
Earth and so he has made a call Avengers
has received his call and they I want to
send four of the Avengers to save zorton
the four Avengers who are going to save
zorton are Iron Man Black Widow
Spider-Man and Hulk each of the Avengers
have their own attack and power and they
have to fight with Thanos in order to
save zorton
but we have a couple of conditions
Avengers can only attack in pairs so
that means at each given point of time a
single Avenger cannot attack Thanos
because Thanos is much more powerful so
Avengers have to team up in pairs of two
and they have to attack Thanos
and while doing all of this Avengers
only have three chances to kill Thanos
otherwise Thanos will kill the Avengers
and we will lose the game sounds
interesting isn't it
but the first thing that I want you to
do is not write the code Yes you heard
right I don't want you to write the code
first
I want you to understand what we have to
do and then you can start writing code
in order to understand better I want to
introduce to you a very simple concept
which is called as VOC dtp it's a very
simple concept that I've come up with
and the entire concept is divided into
two parts so as you can see the first
part is VOC the second part is dtp
so the first part simply means to
visualize outline and code the next part
would be debug test and polish
for now we would be concentrating on the
first part visualize outline and code
so as a programmer always remember first
you always always need to visualize
before you can code you don't have to
write code immediately so let's start
visualize what's going to happen inside
of a game
since it's a game we already have some
characters so let's try to visualize the
different characters that we have
we have two main categories one category
is for the super heroes and the next
category is for the super villains
we have a specific list for the
superheroes and those are Iron Man Black
Widow Spiderman and Hulk and for the
super villains right now we have only a
single super villain and his name is
Thanos so this is where we just simply
try to visualize how the game would look
like
and now we know the characters in The
Next Step let's try to outline how this
characters would look like and how they
would work
so coming to the next point of outline
since we have characters all of the
characters should have some properties
they should also have some constraints
and we should also have some sort of a
logic I have already specified that our
Avengers have a fire or an attack power
but if we have an attack power then we
would also require life and having a
property of life would make our job much
more simple and we can Implement a very
simple Logic for the game now this game
also comes with a couple of constraints
that we can't forget
the constants are the first one that we
saw Avengers can only attack in parents
so at a given time only two Avengers can
attack a single Avenger cannot attack
and more than two Avengers also cannot
attack and Avengers only have 3 chances
of defeating Thanos
so this is where we are just trying to
outline how our characters are going to
look like the last and the most
important part is
can we come up with some kind of logic
where we can simulate the attack now
let's go back to our code editor and let
us see how we can translate all of these
things in our step number three so as
you can see the step number three is to
actually code
in Step number three what we are going
to do is we either is going to translate
all of these things to a logic and that
logic would be coded with python now
let's start with declaring our variables
if you refer our outline we have a
property and the properties are for your
fire or attack power and one for the
life
so let's go right over here and let us
start creating some of our variables so
we can see
the attack power of Iron Man
so I can see Iron Man
attack
power
and just suppose it to be 250
now let's start thinking in types
now since it's a power I have to do some
sort of calculations so it must be
either an integer or in fluid
for the sake of Simplicity I am keeping
it as integer the next thing that I want
you to remember is
since this is an attack power we are not
going to change the attack power in the
future so no matter even if we are
losing or we are winning the game the
attack power of Iron Man is always going
to be 250 so just as a stylistic
preference I want to name my variable
everything in uppercase
so this would denote that I want to have
a constant instead of a variable
now what do I mean by constant a
constant simply means there is some
value which we don't want to change and
that is what we are indicating by
writing everything in the upper case
Now features hover over our variable you
can see on the left we have constant
so that means our code editor knows that
this is a constant but we can go further
and we can improve our typing for this I
am going to import and use something
from an additional package
now what is a package
package is basically some code that the
developers of python have written and
have put all of this code inside a
library which is called as the standard
Library so what I'm going to do is
I want to say I want to go to my
typing package so this package lives
inside the python standard Library
please remember that standard library is
already built into python so from the
package of typing I want to import
finally and we can wrap this integer
inside
finally
now it's very clear that Iron Man attack
power it's not just a variable it's a
constant and we don't want to change the
value of the constant throughout our
program let us repeat the same thing for
Black Widow Spiderman and Hulk as well
the next superhero would be our Black
Widow and she has a power of 180 the
next one would be Spider-Man Spider-Man
has an attack power of 190. the last
superhero would be Hulk and Hulk since
he is the biggest guy he has an attack
power of 300. let me put up some
commands right here so
this is where we are declaring our
constants and on the top let me put up
one more comment so this is the stuff
that we are importing now let's go back
to our outline just to figure it out
what we are supposed to do next
we have defined the attack power now we
also need the life
so let me go to the next line and here I
am going to define the life of Thanos
and the life of Thanos is 1500. as you
can see I don't want the life of Thanos
to be a constant I want it to be a
variable that's why I am declaring
everything in small case
and my my pie is smart enough to infer
that Thanos is of the type of integer or
if you want to be explicit you can
always type int right over here the
reason why I don't want it to be
constant would get much more clear when
we implement the logic for the game now
let's go back to our outline
and here you can see we have a couple of
constraints the first constant is
Avengers can only attack in pairs so let
us go back to our game and I want the
game users the ability to choose our
pairs in order to give this ability I am
going to create one more variable called
as choices and let me assign it the
value of 0. again I don't need to
annotate as integer because my Pi would
be smart enough to infer that my choice
is variable would always be an integer
after this let us create a couple of if
and else blocks and let us start
creating our pairs for our Avengers for
the sake of Simplicity I am just going
to create pairs in line so what I mean
the first pair would be Iron Man and
Black Widow
the second pair would be Black Widow and
Spider-Man
the third pair would be Spider-Man and
Hulk and the fourth pair would be Iron
Man and Hulk but you're free to make the
pairs in whatever choice you want
so here we can say if my choice
is one in that case I simply want to
print out that Iron Man and Black Widow
are attacking Thanos the next choice
would be
Choice number two
and this time I want to print out Black
Widow and Spider-Man are attacking
Thanos
next choice would be three
and this time Spider-Man and Hulk are
attacking Thanos and the last one
if the choice is number four then Hulk
and Iron Man are attacking Thanos while
doing all of this let us not forget that
we want to ask the user for the choice
of The Avengers
so let us Implement that logic and I
want to implement that logic before our
if and else blocks
so here I can since we want to ask the
user for the input we need an input
block
and let us display a prompt message
saying that enter your pair number
we want to assign the input back to our
variable of choice so Choice goes on the
left
and let me save my program but as you
can see we have a small bug so if we
just try to hover
you can see that we have an error saying
that
incompatible types in assignment
expression has type of string variable
has type of integer
so this was what I was telling you about
variable has the type of integer our
variable of choice as you can see on
line number 29 we have declared a
variable called as choice
and the type of this variable is an
integer
but if you hover on input and if you
read the documentation
it is actually giving us a string
so this is where when you start thinking
in types it's going to help you to avoid
a lot of bugs to address this bug it's a
very simple solution
we simply want to convert the string to
an integer
and the way to do that is by using a
cast let me just show you how it is done
so I am going to wrap all of this inside
my brackets
and I want to cast all of this into an
integer
so what this means is my input is going
to give me a string and I want to
convert that string into an integer
right over here
now our types are going to match on the
left is also an integer and on the right
is also an integer now let me see my
program and let me try to run it
suppose I want my pair number two
you can see Black Widow and Spider-Man
are attacking Thanos
let me try to run the file one more time
let me go by pair number four
Hulk and and man are attacking Thanos
so we have some basic logic in place
this time let us display a nice message
to the user informing them of all of the
pairs which are there inside the game
so before I ask the input I want to
display a nice message for this I am
going to create a new variable called as
message and I am going to assign some
string value to it so let me create a
variable called as message
and I'm going to assign some value to it
and this is the value
so please note that I am creating a
multi-line string by using triple quotes
and just before we can show the choices
I want to print out the message let us
do that right over here so we can say
print and my message let me save the
file and let's try to run it
and this time we have a very nice
message and we can see all of the pairs
who can attack Thanos
this time let us go with the pair number
three
and we get the output that
Spider-Man and Hulk are attacking Thanos
let me clear up my terminal
and let us go back to our code
now since this message is never going to
change I can actually make it as a
constant so let me change from the
lowercase to the upper case
and here as well
so we have a message in the form of a
constant let me put up a comment right
over here saying that this is going to
be one of my helper message
and I can utilize this message multiple
times whenever I want throughout my
program
now the next part would be since we have
multiple chances of attacking Thanos we
need some kind of a loop and inside the
loop we can keep on attacking Thanos for
at least three times in order to
simulate this Loop situation I am going
to use a while loop so I can just come
down over here and just before my print
message I can see
while
true
and let me indent it's why it has to be
while not white and let me indent all of
this thing
one tab space inside so all of this
belongs to the while loop now now let's
see since we have a while loop we also
need some kind of a circuit breaking
mechanism in order to exit
now let's go back to our outline and see
how we can do that one of the constraint
is that we only have three chances of
attacking Thanos
another constraint is if we have already
lost or we have already one then we can
simply break out and we don't have to
play a game so we are going to combine
this logic together and come up with a
very simple circuit breaking mechanism
so let me go back to my code
now inside my while loop we need to have
some sort of circuit breaking mechanism
so let me put up a command either we can
break out whenever we win or we can
break out whenever we lose so let's
write our logic right we are but before
adding the logic we need to create one
more variable and that variable is going
to hold our number of attacks as you can
see the constants we have three chances
for an attack so let's save that data
inside one variable let me go to the top
and declare a variable right over here
so this is called as attack numbers and
I am going to assign it a value of 0
initially
let us go back to the while loop and let
us Write Our Winning or our losing
conditions first let us see the winning
condition so we can say if
the life of Thanos
is less than or equal to 0 that means we
have 1 but we need to add one more
condition right over here the second
constraint and that constraint would be
if my number of attacks is also less
than or equal to 3.
only in this case I am going to win
otherwise I am going to lose and I am
going to print some kind of a message
over here so right now let me
just put up a comment that this is for
the for the win
for the else block that means if we have
lost so we can say if my attack numbers
are greater than or equal to 3 oh this
has to be else and if
now in case my attack numbers are more
than or equal to 3
in that case I am actually going to lose
now before I forget we need to add the
break statements to actually
break out of the while loop so let me
add them right away
the next thing that we need to do is we
want to display a nice winning or a nice
losing message so what I have done is I
have already written a nice message
which I am going to paste it right over
here just above the message so the first
one would be my winning message and it's
going to be you successfully saved
zorton along with a couple of emojis
and since this is a constant
all of this is capital and this is final
Str if you want it you can write this if
you don't want you can take it out and
my pie is smart enough to infer that
it's a constant of the type of string
the next message would be our losing
message so I'm just saying that Thanos
killed Avengers and captured zorton
the reason why I have all of this
separately in a constant or in a
variable is because in future if you
don't like this emojis you can simply
take them out
and you don't have to change all of the
logic that you write below you have to
just change one constant or one variable
and it's going to reflect throughout
your code it makes our code much more
manageable let me put back my Emojis I
just love them
and go back to our if and else block let
me
remove this and I can say here I want to
print my
win message and
here I want to print my
lose message
sorry it's going to be a lost message
let me save my file now let us go back
to our outline and let us see what we
need to do next
now we have to do the most important
part that is how to actually simulate
the attack unfortunately for us this is
the most simplest part let's see how we
can do that
suppose you are using the first pair
right over here in this case what's
happening is
Iron Man and Black Widow they are going
to attack Thanos
and if we just scroll up
Iron Man Has a power of 250 Black Widow
has a power of 180 and Thanos has a life
of 1500
so when Iron Man and Black Widow are
attacking Thanos we simply want to minus
the attack power from the life of Thanos
and since we have two Avengers who are
attacking Thanos we have to reduce the
value by 250 and 180 from 1500 and that
is how we simulate an attack
so let's go down over here and let us
Implement that logic
so we can say that my new Thanos life
would be my current Thanos life minus my
Iron Man
attack power
and also minus the
Black Widow attack power and that's it
and after doing this we also want to
increment the number of attacks since we
already have done one attack so we can
say my current attack number would be my
attack number plus one
so initially if you see the attack
number is zero
and whenever we have an actual attack we
are going to increment it by one and
remember we have a constraint right on
line number 49 that we cannot have more
than three attacks
if we have more than three tags then we
are going to lose the game let us do the
same thing for our choice number 2 3 and
4 as well let me just
copy this
let me paste over here and before the
attack I have to say that my
Thanos life would be my Thomas life
minus
Black Widow attack power minus the
Spider-Man attack power
let me go to the new line right here
again the same thing let me copy here as
well
and then here my Thanos life would be my
Thanos life minus
Spider-Man attack power minus
Hulk attack power
let us go to the last choice
and here we can say again the same thing
Thanos like would be
Thanos life minus
Hulk attack power
minus Iron Man attack power
here is my Iron Man
save it and that's it I think we are
good to go and we can try out our game
so let's give it a try
let me take this up a little bit
so the first thing is we have a nice
message saying that we have the
following pairs
for the first pair I want to go with the
first one Iron Man and Black Widow so I
just press one and enter
so I get the message that Iron Man and
Black Widow are attacking Thanos
now it's asking me for the second pair
now I can say I want to go with Black
Widow and Spider-Man so I enter my
choice number two
again we get a message saying that black
Widow and Spider-Man are attacking
Thanos and it is asking me for my third
pair let me go with Hulk and Iron Man so
I can type 4
and that's it and unfortunately we have
lost the game
Thanos has killed Avengers and he has
captured zotan
let us play the game one more time
this time I am going to choose my pair
number four Hulk and Iron Man
and my pair number one and again my pair
number four and that's amazing finally
we have been able to save zorton you can
see the message right over here
and this brings us to the end of section
number three
just take a break have some nice snacks
or coffee and I will see you in the next
section
welcome to a brand new section
this section is all about data
structures
data structures is just a common name
for how we can group our data together
and the first data structure that we are
going to see is called as a list now
since Lewis has a migrated to zorton he
has been making a lot of progress and in
Jordan people greet each other by saying
Zola
so Lewis wants to write a simple program
where he can beat all of his friends by
saying Zola followed by the name of the
friend you can do this by using multiple
print statements but that is not a very
effective approach what if you have
hundreds or thousands of friends then
you can imagine that using a print
statement for each and every friend
would get too tedious instead python
offers a much better solution
and that is called as a list so what we
are going to do is we are going to
create a list and after that we are
simply going to look through the list
and print a grading message to each one
of his friend let's see how to do this
behind the scenes I have created a new
folder called as zero four data
structures and I'm working in this file
called as friends dot pi so let's get
started with this one let us create a
variable called as friends oh let me get
the spelling right
now this friends is going to be a list
for creating a list you have to use open
and closing square brackets and inside
this you have to insert all of your
elements
suppose the first friend is CC
and then we have a bunch of other
friends Rocco Chico and Nico so this is
what a list in Python looks like now
let's see how we can add the type hints
to this one
now obviously this is a list so what we
can do is here we can simply say that
friends is a list and after that let us
try and specify what kind of data that
our list would be holding and if you see
all of our data types are strings so
what we can do is we can simply tell
that this list is going to be a list of
strings the next point that I want to
tell you is all the lists in Python they
always start with the index number of
zero so let me put a command and then
let me try to explain what's happening
so this is how your list will look
inside the memory
on index number 0 it will have CC on
index number one it will have Roku on
index number 2 Chico and so on always
remember that list will always start
with the index number of 0 and this is
common across all of the programming
languages not only in Python the next
point that I want to share is if you see
the length our length is 4 that means we
have four elements inside the list so
this is the first element second third
and fourth so the length of our list
would be four but the index number would
be up till 3. let's print out the
friends and see how they look like so
let me print the prints right over here
and let me run this file
so these are the friends we have friends
right over here now let's create a very
simple for Loop and greet all of his
friends
so let me start by putting some comments
let me take this a little up and we can
use a very simple for Loop so we can say
for
friend in my list of friends
for every friend I simply want to print
out a greeting message saying that
Zola followed by
the name of my friend
let us run this file
so here we have the output Zola CC Zola
Rocco and so on
let's see what Lewis wants to do next
so Lewis simply wants to count his
number of friends
so remember I just told you that the
length of this list would be 4 and we
can find that out by using an inbuilt
function which is also called as length
let me show you right over here let's
print out friends
length
and inside the curly brackets I can find
the length by using the inbuilt function
called as length Len and let us pass our
list to it just save and run your file
and your we have friends length is 4 and
that is what we were expecting let's see
what Lewis is doing next oh he had a
fight with Nico and he wants to unfriend
him
now let's see how we can take Nico out
of our list so we can see Nico Nico is
the last element inside our list and we
can remove him by using an inbuilt
function which is called as Pop let me
show you how it is to be done
so I can say I want to unfriend
and I can say from my list of friends I
simply want to pop the last value now
since Nico is the last element we can
use this method to remove an element
from the list
let us print out the friend that we have
just unfriended so we can just say
unfriend and let me put my curlies and
let me put unfriend over here let me
also copy and paste our friends
and let's see how our list is looking
right now so let me just
paste it right over here
just save it and try to run your file
and here we have it we have unfriended
Nico and this is how our current list of
friends looks like Let Us Go Back
let us see what Lewis is up to this time
so Lewis has made a new friend by the
name of zico so let us see how we can
add Z code to our list we can add zico
by using another input function by the
name of append let's see how to do that
so here I can say in my list of friends
I want to append one more element and
that element is called as zico
let us copy this line and paste the new
list
let me save it let me try to run my file
and here you can see we have zico at the
back
one more thing you must have noticed
that I am not assigning a variable for
this operation so for example I am not
doing something like this
the reason is if you just hover over
append
you can read the documentation this
function returns none that's why I'm not
assigning it back to my list of friends
but at the same time if you hover over
Pop now this method of Pop is actually
returning back a string that's why I'm
using a new variable on the left to
collect that data
but for this we can't do the same now
let's see what Lewis is up to so let me
go down right over here
and let me paste a new comments this
time Lewis wants to know who is his
third friend inside the list let us
check it out let me open up my terminal
so this is how our latest list looks
like so cc is a first print Rocco is the
second one and Chico is a third friend
so let's see how we can get this value
from our list and we can do that by
using our indexes
so just remember let me scroll a little
up our list it has a set of indexes and
always remember that the index is going
to start from 0. now let's see how we
can get the third value from our list
so here I can simply print out
from my list of friends
I simply want the friend who is on the
index number 2.
now remember we are using 2 because our
index starts at zero
let me put a command
so let me save this file and let us try
to run this file and here we have the
output Chico is the third friend inside
the list
let us go back
this time Lewis again had a fight but
this time he had a fight with Roku and
we need to remove Roku from our list as
well
let me scroll to our list
if you see Roku is inside our list at
index number one so let me show you how
we can do this so let us go down
here I can say from my list of friends I
simply want to remove
Roku that's it
let me copy this line and
paste it over here and let us try
running this file so this is our new
list we have CC Chico and zico we have
successfully removed Roku from our list
let's see what Lewis is up to next and
it seems like Lewis and Rocco have
become friends again
so let's see how we can add Roku back to
our list
remember that Roku was at index number
one so we want to insert Rocco back to
its original index so let me show you
how it is to be done so here I can say
in my list of friends I want to insert
at index number one
the element of groco
and let me try to print out the list one
more time
that's it just see run your file and
this is the new list we have Roku back
at index number one inside the friends
list
let's go back and let's see what Luis
wants to do next so this time Lewis
wants to confirm if Roku is in the
friends list or not and we can do this
by using our if and in syntax
so what we can say right over here is
if
Roku
in my list of friends then I simply want
to print out yay Roku is in the front
list or else I can print out
some other message so let me save the
file and let us try to run this one
now since Roku is inside the list we get
the output that yay the Roku is in the
friends list
let us go back
let's see what's happening next so this
time Lewis patches up with Nico as well
and this time Niko has become his number
one friend so we want to add Nico back
to our list of friends
but since Nico is his number one friend
right now we want to add Nico at the
beginning of the list so we can do this
by using the same syntax
right over here we can use the same
syntax
and let's see how to do this so we can
say
in my list of friends I want to insert
at index number 0
the element of Nico and let us print our
list of friends as well so let me go
down
let me paste and let us run this file
and here you can see we have Nico as the
first element inside of a list
let us go back so this time Lewis wants
to sort his friends in alphabetical
order
and luckily it's very simple we simply
have to say
friends I simply want
to sort it
let me copy and paste the list of
friends
and let us run this file
and here we have the output you can see
all of the names are sorted
alphabetically so CC Chico comes first
Nico Rocco and finally we have zico
let us go back
so this time Lewis doesn't really like
this ordering and he wants to reverse
the order
luckily this too is very simple
let me just copy this and let me
paste it right over here
and instead of sort I simply have to say
I want to not remove I want to reverse
that's it and let us run this file
and this time we have the new list and
you can see the first element is zico
and the last element is CC
let's see what's happening next
and this time Lewis again had a fight
with Nico and we again need to remove
Nico from our list but before removing
Nico let us have a look at our list
so this is how our list is currently
looking like and Nico is the third
element or you can see the index number
of Nico is two so keeping this in mind
let us go back and see how we can remove
the go from the list earlier I have
shown you two different methods of
removing elements one was this one of
remove and the first one was with the
pop method let me show you one more
method Again by using pop let me copy
all of this
and let us go down
now since Nico is at index number two
what I can do is I can tell python that
I want to pop an element from an index
number two
let us save and let us run this file for
the last time
and here we have it we have unfriended
Nicole and this is our updated list
the next data structure that we are
going to learn is called as a tuple
behind the scenes I have created a new
file which is called as subjects.pi and
let's see what's going to happen let me
collapse my sidebar
now it's time for Lewis to go to school
and he has to choose his subjects but
his school wants to make sure that once
a student chooses their subjects they
won't be able to change it so let's see
how we can do this and the way to do
this is by using a tuple
so you can imagine Tuple to be like a
stricter brother off list once you
create a tuple you can't change or
modify it so let's see how to create a
tuple
so let's say that we want to create a
tuple by the name of
subjects
and the way to create a tuple is by
using the round brackets and instead of
these round brackets we have to add our
elements suppose the first subject would
be maths the next could be
science then we can see history now
remember that's similar to our list our
tuples will also start with index number
zero that means the index number for Max
is 0 for science it would be 1 and for
history it would be two
let us see how to add typing for this
one
so here I can say that subjects is
obviously a tuple
and the way to define its type is we
have to put our square brackets and
since tuples are strict we have to
define the data type for each and every
element
so for example in this Tuple we have
three elements and the types are string
and string so here we can see that the
first element is a string
the second is the string as well and the
third is the string as well
suppose we had one more element
so if I say that we have one more
element as 13
now the data type of 13 is an integer
so what we would have to do is after
this we would have to say that my fourth
element is of the type of integer
so make sure whenever you are creating a
tuple you write the data type of all the
elements inside the Tuple let me take it
out this is not required for our example
right now
let me also put up a comment so saying
that the index number for match is 0 for
Sans is 1 and history is two
let's see what we can do next so let me
take it a little up
so this time Lewis wants to count his
number of subjects and you can do that
by using the inbuilt function called as
length so we can use a simple print
statement and we can say that
number of
subjects then inside our curly brackets
we can use the inbuilt function called
as length and let us just pass our Tuple
inside so we can say subjects
let us run and see the output
and here we can see that the number of
subjects is three
let us go back
the next thing that Lewis has to do is
Lewis has to sign up for all of the
subjects
so let us create a very simple Loop and
by using the loop we can sign up for all
of the different subjects
you can use your regular for Loops to
iterate over the Tuple so here it goes
we can see for my subject in my couple
of subjects
for each iteration I can simply print
out a statement saying that Lewis is
signing up for let me get my spelling
right Mr be signing up for and inside
the curly brackets we simply have to say
for my subject let us run and let us see
the output
so here it is Lewis is signing up for
maths and then for Science and the last
one is history
let us go back
so this time Lewis wants to see which is
his second subject and we can do that by
using our index so as I just mentioned
tuples also have indexes so the second
subject would have an index of one
so let us try and print it out
here I can simply say that I want to
print out
from my top love subjects the subject at
my index number one
also let me put up a comment saying that
since the double starts from index 0 we
are using one let us see the output
so you can see the second subject is
science
let us go back
and this time let us see what's
happening
so this time the school wants Lewis to
take another three subjects to get his
full credits now what happens is once
you create a tuple you can't add
different elements to a tuple
for example when we saw list we could
append elements to the list but you
can't do for the Tuple then what can you
do well you can add two different tuples
and create a new Tuple let me show you
how it is to be done so suppose the
additional subjects which he has to take
would be a new Tuple and we can say that
the new subjects are English Python and
physics on the next line we can create a
new Tuple called as my total subjects
and we can simply add our top subjects
plus our additional subjects
so now we have a new Tuple which has all
of the subjects together
we can also try and print it out so here
let me just say that my
all subjects would be my couple of total
subjects let us run it
and here we have the output you can see
we have English Python and physics at
the back and also we have maths Science
and History
so this is our newly created Tuple let
us go back and let's see what's
happening this time now it's obvious
that out of all of the subjects Lewis
loves Python and he wants to make sure
that python is inside his list of
subjects so we can check for an element
inside a tuple by using our if and else
blocks so let us see how to do that
so here we can simply say that if python
is in my Tuple of total subjects if this
is true then I simply want to print out
yay Lewis is going to Learn Python if
not so we can say else
we can print out oh no no python for
Lewis so let us save this file and let
us try to run this file for the last
time
and here we have the output
now since python is inside our Tuple we
get the output of a Lewis is going to
Learn Python
now let's try to learn about
dictionaries
dictionaries are of mapping type that
means the dictionary are going to map a
key to a value
so let us see what's going to happen
right now behind the scenes I've created
a file called as marks.pi and I'm
working in this one so let me collapse
my sidebar and let us see what's
happening
now this time Lewis has given his exam
and he has received his marks
so let us see how it looks like so we
can create a dictionary and call it as
marks
the way to declare a dictionary is by
using your curly brackets
and inside of this curly brackets let us
give the key and the value pairs suppose
the first subject is maths so we can say
Max
and he scored maybe 80 marks in his
match so this is how your key and value
pairs look like on the left of the colon
we have a key and on the right we have a
value
let us give a couple of more key and
value pairs suppose the next subject was
science and suppose he fed 82 marks in
science
and let me add a couple of more subjects
as well
so this is his score
and the next line let us print out all
of this subjects we can say
in my formatted string my marks and
let us see marks let me save the file
and let us try running this one
and here is output so this is the
dictionary that we just created
now let us go back and see what's
happening next
let me put some comments right over here
so this time Lewis wants to check all of
the subjects now remember inside our
dictionary the keys are our subjects so
let us see how we can just get the keys
out of our dictionary
the way to do that is very simple let's
also use a for Loop to print out the
keys so we can say for my subject in my
dictionary of marks
I want to get all of the keys and for
each iteration we simply want to print
out the subject let us run this file and
see the output
so here is our output we have all of the
keys inside our dictionary
now let us go back and let's see what's
going to happen next
so this time Lewis wants to check all of
his marks now again remember that the
marks are the values
so anything on the right is the value
and this time we want to get only the
marks out of our dictionary
so let us do that and the way to do that
is similar to something like this so let
me show you how it is to be done
so we can say for my score
in my dictionary of marks I want to get
only the values
and for each iteration I just want to
print out my score
let me save the file and let me try to
run this file and here we have the
output here you can see we have all of
our score
let us go back
let us see what Lewis wants to do next
so let me take a little up
this time Lewis wants to check out all
of the subjects and marks together that
means we simply have to print out our
key and value pairs so let us see how we
can do that
again let us use our for Loop to print
out the key and values so we can say
for
now since the keys is for the subjects
let us call subject and on the right we
have score so we can say score
in my dictionary of marks I want to get
all of the items now this method is
going to return our key and values which
we are capturing right over here
and for each iteration let us print out
our KN value pairs so here I can say
that my
subject and here we can say the score
and we can say the score is out of
just let me save it and let us try
running this file
and here we have the output match Lewis
code 80 out of 100 science was 82
history was 78 and so on
now let us go back and see what we have
to do next
and this time Luis wants to check if he
has passed in all of the subjects or not
and the passing marks are 50.
so let us see how we can do this
we can do this by using our for Loop and
our if and edge blocks so let me show
you how it is to be done
so here we can say for
my subject and my score in my marks dot
items
for each iteration I want to check if my
score is greater than or equal to 50
only in that case I can print out that
subject and I can say pass
else if the score is less than 15 that
means he has failed and so we can print
out the name of the subject so we can
say
the subject and we can see field let me
save it and let me try to run this file
so let's see how he has done in his exam
match is a pass science is a pass
oh but what's this English is a field so
let's see what's going to happen next
let us go back to our file
so let me take it a little up and let me
put some comments so those things that
there was some kind of a totally mistake
for his English paper and he's asking
for a revaluation
and after the revaluation the new marks
are 70 so let us see how we can update
the values in our dictionary
so this time what we want to do is let
me show the dictionary
so this time we want to update the marks
of English from 35
270 so let us see how we can do that so
let me go down
and here I can say that from my
dictionary of marks I want to go to my
key of English
and I want to assign the new value of
17. so this is how you can update the
values inside your dictionary
on the next line we can print out the
value we can say something like this
Lewis
score inside the curly brackets we can
see the marks of English
in English
so let me just save this and let me try
to run this file
so here we have the output saying that
Lewis scored 70 in English
now here what we are doing is this
syntax we are just retrieving the value
from our dictionary
so the syntax means that from my
dictionary of marks I want to get the
value for the key of English let us see
what is happening next now this time low
is also took an exam for geography and
his code 78 marks
so this time what we have to do is we
have to create a new key and a new value
this time remember we don't have
geography inside our dictionary of marks
and we have to create one right now
so what we can say is for my dictionary
of marks I want to create a new key for
my geography and I want to assign the
value of
78 to it and Lewis also wants to check
if he has passed in all of his subjects
or not
so let me go up and I just have to copy
all of this and let me paste it right
over here
so here is the output and it looks like
Lewis has passed in all of his subjects
and you can also see we have the output
for geography as well
now let us go back so let's see what's
happening this time
so this time his friends on zorton they
want to know how much Lewis scored in
Python so let us see how we can retrieve
the values from our dictionary so let me
show you the first alternative
let us create a new variable called as
our python score and we can retrieve a
value by using the syntax so we want to
say that go to my dictionary of marks
and I want you to get the value for the
key of python and that's how you
retrieve the value but this syntax has a
couple of limitations which I'll explain
it shortly but first let us print out
these values let us print out the marks
in Python so we can say Lewis
core the python score in Python let us
run this file
and here we have the output saying that
Lewis scored 98 in Python now let me
show you one more alternative method let
us go down and let me
put one more comment and here again we
can say that the python score and this
time we can use one more alternate
syntax so what we can say that from a
dictionary of marks I want to get the
values for my key of python and on the
next line let us print out the same
statement so let me copy from here and
let me paste it right over here
and let us run our file
so this time we can see we again have
the output now let us go back and let's
see what's happening next
so let us see what's happening this time
and this time his friends from Earth
they want to know how much Lewis code in
Java
so what we can do we can create a
variable called as
JavaScript and we can save from a
dictionary of marks I want to get the
value for my key of java and the next
line let me try and print it out so what
I can say that I want to print out Lewis
code
Java score in Java let me see and let me
run this file and this time you can see
that we have an error and the error is
called as key error now this is because
our dictionary does not have a keyword
as Java so this is one of the
limitations of using this syntax right
over here let me put up a command saying
that this syntax will throw an error now
let's see a better way of getting the
values from our dictionary and that is
by using the get method that we just saw
on the next line let me paste some
comments and I want to comment this out
because this is always going to fail so
let us go down right over here
let me take everything up so here let me
create one more variable called as our
Java score and let us use the get syntax
so what we can say is from my dictionary
of marks I want you to get
the value for the key called as Java let
me save this and this time let us try to
print out this same sentence so I can
just copy and let me paste it right over
here let us run this file and see the
output
so this time we get the output of Lewis
scored none in Java so let us go back
and let us see what's happening
now this method of get returns a none if
it can't find the value and that's what
is happening right over here one thing
that I forgot to show is how to use the
typing for this one so let us go up and
let me show you how to write the type
hints for our dictionary
so this variable of marks this is a
dictionary so we can say this is our
dictionary
and inside the brackets we also have to
mention the types for our keys and
values so here we can say that since all
of the keys are string so the key is
going to be of the type of string and
the values are integers so we can just
say int and that's it now let us go down
and let us see what's happening so here
on the line 108 this get method is going
to return none or if it finds a value it
is going to return our score which is of
the type of integer now let us use our
if and else blocks to print something
meaningful so here we can say that if my
Java score is none that means if we
can't find the value
then we can simply print out saying that
Lewis did not study Java
and else we want to print out this
statement so let me take it inside my
else blog and let us try to run this
file and here it is we have the output
of Lewis did not study in Java
now let us go back
the last thing that I wanted to show you
is how to delete some elements or how to
delete the key and value pairs from our
dictionary now suppose we want to delete
the key and value pair for English
then we can say that I want to delete
from my dish media of marks
English so this is how the syntax goes
let me remove the extra codes
now let us print our marks one more time
so I can see
marks and let us print out the marks
right over here
let me run this file so this is how our
dictionary is looking and you can see we
have deleted English from our dictionary
as well the last thing that I wanted to
mention for this one is the lookups and
dictionary are extremely fast what do I
mean by lookup
so on line number 108 we are getting the
value from our dictionary so this is a
lookup when we were working with our
list or tuples we were using indexing
but for a dictionary we always use the
key to get the data and this is the
reason why lookups in dictionary are
extremely fast
and we would be using dictionaries and
lists in our final project as well so
make sure you go through them a couple
of times and understand what's exactly
happening
there is one last thing that I wanted to
show you so if you open up the code from
the GitHub so this is the code from
GitHub
inside my 4.04 data structures this is
the file which I am referring to it is
called as dictionary
now let me collapse my sidebar
so here I have one more sample
dictionary called as pizza and you can
see the structure is very interesting
the first key value pairs we have
integer as the key and string as the
value
for the next one we have a float as our
key the next one is even more
interesting we have a tuple as the key
and the last one we have a Boolean value
as a key now the interesting part is
this is a valid syntax
so let me copy all of this and let me
paste all of these things inside my
IPython shell so here it is let me paste
it right over here and let us try to
print out our pizza
so you can see we have a valid output so
what happens is you can use any data
type for a key as long as it is
immutable
so our strings are immutable integers
are immutable floats booleans are also
immutable and we also saw that our
tuples are immutable as well so you can
use all of these data types as your keys
the way to retrieve the data is similar
so let me give you some small examples
so here we can say from my dictionary of
pizza
I want to get the value for the key of
10. and here we have the output
the same thing can go for our float as
well so we can say 8.99
and here we have the value
you can do the same thing for our Tuple
as well let me copy this Tuple
and here I can say from my dictionary of
Pisa I want to get the value from the
key and this time the key is a tuple so
let me paste it right over here
and you can see we have the right output
but before we make such additionally I
want you to wait and think do you think
that this is going to be a developer
friendly dictionary I would rather think
not
I just wanted to show you that you can
create such dictionaries and all of this
is a valid syntax
now let us have a look at the next data
structure and this data structure is all
about being unique
the name of this data structure is
called as a set
for this video I have created a new file
called as teach dot pi and let's get
working with this one
so let's see what's happening this time
Lewis wants to show some of his English
magic to zortans but Jordan's they can't
understand what's happening and they
want to see each alphabet separately
that means they want to understand each
unique alphabets so let's see what's
going to happen next
so suppose we have a magic word called
as
Abracadabra now let's see how we can get
the unique alphabets from our string
so on the next line let us create one
more variable called as unique alphabets
and in order to get unique alphabets
from the string we have to create a set
and the way to create a set is by using
the cost which is called as set and let
us pass our variable magic words to this
one
now if you hover over the variable
unique alphabets
you can see the type is set and the set
is of the type of a string
so let's write that over here so this is
a set and the data type is for the
string let us print out our unique
alphabets so here we can say I simply
want to print out
my unit alphabets
let me save it and let us try to run
this file and here we have all of the
unique alphabets
so let me take this a little up
so inside our word of abracadabra
the alphabets of c d a b and R all of
this alphabets are unique
let us go back let's try one more time
and this time let us use a sentence so
we can create a sentence like this the
big blue sky and the big blue ocean and
let us see the unique alphabets so I can
reuse my variable of unique alphabets
and this time let us create a set from
our sentence and let me copy and paste
this line
right over here let us run the file
and this time we have an output so all
of this alphabets are unique inside our
sentence
but what happens if you want to check
the unique words instead of the
characters let us see how to do that the
first thing that we would need to do is
we would want to convert our sentence
into a list of words
so let us see how to do that first let
me create a variable called as my word
list
and we can simply split our sentence by
using an inbuilt function by the name of
split
so we can say that I want to split my
sentence now if you see the type of
sentence is a string right
so on a string you have a method called
as
split
so this is going to return a list of all
of the words inside the sentence let us
try to print it out on the next line so
let me say
my word list
is my variable of
word list let us try to run this file
so here you can see we have the list of
all of the words inside the sentence so
the next step is to actually create a
set out of our words list and once we
create a set then we can know all of the
unique words inside our sentence so
let's do that let me put up comments in
that we need to extract the unique words
let us create a variable called as
unique words and we simply need to
create a set out of our word list
let us try to print it out
so here I can say
my unique
words
and the variable of unique words let us
try to run this file
so here you can see the unique words are
big Ocean Blue Sky the and and also one
more thing that I want you to note that
at the beginning and at the end we have
the curly brackets so you can see right
over here
for the beginning we have a curly
bracket and at the last we have a curly
bracket so this symbolizes a set in the
dictionary we had key and value pairs
inside curly brackets but for a set we
only have values
so let us go back
so this time zortans they are really
impressed and they want to see if we can
add a couple of more words to our set
so let's see how we can try and update
our set so what we can do is let us take
the existing set for our unique words
and we can say that we want to update
with the new values and here we need to
pass an iterable that means you can pass
a list or a tuple or any other data
structure which is iterable
so let me paste some values right over
here so let us see if we can update with
the new values of big blue and Sky let
me copy this line and let me
paste it right over here and let me try
to run this file
now if you see nothing is happening
this line and the line before that
they are exactly the same now what's
happening
no sense set is all about being unique
we can't add the existing values to the
set if you go back to our code big blue
and Sky these words are already existing
inside our set so nothing is happening
let me put up a comment if you try to
update your set with existing values
nothing is going to happen
now let us try to update with some other
words which are not there inside the set
so I can say my unique words
I want to update with the new values and
this time I want to pass the value of
green and grass
let me copy this
paste it right over here now let us try
to run our file and this time you can
see we have the words of green and grass
inside our set let us go back and let us
see what's happening next let me put
some comment right over here saying that
something does happen
now what happens is zortens they don't
like the word of grass now let's see how
we can remove the word of grass from our
set so we can simply say that from my
list of unique words I want to remove
and I want to remove the element of
grass
and again let me copy and paste all of
this
and let us save and let us run our file
and you can see that this time we have
removed the word of grass from our set
let us go back now I just wanted to let
you know that you can do a lot of other
operations on sets such as your union
and intersections and so on but I would
not be covering all of those inside this
tutorials now let us see how we can use
data structures for our game so behind
the scenes I've created a new file
called as game saves button 2 and this
is the file and I have also pasted a
couple of comments right over here
so this time what is happening is the
war is just getting more intensified
this time the army of Thanos is also
arriving and since it's going to be a
very intense fight
our program will automatically choose
superhero and the super villain and our
Avengers have exactly three chances to
defeat Thanos now this time since we
have already seen data structures
we are going to create a nice data
structure for our characters but first
let me go to my old file inside my
folder number zero three
and let's copy a couple of things from
here
so
let me copy from here
till my last message
let me go back let me collapse my
sidebar
and let me paste it right over here
so this is our current file now let's
get started this time we are going to
define a nice structure for our
characters you have seen that our
character has an attack power and Thanos
had life but this time our super
villains are also going to attack our
superheroes so all of the characters
will have a property of life as well so
let us see how we can do all of these
things let me create a constant and let
me call it as Iron Man
and the most ideal data structure would
be additionally now since with
dictionary we can have the key and value
pairs it makes much more sense to use a
dictionary right over here
the first key would be for the name of
the character
so in this case the name is Iron Man
the next key would be for the attack
power so I can say my
attack power
the value is of the type of an integer
and the attack power of Iron Man IS 250
the last key and value pair would be for
the life so you can say I want to have a
key for my life let's give him a life of
say
1000 now let us see how we can Define
the types for this one now obviously
Iron Man is a dictionary now if you see
the structure of our dictionary
all of the keys are strings but for the
values sometimes we have a string and
sometimes we have an integer
so let us see how we can Define the
types over here
since all of the types the keys are
going to be string so we can see the key
is of the type of a string and the value
we can see it's either going to be a
string or it is going to be an integer
so this is how you define the types for
our Iron Man
now since this is going to be a constant
we can wrap all of these things inside
final so let me do that
let me put my brackets and let me say
final but what happens is typing all of
these things again and again becomes so
boring so what we can do is we can use a
small trick and that trick is called as
in typing Alias so what I can do is let
me just cut out all of these things and
here let me create a new variable called
as character and I can Define the type
right over here so what I am doing on
line number 20 is I'm defining a new
variable called as character and I am
assigning the type to it so what I can
do on line number 22 is I can simply say
that Iron Man is a constant of the type
of character
so this is going to save us a lot of
typing let me put up some comments over
here
now let us go down and let's create some
more superheroes so let me just paste it
right over here so what I've done is I
have created three more superheroes one
is Black Widow Spiderman and Hulk and I
have also assigned values to each of our
superhero let me put a comment right
over here so this is for our superheroes
similarly let us also do for our super
villains so let me put a comment right
over here
so I can say that let us Define a super
villain called as Thanos
the type would be final and we can say
character right over here
and let's create our dictionary so we
can say the name is Thanos the attack
power is 1500 and life is 1500 similarly
let me create some other supervillains
as well so I've created a couple of more
super villains One is Red Skull and the
last one is Proxima now since we have a
structure for our character
we don't need all of these things so let
me take it out the next thing is let us
create a list of all of our superheroes
and all of our super villains
so let me put up a comment and let us
create a list for our superheroes
and we can say this is going to be a
list so I can put my square brackets the
first is our Iron Man next is
Black Widow next is Spider-Man and last
is the Hulk now let us see how we can
Define the typing for this one so
superheroes is a list
and the type is of the character let us
go down and let us create one more for
our supervillains as well so I can say
that my villains is again going to be a
list of my
character and let us create a list right
over here the first is our Thanos then
is for the Red Skull and losses for
Proxima let us go down and let me put up
a comment right here that choices and
attack numbers all of this are our
helper variables it takes out and let me
take this out as well that's not
required now let's go down
and let us see how we can implement the
actual attack
the last time we had used a while loop
this time I want to show you a for Loop
and I also wanted to show you a new
keyword that keyword is called as range
so first let me type and then I will try
and explain what's happening so I can
create a for Loop saying that for attack
in my range of 3 now let me try to
explain what's happening if you remember
we have a constraint that Avengers can
attack only three times and that's what
I'm doing right over here let me open up
my IPython shell and let me try to
explain over there
so range is an inbuilt keyword inside
python
so we are typing as for my number in my
range of 3
I simply want to print out my number
let's see what kind of output we are
getting
so we get the output of 0 1 and 2 and
after we get to our for Loop is going to
stop so that means our Loop ran for
three times this was the first this was
the second and this was the third time
so this is where I am trying to
implement our constraint of Maximum
three attacks
so here our for Loop will run for
exactly three times and then it will
exit let's see what we can do next now
since this is a very intense fight our
program has to choose a superhero and a
super villain randomly so let's see how
we can do that first let me put our
Command and here again I want to show
you one more function which is built
into Python and that is called as random
integers so what's going to happen is
for each iteration of our for Loop we
want to choose a superhero and a super
villain and remember our superheroes and
supervillains are listed and lists have
indexes right
so for Iron Man the index number would
be zero for Black Widow the index number
would be one Spider-Man would be index
number two and Hulk would be index
number three
so what we are going to do is we are
just going to generate a random index
number and we are going to take that
Superhero out of our list of superheroes
and similarly for our villains as well
but before we can generate an random
integer first we need to import that
functionality
so here I can say from my package of
Random I want to import something which
is called as random int let us go down
and let us see how to use this let me go
to my iPath and shell and let me give
you a small demo right over here here I
can say from random I want to import my
random integer
and let us try and see the output of
random end
and let us pass the values of 0 to 10.
so this time we get an 8 let us try to
make it one more time this time we have
a three this time we have a seven
so you see that we can randomly generate
different numbers so let's see how to
use this inside our program
so here I can say that for each
iteration of the for loop I want to
generate a random integer and my
starting index would be 3
and my last index would be 3
now let's see why I'm writing 3 over
here the first time we want to generate
a random integer for our hero so let me
create a variable called as
hero index and assign the value right
over here now let's see what's happening
if you see our list of superheroes we
have four elements that means the length
is 4 but the index number is 3 that is
why I am writing 3 right over here let
us generate a random integer for our
billion as well so let me create a
variable called as
villain index and I can use the same
function random integer I want to start
at 0 and at the max I want to have 2
that's because the length of valence is
3. now let's see what we can do next
so what we are doing on line number 54
and 55 is we are just generating a
random integer number
the next thing is we can use that
integer number to get a superhero from
our list so let's see how to do that
so let me put up a comment saying that
we have a couple of more helper
variables and I can say that I want to
get my current superhero
from my list of superheroes and the
index number is the randomly generated
number which we have stored in the
variable of hero index so that means on
line number 54 we are just generating an
index number
and online number 57 we are using that
index number to get a superhero from our
list of superheroes let us do the same
thing for our villain as well
so here I can say that my current
villain would be from my list of
villains from the index of my villain
index
let us try to print out the values and
see what's happening
so here I can say I want to print out my
current superhero
and I want to print out my current
supervillain
let us run this file so here is the
output
for the first iteration we have Iron Man
and Proxima for the second iteration we
have black widow and red skull for the
third iteration we have Iron Man and
Thanos so you see for each time we have
a different pair who is going to attack
each other and that's what we want so
let us go back to our program
let us display a nice message right over
here
so let us see I want to print using my
formatted string
the first thing I want to display is my
attack numbers I can save my attack and
let us also display the names of our
superhero and our super villain who are
going to fight so I can say inside my
curly brackets that my
superhero and let us also get the name
now remember that current superhero is a
dictionary and we can get the values by
using our key and values and tags so I
can say that I want to get the value of
my key of name and then we can say that
is going to fight with here we can
display the name of our super villain so
I can say my
current villain and I want to retrieve
the value from my key of name let me
save it
let us take out this line it's not
required now and let me try and run this
file
so this time we have an output for the
first attack we have black widow who is
going to fight with Red Skull
the next time we have black widow again
and she is going to fight with Thanos
the last time Spider-Man is good fight
with Thanos what we can do right over
here is instead of displaying 0 we can
start from one so let me go back and
here I can say attack plus of one let me
save it and let me try to run the file
so this time we have a much better
output let us go back
so here before we can attack we also
need to calculate the total life so
what's happening is for each iteration
of our for Loop we have a superhero and
you also have a villain so we need to
calculate the life of our superheroes as
well as our super villains for that we
would need two more variables so let me
go right over here
and create two new variables right over
here
so the first one would be for our hero
life and initially give it a value of 0
the next one is for our villain life
again let us set it to a value of zero
now we don't require this variables
because remember we are using the
function of range so we can simply take
them out it's not required
let me take it up
let me save my file and let us go down
right over here
let me put up a comment saying that
first we need to add the life for each
iteration so I can say for my life
and for each iteration what I want to do
is this is my life of hero and I want to
add the life of my current hero to my
hero life for each iteration so I can
say my hero life plus my current hero
and from my current hero I want to get
the value of his life let us do the same
thing for the life of villains as well
so I can say my villain life is equal to
my villain life plus my current villain
and I want to get the value for life
now what we can do is we can also use
our shorthand syntax that means we can
take this out and here we can say plus
equal to so this means the exact same
thing let me do it for the villain life
as well so let me take it out plus equal
to now you see that we have an error
right over here but for now just ignore
this error all of this errors will go
away when we Implement these characters
by using classes now let's see how to
implement the actual attack so let me
put up a command now what is going to
happen is our villain is going to attack
the hero so what we need to do is we
need to minus the attacking power of the
villain from the life of the hero so let
us do that right over here so I can say
that my hero life would be my hero life
and minus I want to have the attacking
power of my villain so I can say my
current villain I want to get the attack
power we can use our shorthand syntax
right over here as well so here I can
take this out and I can say minus equal
to let us do the same thing for the
villain life as well so here I can say
my villain life minus equal to the
current superhero and I want to get the
attacking power of my superhero
now let's see what to do next so this
attack is going to happen for three
times and after the attack is done we
need to see if we are willing or we are
losing so once we are out of the for
Loop let us print a nice separating line
so let me put up a command and let us
print a nice separating line so I can
say equal to multiplied by 70. so what
this is going to do is it is simply
going to repeat the string of equal to
70 times next let me take it a little up
and let me put up a command so this time
we want to check if we are winning or if
we are losing and the logic for this is
very simple if the life of the heroes is
greater than or equal to the life of the
villains that means the Avengers have
won so let us do that right over here so
we can say if the hero life is greater
than or equal to
the villain life
then we simply want to print our win
message
else that means we have lost so let us
print out the Lost message that's it let
me save my file and let me try running
this amazing we have a nice output so
here you can see that we attacked three
times the first time Spider-Man attacked
Proxima the second time again Spider-Man
attacked Red Skull and the third time
Black Widow attacked Red Skull but
unfortunately Thanos killed Avengers and
he has captured zorton let us try
playing one more time so let me play one
more time okay so this time we have
saved it's so amazing
welcome to the last video in this
section
now this is an extra video and I want
you to come back to this video after you
learn about classes
I am putting this video right over here
just for the sake of completeness
in this video we are going to learn
about enums so behind the scenes I have
created a file called as choices and let
us see what's going to happen now elams
are the perfect data structures whenever
you want to create multiple choices or
varieties so let's see how to do that
the first thing is we need to import
enum so we can say from my package of
enum I want to import enum and let us
Import Auto also so I'll explain what is
it all about suppose you wanted to
create choices for different pizza sizes
so let us see how to do that so I can
say my class
of my pizza size now this inherits from
my class of enum
let me put up some documentation
and here we can say that my first choice
would be for a small size
and we can assign it a value of 8
the next choice could be medium it could
be at 10 inches then we have one more
for large
it could be 12.
so what this simply means is we have
created an enem of pizza size and we
have three choices small medium and
large
now let us see how to work with this
enum so let me go down
let us create a variable of choice and
suppose the choice of the pizza size
could be medium
so we can say from my enum of pizza size
I simply want the medium value
let us print out the value on the next
line so I can say print and I can say
one order four now in order to get the
value we can say from my enum of choice
I want to get the value and then I can
write inch pizza so let me save this and
let me run this file and we have the
output one order for a 10 inch pizza so
let us go back
let us create one more enum for colors
of a t-shirt so I can make a class and
the class is for color this also
inherits from my enum
let me write some documentation this is
for my t-shirt varieties and here I can
say that my first choice is red and I
can give it a value of red the next
could be blue and green let us also try
to print out the values
so let me go right over here and let me
copy this line let me go down let me
paste it right over here and here we can
see one order for my colors suppose we
want to have Green Dot we can get the
value right over here
and this becomes my t-shirt
that's it just save and run your file
and here we have the output one order
for a green t-shirt let us go back let
us create one more enum there may be
times we don't require a value
let me show you one example let me
create a class called as role we can
inherit from enum now suppose you want
to create different rules for your stuff
it could be a associate it could be a
supervisor and so on and you don't want
to assign values to them but what we can
do is we can automatically give them
values let us see how to do that
suppose the first rule is for an
associate
we can assign it a value by using our
imported function called as Auto now
remember on on line number eight we are
importing Auto and that's what we are
going to use right away
so what this Auto is going to do is the
first time it is going to assign the
value as 1 the next time it is going to
assign the value of 2 so suppose we have
one more role for a supervisor
and we assign it to Auto so this time
the value of supervisor would be set to
2. suppose we have one more rule for the
manager
now this time the value of manager would
be 3 let us try and print it out so I
can say print from my in above role I
want you to go to my manager and I want
you to print the value
let us run this file and here you can
see that the value of manager is
automatically set to 3.
welcome to a brand new section this
section is all about functions
till now we have used inbuilt functions
such as print and in this section we are
going to learn how to create our own
functions but before we can create our
own functions I wanted to talk a little
bit about functions the main goal of a
function is for your data processing you
have some sort of an input this input
goes inside your function your function
processes the data and finally we would
like to have some sort of an output
so this is your ideal function
you take an input you process it and you
give back an output but in real life
it's not so simple
so let's try learning more about
functions so let us go back to our code
editor behind the scenes I've created a
folder called as zero five functions and
this is the file called as greater dot
Pi let us see what's going to happen
right now so this is a very simple
program for greeting
and the people in shortened they greet
each other by saying Zola
and Lewis wants to write a program where
he can greet his friends in Zola so
let's define a function and the way to
define a function is by using the
keyword called as def followed by the
name of the function so we can say the
name of my function is greda and this
function accepts one argument and we can
call that argument as anything in this
case I am going to call that argument as
name and then you put your colons and
inside of this you have to write the
body or the logic of the function you
can also write some sort of a
documentation and you can do that by
using your triple quotes so you can say
that this function greets
Zoltan let us go to the next line and
let us print out a greeting message so
what we can do is we can simply print
out a message we can use our formatted
string and then we can say Zola followed
by the name now let us see how we can
Define the types for this function
we can say that this function of Grita
accepts one argument and we can Define
the type right over here so we can say
my argument has to be the type of a
string and since this function returns
nothing so we can say that this function
is going to return
none let's create one more function
called as main so we can say this is my
main function
this function does not accept any
arguments and this function returns
nothing
here we can create a list of all of the
friends so I can create a variable
called as
friends and let me assign some values to
it so these are all of the lists of the
friends and we want to greet all of
these friends
we can create a very simple for Loop and
using the for Loop we can call this
function let me show how it is to be
done but before that let me add the
types for this as well so friends is a
list and the data type is a string or
the next line we can say that for my
friend in my list of friends for each
iteration I simply want to invoke the
function of greeter and pass a name so
what we can say right over here is
for each iteration I want to call the
function of Greater and I simply want to
pass the friend each time now the reason
why we have created a main function is
just by sake of convention we always
like our programs to start with the
function which is named as Main
now let us see how to use this function
you need to invoke or you need to call
this function in order for our program
to run so on the next line we can invoke
our main function and the way to invoke
is by just writing main along with the
brackets
so whenever you write the brackets that
means that you want to invoke the
function if you just write like this it
means an assignment but if you want to
run that means you want to put the
brackets so let me save this and let me
try to run this file
and here we have the output so we have
Zola CC Zola Rocco and so on
we just saw how to write a function and
in this video I'll show you how we can
write a slightly better version of our
greater function
first let us go back to our diagram
now in an Ideal World We would like to
take one input and we would also like to
give back an output
but let us have a look at this function
called as greeter we are taking an input
but we are not returning an output so
let us see how we can create a better
version of this so behind the scenes
I've created a file called as beta
greater dot pi
and let us get started with this one let
us go back to this file and let me copy
all of these things so let me copy right
from here
let me go back to this file and let me
paste everything right over here let me
collapse my sidebar and this time let us
try and return something so instead of
just printing Zola followed by the name
we can actually return this value so let
me take out the print statement the
bracket as well and here I can say that
I want to return my new string so what
this function is going to do is it is
accepting one argument and it is
transforming that string into a greeting
message and we are returning that string
as well now since this function is
returning a value we also need to change
the type over here and the type is
string so what happens is when we were
using the print function we were causing
something which is called as a side
effect but this function is a more pure
function it takes one input and it gives
back one output now it is the
responsibility of the color function of
how to handle the written data let me
tell you let me show you what I mean by
it but first let me write some comments
so let me go right over here and put me
some comments
saying that the call function is
responsible for the written data and
here I can say that
this function transform the original
string to something useful and let us
change the documentation as well so this
function is going to return a greeting
message
now let us go down and let us see what's
happening on line number 25 we are
invoking the function of Grita and our
main function is responsible for calling
this function
nut means conceptually you can call the
main function as your caller function
that means main is calling greater and
now it is the responsibility of your
caller function that means it is the
responsibility of your main function
of how to handle the return values
now this pattern is very useful
what if you wanted to check for the
written values
you can check for the written values and
you can do something with it let us have
a small example right over here let me
put up some comments over here now
suppose Lewis finds Chico to be queued
so what we can do is we can say for each
iteration
if Chico is in the output of my function
of grida so greater and friend
now remember our function of Grita is
returning back a string
and if that string contains Chico then
we can't print out something like this
so here we can say that print is cute or
else we can simply print out the message
as it is so here we can simply print our
glitter and friend
so what's happening is for each
iteration our function of Grider is
returning back some values and that
value is Zola followed by the name of
the friend so for the first iteration
the return value is Zola CC the second
time is zolaroko and the third time is
Chico and so on
but since the function of gritter is
returning as data we can handle that
data in multiple ways so first let me
run this file and then let me try and
explain you again one more time
so here we have the output that Chico is
cute
so what's happening online number 27 is
let me open up my IPython shell
so here I can see if Chico in Sola Chico
then we have the answer as true
if we say something like this
Lewis in zorachico the answer is false
and that is what we are doing on this
line
suppose the output of this function is
zorachico that time we simply want to
print out a message saying that Chico is
cute so basically what we are trying to
do is our caller function is handling
the response of glitter in multiple ways
let's have some more practice with our
functions for this video Behind the
Scenes I've created a file called as
weight dot pi and let us see what's
happening
now since Lewis is staying in zorton
gravity Works differently over there and
this time we want to calculate how much
you wait in zorton and this is the
formula to convert the Earth's weight to
salt and sweet let me go down over here
and let us Define a function which is
called as
calculate weight
this will accept one argument which you
can call as weight
we can Define the type as a float
because your weight can have decimal
values so let me write the type the
float and this function will also return
the float value
inside the body of the function we can
have one single return statement and we
can say that I want to return and here
we can calculate the weight by using the
formula so we can see
the weight plus of 32
divided by 8.
now let us try and print out the weight
so let me write a very simple print
statement
we can use our formatted strings so you
can see
U way and inside the curly brackets let
us invoke the function so I can say
calculate weight
and for example let's pass 60 kgs
and then you can see kgs on
zorton let us say this and let us try
running this program
so here we have the output saying that
you weigh 11.5 kgs on certain
let us go back I wanted to show you one
small trick what happens if we want to
display exactly two decimal places or
three decimal places and so on
the way to do that is right over here so
here we can say that
I want to display my two decimal places
for the float
receive a file and drive Renegade for
the last time
and here we have the output so you can
see we have two decimal places
let us have a look at the next example
this time I am working on this file
called as fly dot pi and let's see
what's happening this time now we just
saw that gravity insulting is much less
as compared to Earth
so what happens is if you weigh 15 kgs
or less then you can actually fly on
certain
so what Lewis wants to do is Lewis wants
to see which of his friends can fly so
let's see how to work with this one
and there is one very important concept
which is called as single responsibility
principle
and let us see what do I mean by this
principle in this video
so as a convention let us create our
main function first and from there we
will create functions as we require them
so let me Define my main function so I
can say my Define and Main this function
does not take anything and it returns
none so I can write none over here now
inside of this function let us create
the friends of Lewis so let me create my
dictionary of friends and let me assign
some values to it so here we can see
that we have a couple of values cc is
being 54 Rocco is being 88 and so on
let us also write the types for this one
so friends is medicinally
the keys are strings and the values are
integers what we can do over here is
instead of just declaring integers we
can also write a float so in case if you
have a decimal value in the future we
can easily handle it if we declare it as
a float
next let us create a function called as
flying friends and see which of the
friends can fly so I can say my function
of flying friends
and we just have to pass the dictionary
of friends
now let us go up and let us start
creating our functions
so as you can see there is one small
constraint and that constant is you have
to weigh 15 kgs in order to fly so what
we can do is we can create a constant
so let me call the constant as maximum
flying bit and we can assign it a value
of 15 let us also Define the type for
this one so since this is a constant it
has to be declared as final
but before we can write final we need to
import it
so here I can say that from typing I
want to import final and here we can use
the keyword of final so our maximum
flying weight is a final and the pipe we
can Define it to be a float as well now
let us go down and let us create the
function for flying friends so here we
can say that Define
flying friends this takes one argument
let us call that argument as friends
and and as you can see on line number 28
we are passing the argument of friends
and the type of friends is this one is
dictionary string and Float so let me
copy this right from here and let me go
back to my line number 18 so we can
Define the type right over here so this
friends is going to be a dictionary and
this function is not going to return
anything so I can just write none let me
also write some documentation for this
function
so what this function is going to do is
this function is going to display all of
the flying and non-flying friends now
remember that this function is creating
a side effect this function is not going
to return anything that's why we can say
that this function creates a side effect
now let us go down and let us Define the
body of this function so here what we
can do is we can use a for Loop to
iterate over the friends and see which
of the friends can fly or not
so I can see for the name and Earth
weight in the dictionary of friends
we want to get all of the items now
remember that the keys are the names so
if you see right over here the key is
the name that's why I'm naming this
parameter as name and the values are the
weight so that's what I'm calling as
Earth weight right over here
so for each iteration the first thing
that we want to do is we want to
calculate the weight in certain so let
me create a variable called as
zort and weed and here we need to
calculate but for calculation let us
create another function called as
calculate weight so let me write the
function first and then we will create
it so calculate weight would be my
function and I need to pass my Earth
weight to it now let us go up and Define
this function
we have defined this function in our
last video so let me open up that file
right over here so the file was called
as weight dot pi and I just have to copy
this go back to my current file
let me collapse my sidebar and let me go
to the top
and we can paste it right over here let
me also add some documentation
so what this function is doing is this
function is calculating your weight in
zorton
so this is an example of data
transformation it is taking a weight in
kgs and it is returning the same weight
but in short and in weight you can also
say that this function is a pure
function since it takes one input and
gives back one output now let us go back
to our function of prime friends
so on line number 36 we are able to
calculate the weight in zorton
now the next thing to do is we just need
to check if we can fly or not so here we
can say that if and here we need one
more function to check if we can fly or
not so first let me write it and then we
will create the function we can call
that function as can fly
and we need to pass the weight in
shorten so let me pass my zorton weight
now let us go up and create this
function as can fly so just let me go
right over here
and I can Define my function as can fly
this function accepts weight and the
type would be a float and this function
is going to return a Boolean value
let me write some documentation for this
as well
so the only responsibility of this
function is it is going to see if you
can fly or not that's why we have the
written value as the Boolean
so this function is also a very nice
example of data transformation
so you can see that we are accepting a
data which is of the type of fluid then
we are transforming the data and we are
transforming from a float value to a
Boolean value
let us see how we can write the body of
this function
now the body of this function is very
simple we just have to say that we have
to return
if my weight is less than or equal to
our constant of Maximum flying weight
so what we are doing is we are basically
composing functions where each function
has only a single responsibility for
example this function of can fly the
only responsibility of this function is
to say you if you can fly or not
now the only responsibility of this
function calculate weight is just to
transform the weight from the Earth to
the Sorting in weight now let us go back
on line number 47 we have created this
function can fly now this function is
retaining a bull value so we can use it
with our if and else blocks let me take
it a little up
so here we can see that if the friend
can fly then we can simply print out a
nice statement saying that here we can
put the name and then you can display
the weight in zorton and then we can say
kgs can fly on Jordan
else that means the friend can't fly in
that case let us print out another
statement saying that
the name followed by the certain weight
can only walk on zorton let us save it
and let us try running this file but
before we can run this file we have to
invoke our main function so let me go at
the bottom and here I can say that I
want to invoke my main function so I can
say mean followed by our brackets let me
save it and now let's run this file so
here we have the output
CC the weight is 10.75 in shortened so
she can fly but for Nico Nico weighs
16.75 so he can only walk on zorton and
similar with zico as well
so getting back to our program what we
have done is we have seen how to create
functions which can have a single
responsibility principle now let us
understand one more very important part
of functions and that is how we can work
with variable arguments and variable
keyword arguments let me create a file
over here and let me name it as
arguments and keyword arguments that
means args and kwarts for short
let me put up some comments
the first thing that I want to show you
inside this program is all about
unpacking first we will see how we can
unpack a couple of data structures in
Python and once we understand unpacking
then we can move to the variable and the
keyword variable arguments so the first
thing that I want to show you is all
about unpacking suppose you have a tuple
like this Lewis and Zappa you can unpack
the values of this Tuple in a single
line so on the left I can say that my
Lewis would be my first name so I can
write fname
and Zappa would be my last name so I can
say l name
and that's it this is called as Tuple
unpacking Lewis would be assigned to
this variable and Zappa would be
assigned to this variable just to
confirm let us print out the values and
see what we are getting
and you can see we are getting the right
values
now let's see how we can unpack a list
suppose you have a list like this and I
want to unpack this list but while
unpacking I only want the first value
inside a variable and I want all of the
rest into a separate list
we can do this by using a special syntax
so I can say first then I can say star
rest of the values is equal to my list
so let's see what's happening the first
value that means cc is assigned to this
variable and Roku Chico and Nico inside
a list is being assigned to this
variable we can name the variables
whatever you want let's try to print out
the value and check if we are getting
the right output or not let me run the
file
and here you can check the output
let me take it up
the first value is CC and that's what we
are getting right over here rest is a
list of all of the remaining values
Rocco Chico and Nico that's what we have
right over here next let us see how we
can unpack a dictionary suppose we have
an existing dictionary like this so this
is for specifications
type is dynamic optional static typing
and it is found everywhere let us create
a new dictionary and let us try to
unpack the existing dictionary into it
so let me call the new variable as Lang
and I can see
name is python
now I can unpack the entire dictionary
right over here by using a very special
syntax so I can say star star
followed by the name of the dictionary
that we want to unpack so the name of
the dictionary is specs
that's it let us print it out and see
what we are getting
and as you can see we have the right
dictionary so the name is Python and
here you can see we have unpacked the
entire other dictionary as well now
let's go back to our program now let's
try to think of a situation where we
would use this functionality suppose we
have a function and this function has to
accept unknown number of arguments at
that time we can use this functionality
now suppose we have a function called as
unknown friends
and we don't know the number of friends
that we are going to get in the
arguments so here I can see that we are
going to receive variable argument and
that variable argument I can declare by
writing so star and the name of the
variable as a convention whenever we are
getting variable arguments we name that
variable as args now let's go to the
body and see what we can do with this
one let's try to Simply print out the
values so I can say for
my friend in my arguments
I simply want to print out my friend oh
it has to be friend not friends so
this looks good
now let's see how we can add types to
this function
by default python is going to pack all
of the variable arguments inside a tuple
so essentially what's happening is this
argument is going to be of the type of
Tuple and since this function is not
returning anything this is going to
return
none let us invoke this function on the
next line so I can say my unknown
friends
and here let me pass a couple of friends
so I am passing an unknown number of
friends
now adding type in to this variable it's
a little tricky because by default RX is
a tuple but we can say this Tuple is of
the type of string and that's it this is
how we would add type hints to our
variable arguments this simply means
that our variable of args is a tuple and
the data type inside the Tuple is of the
type of string
let us try to save this file and let me
try to run it
and we have the right output we can see
all of the friends right over here so
all of these friends are coming from
this line
right over here line number 33 now
similarly we can also accept keyword
arguments now what do you mean by
keyword argument first let me write the
program and then I will explain what
exactly I mean by a keyword argument so
let me put up a comment
so suppose we have a function called as
unknown product and this function
accepts a variable keyword arguments so
that can be denoted by two stars and by
convention we always name the variable
as
kwarjs that means keyword arguments now
let's see what we can do inside the body
of this function
now what python is going to do is it is
going to pack all of the keyword
arguments in the form of a dictionary
so we can simply print out the key
and the value
from our keyword arcs
dot items
and let us print it out I can also write
this in a short form V for value and K
for for the key and here I can simply
say I want to print out
my key
and
my value
now let me try to invoke this function
by passing keyword arguments so this is
the place where all the things are going
to get cleared so I can say my unknown
product and the keyword arguments would
look something like this
name is equal to Pizza price is equal to
3.99 topping is equal to olives and so
on
so you can see all of the arguments are
in the form of the key and the value the
key and the value
so that's why we call this variable as a
variable keyword argument
by default it's always going to be in a
form of a dictionary now let's see how
we can add types to this one
now adding types for this one is really
very tricky
if you see our keyword arguments the
first one is a string the next one is a
float
the last one is a Boolean so we don't
know what kind of argument we can get
inside the dictionary
so this time what we can say that the
values can be anything so I can write
the type as any and let me import any
from our typing Library
so on the top I can say
from typing
I want to import any so what this really
means is since we don't know the value
of the type of the dictionary we are
going to accept any kind of a value and
since this function is not going to
return anything we can say that the
return type is none let's try to run our
program and here is output let me just
take it up
so for the variable keyword arguments we
have name price toppings and extra
cheese
and that is what we have right over here
now let's see how we can combine both of
these Concepts together
that means let us combine the variable
arguments and the variable keyword
arguments in a single function
so let me put up a comment over here
suppose I have a function called as
invoice
wherein I am supposed to generate an
invoice for a product but I don't know
what is the product I don't know the
characteristics of the product then how
do I handle this situation so let's see
how we can Define the function
the first argument can be the name of
the product so I can simply write as
product
the type is going to be a string
after that since we don't know what the
product is all about or the different
varieties of the product we can simply
write that we can also accept a variable
argument right over here now suppose the
user gives an argument in the form of
keywords we can handle that situation as
well by using our keyword argument so we
can say double star
keyword and args
and this time let us simply print out
our product arguments and our keyword
arguments so I can say I want to print
out my product let me copy and paste
then I want to print out my arguments
then I want to print out my keyword
arguments now since this function is not
good written anything so I can say that
it's going to return none
now let's try to invoke this function so
let me go down over here I can say
invoice
my product would be
sneakers
now suppose the sneakers are available
in black and white color so I can give a
variable number of arguments so I can
say
black
and white
we can also Define a couple of keyword
arguments over here suppose we know the
name of the brand so we can say my brand
is equal to me bits Nike
the category would be my Air Jordans
price could be
899.99 dollars
in
stock would be a Boolean value and let
me assign it a value of
false these stickers are not in stock
let me save my file so as you can see my
formatter which is black it
automatically formats my file now let me
save the file and let me run it for the
last time and here we have the output so
let me just
take this down
the product is our stickers so that's
what we are getting over here now this
arguments by default this is going to be
a tuple so that's why we have a tuple
over here and the keyword arguments this
is always going to be packed as a
dictionary so that's why we have the
last line as a dictionary
there is one more important concept that
I want to cover and after that we can
move on to our game
this concept is called as your local and
Global variables
for this I want you to create a new
folder right over here
and I want you to call that folder as
scratch pad
you can utilize this folder for adding
small programs and for doing small
experiments I always create and use a
scratch folder let's create one file
inside of this folder
and let me name it as
variable Scopes let me put up a heading
right over here so we are going to talk
about global and local scopes for that
let us try to understand One More
Concept
all of these files that we are creating
these files are technically called as
modules
so in the world of python all of these
files are modules now let's go back to
our file
inside our module if we declare a
variable like this num is equal to 10
that means this variable has a global
scope that means anyone inside our
module can use this variable any
function or any functionality or any
variable inside the module can use this
variable so let's create a function
called as print Global num
and this is simply going to print out
our number
let me save it and let me invoke it
right over here so I can say print
Global number we can do a slight
improvement over here we can use a
formatted string and we can say
Global number is and this is my number
now let us try to execute this file
and we have a output saying that the
global number is 10. now let us see what
happens if we declare one more function
and if you declare the same variable
inside that function so let me create a
new function by the name of
print num
this does not accept anything and inside
this function let me assign a value of
20
to the variable of num
and let us try to print out and see what
values we are getting over here so I can
use my formatted string my local number
is the now
let us invoke this function and let us
see what we are getting
let me
run this file
and here is output
now watch closely what's happening
on line number eight we have declared
that the num is 10.
and on line number 16 we are saying that
num is equal to 20.
now what happens is whenever python sees
we have the same variable
python is going to create a new variable
called as num and this variable is
available only inside our variable of
print num and that's it
so this is also called as variable
shadowing now please keep in mind that
this variable shadowing can introduce a
lot of bugs and this bugs can be really
difficult to debug
just to demonstrate let me go right over
here and let me say I want to print my
num
let me save it and let me try to
run it
so here you can see the global num is 10
but on the second line the local number
is 20. and this 20 is coming from our
line number line number 17 so this
variable is accessible only inside this
function and it is not valid outside
outside only this number that we have
declared on line number eight is visible
that's why we are getting the output of
10 right over here now let us see how we
can access This Global variable and how
we can do some operations on it let us
create a new function by the name of
increment number here we simply want to
increment our number by 2 so we can say
my num
plus equal to 2.
but what's happening right over here is
python is seeing that we are doing some
sort of an operation on num so python is
going to create a new variable we want
to increment the global num
so we have to explicitly tell python
that hey python I want you to use
the global num
and that's it let me put up some
comments so I have a comment for this
one and this one is my function or my
local scope and this one for my Global
declaration
let me save it now let me increment the
number and then we can print it out so
let me say that I want to increment the
number
let me save it and let me try to run it
so this time you can see the global
number is 12. now let's see one more
behavior of the global number so here
let me create a new function
by the name of increment my local num
and here I am saying that my new number
is is equal to my existing number
plus of 10.
and let me print out my new number right
over here now can you tell me what is
going to be the output of line number
13. well we don't have to guess we can
simply run the program and let's see
what output we are getting so let me
invoke the function right over here so I
can say
my new function I want to invoke it let
me save the file and let me run it
so as you can see I am getting the
output as 22. let us see what's
happening right over here so as you can
see on land number 29
the value inside num is 12 you can see
that's what it is and since we are
creating a new variable and we are
trying to assign value to the new
variable
python is taking this num from the
global scope
in the global scope the value is 12 and
we are trying to add 10 that's why the
new number is 22. in the next video we
will go back to our game and let us see
how we can divide all of the logic into
small functions
now let's see how we can use functions
inside our game so I want to do just
copy this file from folder number four
to our folder number five
and I want to just rename this file from
number 2 to number three
and that's it and let me also change the
documentation for this module in this
video we are going to concentrate on two
main things the first concept is called
as dry that means don't repeat yourself
what this means is whenever we have some
kind of a logic that is repeating at
that time we want to take the logic out
and put that logic inside a function and
we can keep on using that function
wherever we require it the next one is
what I've already shown you this is
called as single responsibility
principle that means we want to Define
our functions in a way that one function
will ideally do one job at a time
let's see how we can do all of these
things
let me go down over here so here you can
see that we have a list of all the
superheroes and all of our super
villains
so what I can do is I can create a
function that will return the list of
all of this superheroes and
supervillains as well now why do we need
to do this the answer is we want to
isolate parts of our program
suppose you are working in a team and
you don't want any other developer to
add or subtract from your list of
characters so that's why we need to have
some sort of an isolation so let us
create a function for superheroes and
supervillains as well let me put a
comment right over here so this block is
going to be for my superheroes let me
Define a function called as get all
superheroes this is not going to take
anything and let me take all of these
things inside my function and since I am
going to return a list of superheroes I
will also cut my line from 51
and I'll put it inside my function
which is right over here
I also need to return my list so I'm
going to use the keyword of return and I
want to return my list of superheroes
now since my function is returning a
list of characters so the return type of
my function would be
like this so this function is going to
return a list of characters till now I
have been using this keyword of final
because I just wanted to show you that
whenever we type everything in capital
that symbolizes a constant and we don't
want to change the value in the future
but these days your code editor and my
pack is smart enough to infer that if we
write everything in capital we can
actually skip writing final so I am just
going to take it out what I can do is I
can just leave Final on this line number
40 just as a reference for you
and let me take it out
right over here and this one and this
one let me see my file if you just hover
over any of the variable you can see
that we have the word of constant that
means my pi and your code editor they
are able to correctly in for that this
is a constant let us create one more
function to get a particular superhero
in this function we can get all of the
superheroes but what happens if we want
to get a particular superhero and
remember this is a list of superheroes
so we can get a particular superhero if
we know the index suppose the index
number is 1 so we can return Black Widow
if the index number is 3 then we can
return Hulk and so on so let's create a
function to return a single superhero
let's create a function right over here
so I can say Define a function called as
get superhero this function is going to
accept one parameter called as index of
the type of integer
and let us see what this function is
going to return
this function is going to return a
character
but what happens if we can't find a
character in that case we also have to
return none
so this function is either going to
return a character or it is going to
return none
let's see how we can implement the logic
let me add some documentation right over
here but before we can get a superhero
we need the list of our superheroes
but that's pretty easy we just created
an entire function for this so I can
just say
that my
superheroes is equal to the function get
all superheroes and that's it we have
the list of all our superheroes now
let's see the logic of getting a single
superhero from the list of superheroes
we already know how to work with indexes
but this time we have to be a little
more careful what happens if we get
index number which does not exist in
that time our program will panic and it
will exit but we don't want this kind of
a behavior
let me go to my IPython shell and let me
show you what I'm talking about
suppose I have a list called as
my characters would be
a b c and d here you can see the length
is 4 so I have four characters so the
length is four but my index number stops
at 3. so this is my index number 0 index
number one index number two and index
number three we don't have a index
number four
now what happens if I say I want to get
characters on my index number 4. this is
going to cause an error let's see what's
happening so as we can see we have an
error and the error is the index is out
of range and we want to avoid this
situation inside our program because we
don't want our program to panic and exit
so let's go back and here we can say
if my index
so if my index is less than the length
of my list of superheroes only then I
can have the right index number so here
I can say I simply want to return
from the list of superheroes the
superhero at the given index
else we have some issue and here I can
return
none because we can't find a superhero
let me just save my file let's do the
same logic for our super villains as
well let me put up a comment these blogs
are for my villains let us Define a
function get all villains
this is going to return a list of my
characters
and let me take all of these things
inside
and then I also want to return my list
so return villains
then we want one more function to get
our single villain so let me copy and
paste this block
so this goes right over here
this becomes from superheroes to villain
and that's it so now we have a way of
getting a particular character and and
how to get a list of our characters now
let's see where we can use this logic
the place where we want to use this is
right over here on line number 98 and 99
here you can see we first generate a
random index and after that we want to
get a superhero given that index
let me use the function right over here
but before we can use this function as
we can see we have a block for the
attack we can create a function for the
attack and we can isolate this
functionality as well so let's start
doing that so let me add a comment
saying that this is the main Logic for
the game
and I can define a function called as
attack
this is going to return nothing so I can
say none
and let me take all of these things
inside
my function so all of this things goes
inside my function
let us change this logic so this becomes
I want to get
super hero from the given hero index
and this becomes
and get my villain
from the given index just save a file
and you can see we have a bunch of
Errors let's start addressing this
errors one by one
first thing that I want to change is
this variable what I mean to say attack
is the attack number so we can improve
the name of the variable from Attack to
attack number
let me change right over here as well so
as you can see inside my print statement
I'm using this variable so this also
needs to be changed from Attack to
attack number there is one more final
point that I want you to think
if you see at the definition of our get
superhero we are returning a character
or none
so what happens if we don't have a
superhero or if you don't have a villain
in that case we can't have a fight let's
create some logic to handle this as well
so here after this line I can say
if
I have a superhero and if I have villain
so my current villain
only in that case I can do something let
me write a comment over here so if you
have a superhero and we have a super
villain in that case we are going to
have the attack
else that means we don't have a
superhero we don't have a super villain
that means we have an error so let me
print out a message saying that error no
superhero or villains to fight now let
us go to this line land number one or
four
what happens if we have a valid hero and
a valid villain then we need to have an
actual attack so all of this logic from
line number 108 to 117 should go right
over here but we are going to create one
more function to simulate the attack if
you're wondering why do we require so
many functions
the answer is for flexibility if in the
future you have some more characters if
you are fighting seeing changes then you
can change only a single function and
the changes would be reflected
throughout your program
so we want to have our program as
modular as possible
that's the reason why we are creating so
many different functions first let me
invoke the function and then I will
Define the function so the function
would be called as simulate attack
similar attack
now let's see what we need to pass to
this function the first thing that I
want to pass is my attack number
we can have only three attacks so that's
why we have the range of three over here
so I can say
the first parameter I want to pass is my
attack number then obviously we need the
superhero and we also need the super
villain
now let's go down to line number 107 and
let's create this function so let me
just copy
all of this
let me go down let me create a function
let me say that
Define function put my codes
let me add a command
I also need to adjust the spacing
because this is out of format
now let's work on this function so here
I don't need the word of current
this has to go this also has to go
it has to go from everywhere so let me
do a multi select
so this looks good let me save my file
everything is looking really good let me
put a comment right where so this is a
place where we are
setting the life this is where we print
some nice message and this is the place
where the actual attack is taking place
but I'm not really happy with this logic
here we are manually adding and we are
manually decrementing let us create
functions for this as well
you must be thinking that I have gone
crazy why do we require so many
functions let me ask you a question
suppose tomorrow the logic of the game
evolves and you have some bonus
attacking power or you have some bonus
life then what do you do so at that time
you simply have to change the logic in a
single function and that's it so let's
develop this habit of making the logic
inside different functions as possible
and let us try to stick to the principle
of single responsibility function
that means I want my function to do only
one job and also in the future when we
learn testing at that time testing
functions becomes a much more simpler
job so let's see what functions we are
going to require we are going to require
one function to increment the life of
the superhero
want to increment the life of the
villain
and then one more to decrement the life
of the villain and one more to decrement
the life of the superhero so we require
four different functions to do all of
these things so let me go to the top
and uh
here just below the characters let me
put up a comment so this block is for
the live let me go below and
I want to take this variables
to the top as well so let me paste it
right here and here we can start
creating our functions
the first one was to increment the hero
life
so this function accepts life which is
all the type of integer and it returns
nothing so it has to return none
let me put a comment now let's see how
to use the logic inside of this here I
have to operate on this variable
and if you remember the last video this
variable is defined on a global scope
that means I have to use the keyword of
global to reference this one so let me
go down over here and
let me say that I want to use the global
variable of
hero life
and let us increment the life so I can
say hero like is equal to
plus my life
and that's it
we can also use the shorthand syntax so
I can simply say
plus equal to
so let us copy and paste this one and
this time let us
decrement so I can say
decrement
this becomes
decreases this becomes minus equal to
and let us do the same thing for our
villain as well so let me copy all of
this
and let me put it over here
and my hero becomes villain so let me do
a multi select
and this becomes my
villain let me copy and paste this one
for the last time so this one to
decrement
so this becomes
decrement
decreases
minus equal to
let me save my file everything is
looking really good
let us go down and see what we are
supposed to do next
now once inside our function of simulate
attack let's see how we can use this
functionality but first let us set the
types for our function definition so the
attack number is my integer
my superhero is my character
villain is also of the type of my
character and this function is going to
return nothing so I can say none now
let's use the newly created functions so
we can use the function right over here
so I want to increment the life of
superheroes let me grab this
let me take it out and write the name of
the function this was to increment the
hero life
same thing will happen here also let me
take it out
put inside my brackets I want to
increment my life of the villain
let us do the same thing so here first I
want to decrement the life of the hero
so
let me put this inside my brackets
and I can see I want to decrement
the hero life
and let us do it
here as well
and here I can say
I can decrement
the villain life
just save your file and we can see we
have a couple of Errors so let's see
what's happening so what's happening is
my Pi is complaining because of
incompatible types for now you can
ignore the error but let me try and
explain what's happening all of these
errors will go away when we convert all
of the characters into classes in the
future videos but right now what's
happening is if we go to the definition
of our character
here you can see the values can either
be a string or an integer this is the
thing that my Pi is trying to complain
is saying that we can't add or we can't
subtract strings right over here
so that's why it is showing this error
so let's move on and let's go to the
next block
so this is the place where we are seeing
if we have lost or if we have won the
game we can create a function for this
as well so I can put up a command saying
that this is for my final game status
and let us Define a function called as
win or lose it's not going to accept
anything
and it is going to return nothing
let me take all of these things inside
we can slightly improve the code as well
on line number 164 and 166 we are
printing a statement so let us get those
variables inside our function so here
they are let me take them out
and and let me
paste it right over here
they have to have the right formatting
let me put up some documentation right
here
and a little space
let me save and see if everything is all
right or not everything looks good and
we have a very nicely typed program the
last thing to do is just to Define our
main function and we simply have to
invoke it writing the main function is
the most simplest thing so we can just
say
let me Define my main function
this is also going to return nothing so
this is the place where we would start
the game first thing is we want to have
an attack
the next thing is we want to check if we
have lost or won
and that's it the last thing to do is we
simply have to invoke this function so I
can just say main just save a file and
let me just browse if we have some
errors or not
we can ignore this error as I have just
explained
but let me check if we have some errors
no no everything is looking beautiful
all right so let's go down and let us
try and play this game beautiful it
looks like I have defeated Thanos in the
first try itself it's amazing
hi we are officially at the end of this
section
but I have decided to add one more bonus
video
now this bonus video is all about
teaching you higher order functions
now learning higher order functions can
be a little bit challenging for
beginners so I want you to just sit back
and relax and just watch as if you are
watching a movie
if you can understand the concept then
it's really amazing if you can't there
is nothing to lose and normally it will
take you multiple attempts maybe twice
or Thrice before you can understand the
concept
and which is perfectly fine I don't
blame you for that the concept itself
can be a little more challenging so just
enjoy and see if you can get it
welcome to the world of functions
let's start by understanding what are
functions and how they are managed
inside our memory so suppose we have a
couple of functions so here I have
defined two functions one is hello and
the next one is good morning
so these are pretty simple functions now
let's see what's happening inside our
memory
so this green area would be our memory
now please keep in mind that this is a
very simplified version in actual life
things are much more complicated let's
see what's going to happen now when
python comes across this line number
three and four it is going to create a
function called as hello inside our
memory so this is what is happening we
have a function called as hello inside
our memory now the next question is how
does python know how many functions it
has created inside the memory the answer
is python gives each and every object a
unique ID now what do I mean by an
object object is a generic term just
like all of us are human beings but we
are also animals same thing anything
inside the world of python is an object
a variable is an object a class is
object a function is object anything is
an object inside the world of python so
let me say python is going to create an
object which is also type type of
function inside the memory and the way
python is going to keep a drag of all of
the objects inside the memory is by
giving each one of them a unique ID it's
just like us every one of us has a
unique passport number so you can say
each one of us has a unique ID as well
the next question would be how does
python know where does the object live
it knows because it allocates some
address to the object it's just like us
every one of us has an address similarly
inside the world of python every object
which is created inside the memory also
has an address and this is how it looks
like now this format is a very special
format it is called as hexadecimal
format you can see this address always
starts with a 0 followed by an X so
whenever you see this format it means
it's an hexadecimal format it is just a
way of representating the memory inside
our computer now what happens when
python goes to next line line number
seven it sees that we have another
function so it goes back to the memory
and it creates another function by the
name of good morning
now good morning also has a unique ID
and it also has a unique address
so for example we can say good morning
has this address right over here we can
see this in action inside our IPython
shell so let me open up my IPython shell
so here it is so here I can see my
definition of hello it's simply printing
out hello world so here I'm just
creating a very simple function
let us see the ID of this function so I
can simply type I want to see the ID of
my function called as hello
so this is the unique ID of our function
you can also ask python to reveal the
type of this object so you can say I
want to see the type of hello
and the type is a function if you want
to see the address then we can say I
want to see the hexadecimal of the
object which has an ID of hello
and here it is so this is the address of
hello inside our memory let us create
one more function so let me Define a
function called as good morning and on
the next line I can say I simply want to
print
good morning
so we have another function let's see
the idea of good morning
now you can see we have a different ID
this ID ends in 144 the idea of hello
was 0 3 2. let us also check the address
of this one so I can say hex ID of good
morning
so you can see we have a different
address so this is F7 F0 and here it was
b370 so that means hello and good
morning are two different objects with
two different ID and with two different
address inside our memory
Let Me Clear My terminal
and now watch closely what happens if I
create a variable called discrete and if
I assign it the value of hello and if I
try to invoke greed
we have an output called as hello world
so what's this what's happening behind
the scenes now let us go back to our
diagram to understand what's happening
what's happening is python is actually
playing a trick with us
so this is the variable which we just
created
but if you check its address it has the
same address as hello
so in short what python is doing is it
is just creating a reference to hello so
the grid variable is just referencing
the function of hello it's just like
sharing your house and when we invoke
this function by using brackets so
when we use the bracket that means we
are invoking
here you can see I don't have the
bracket on line number 33 I am just
assigning the function of hello to grid
and on the next line I am using brackets
to invoke the function and when we
invoke the function we get the output of
hello world so what happens is when we
invoke grid it goes back
it says that grid is actually
referencing hello and behind the scenes
it's this function which is being
executed
but on the scene it looks like it's the
function called as grid which is being
executed
now let's get back to our code editor
and start writing some code
what I've done is behind the scenes I
have created a new file called as Hof
this stands for higher order functions
Dot py and I have created a couple of
comments for us
the type of function is also called as
callable
because this object can be called we can
give some arguments to it and we can get
some values from it that's why in the
world of python functions are also
called as callables if you're thinking
why do we need this kind of a
functionality the answer is till now we
have been passing data to the functions
but sometimes it can be very expensive
so what's the solution the solution is
passing the function to the data you
have to just start thinking in Reverse
so what we are going to do is we have
some data and we would be passing
functions to it imagine you have
terabytes and terabytes of data it would
be so expensive to transport all of this
data from one server to the another
server just for the sake of computation
instead we can simply pass a function to
the data and we can get our job done
much more easily so let's start by
creating the same function called as
hello right over here so
this is the function that we created the
next point I again want to reiterate
that function is just a regular object
of the type of function there is nothing
special about it now let us print let us
also try to print the ID of hello
and let us also try to print
the type of
let me run the file so here it is
let me take it up a little bit
okay so when I'm saying I just want to
print hello so hello is a function which
is present at this address
the ID is this one and the type
is actually a class of the type of
function let's get back and see what
else we can do now let's try to create a
variable and assign the value of hello
to that variable so let me put a command
and let us create the variable called as
grid and let me assign the value of
hello to it again remember I'm not
putting my brackets over here because I
am not invoking the function I am just
assigning the function hello to the
variable of grid now let us try to
invoke the function of grid so let me
write grid with the brackets let me save
the file and let me try to run the file
so here we have the output of hello
world let us go back and see how we can
add types to all of this variables I
just explained that hello is also called
as a callable inside the world of python
so the type of grid is actually a
callable type
let me go up and let me see that
from
typing
I want to import
callable
now let us go down
let us start adding our types right over
here so grid
is of the type of callable now if you
see the function of hello it is not
taking any arguments and it is returning
none
so what we can do is callable let us put
some brackets this means that grid is of
the type of volleyball and inside this
brackets we have to specify the input
arguments and the output of the function
and here inside the square brackets the
first argument is always a kind of list
and the second argument is the return
type of this function now let's see how
we can add the types hello it is not
accepting any arguments so the first
argument to callable would be empty next
our function of hello is returning none
so here after the comma I can say
it's a callable which returns none and
that's it we have a nicely typed
function as well let me add some
comments just for the sake of reference
so here we are just assigning the values
and here we are invoking the function
let us see what else we can do with our
functions let me put a separator and let
me put some comments
so this time we are going to create a
universal gritter remember I just
explained the concept that we can also
pass the functions to the data that's
what we are going to do right now I am
going to create a universal greeter that
takes two arguments the first argument
would be for the name and the second
argument will actually take a function
now suppose you want to grid Zola then
our universe are greater function will
grid as Zola if you want to create as
good morning then our function will
great as good morning
if you want to create as goodbye then
our function will great as goodbye
sounds awesome isn't it so first let me
type all of the functions and then I
will try to explain all of them let me
create the first function called as Zola
so what this function is doing is it is
simply taking one argument and it is
returning a Grita in the form of Zola
followed by the name let's create one
more function for good morning the next
would be for goodbye now let's create
our Universal Creator function so let me
put up a comment over here and I can see
my
Universal
greeter so this function is going to
accept
two parameters the first parameter is
the name
and let me get the spelling right string
the name is of the type of a string now
what should be the next argument
the next argument is of the type of a
function
let me name it as greet up
the type of this is callable
now let's see how we can Define the
types inside callable look at all of the
functions which I have created Zola good
morning goodbye
the function signature is common all of
these functions accept only one
parameter that two of the type of string
and all of this function returns a
single argument which is also of the
type of string
so that's what I am going to pass right
over here let's see how we can Define
the types so the first argument is a
list and the second argument is the
return type all of the functions are
returning strings so I can just write
string over here and all of the
functions are also accepting a string so
inside my inner brackets I can say
string so this is called as a function
signature
all of this function except one string
and return one string
same thing we are saying over here our
callable accepts one string and returns
one string
now let's see how we can Define the body
of this function let me add some
documentation
now here you will be amazed it is just
two lines function
the first thing that we want to do is
let us take the function of Grita
and pass it the argument of name that's
it
that's the entire Logic Let Me assign
the output to a variable called as
message
on the next line let me simply
print it out
just save a file
let me try to run the file and after
that I will again try to explain what's
happening but before that I want to
comment all of these things let me
comment out all of this I don't need all
of these things the grid function as
well
let us invoke our Universal greater
function and then we can have a nice
output so let me go right over here
and here let's see how we can invoke the
function so let me say Universal greeter
my name is
thallium
now let's see what we can pass as the
second argument if you see right here my
IDE is telling me that Glitter is also a
type of function
these brackets it denotes a function it
takes a string and it returns a string
so basically we can pass any functions
that satisfies this signature
and luckily all of our functions Zola
good morning and goodbye satisfy these
conditions so we are going to pass one
by one inside the universal reader for
the first one let me pass simply as Zola
now remember I don't have to put
brackets because I am not invoking I
simply have to pass my function and
that's it let me copy and paste
let me take a little up
the second one would be good morning
the last one would be goodbye that's it
just save a file
and let's try to run it and hopefully
this time we should have a nice output
wow it's so amazing single function can
produce multiple outputs now let's see
behind the scenes what's exactly
happening for example let us take just
this line line number 65 so Zola is
actually a function and this is how it
looks now let's go back to our
definition right over here this Zola
comes as a function called as greater
inside our function
now this greater is just a reference to
the function of Zola
let me open up my diagram one more time
so imagine this to be our greater
function and this to be Zola
so greater is just a reference to Zola
and whenever we invoke this function
behind the scenes the original function
is being evoked so let me go back to my
code so you can see on line number 61 we
have a new variable called as Grita so
this grid is actually a reference to
Zola we pass one argument of name to the
function
this name goes right over here and if
you see the function definition we are
returning a string called as Zola
followed by the name we are saving this
string inside a variable called as
message and we simply want to print it
out this is happening with each of the
functions
the second time what happens is we are
passing good morning now the second time
this greater over here this references
good morning and what good morning is
doing is it is simply returning a string
good morning followed by the name if we
capture this output inside this variable
right over here and we are printing it
out and the same thing goes with goodbye
as well that's the reason why every time
we have a unique output first time grida
was referencing Zola so we have Zola
octallium second time it was good
morning so we have good morning
octallium and the last time we had
goodbye so we have goodbye octallium
sounds pretty neat isn't it
now let's get back and let's try to
learn a little bit more about functions
let me put a separator
a function as we saw can accept a
function but a function can also return
a function
now this part really took me a couple of
attempts to understand so if you can't
get it don't worry
you will eventually get it so let's go
down and let's see how we can create a
function that accepts as well as returns
a function
let me put up a comment
let us see how we can create a function
that will return us a function
let me Define a function called as
add Wi-Fi
this takes one argument number which is
of the type of integer
now since this function actually returns
a function so we can say this is going
to return a callable
and we will Define the types A little
later on right now just go ahead and let
us type the body of the function
let me add some documentation
now what I'm going to do is I am going
to create one more function inside this
function
so let's create one more function
let me create a function called as by 5
and
this actually does not accept anything
and this function returns an integer
inside this let me say I want to return
the number that we get right over here
so I want to return that number
plus of 5 so this is the function inside
this one and since our outer function it
has to also return a callable so we need
to have a return statement
and this time I am simply going to
return my function which is going to be
this one called as Wi-Fi
first let us see the type hinting and
then we will try to understand what's
happening so let me go back to this line
so we know that this function is
supposed to return a callable type
now this callable type is actually this
function so now we can start adding
types to it so here goes my brackets
first one is for the inputs
after the comma is for the output this
function is returning an integer so let
me write
int over here and this function is not
accepting anything so this argument
remains blank
just save a file so this is also called
as your higher order function
let's see how we can work with these
functions let me say that a new variable
called as sum is equal to
my function of add by Phi is
let me pass a argument of 5 if it is
hover over right over here so your IDE
is also telling you that the return type
is a function which accepts nothing but
returns an integer so what's happening
is a variable of sum now this is
referencing to this variable which is
inside
we can also invoke some and let's see if
we are getting the right output or not
so I can say print and sum
and that's it the reason why we are not
giving any input right over here is
because sum is referencing this function
right over here and this function does
not accept any argument that's why it is
blank let me just save it and let me try
to run this file and here we have the
output of 10.
so this Phi plus this Phi is equal to
10. well we can also written a function
that accepts an argument
that means we can create a function
which can actually accept something and
do with the data
so this time let us create a new
function called as universal adder but
this Adder is going to be a little
unique
this Adder is going to add to numbers
and subtract by one it's our own add-up
so let me go down over here let me take
it up
let me add a comment
and let us Define a function called as
our unique adder
now this accepts one number so this is
going to be our first number so let me
call it as num1
the type is integer this also returns a
callable
we will add types shortly
let me add some documentation now let us
create one function right over here
but this function is going to accept
another number
and we are going to return this number
plus another number minus of 1.
so I can say Define
our adder
this function also accepts one argument
let me call it as num2
type of integer
and this one returns an integer
and let us place our logic right over
here
so since this is a unique Adder what we
want to do is
we want to add the first number
the second number and minus of 1.
let us go below and complete the
function by adding our return statement
so we can say
this function right over here this is
going to return a callable and this time
this callable is going to be Adder so we
can say return Adder
let us Define the typing for this one so
our brackets
one more brackets inside for the input
argument and the next one for the
written argument
let us see this function this function
is returning an integer so we can say
integer right over here and this
function is also accepting one integer
so inside this brackets I can say
integer
and that's it we have a beautifully
typed function as well
let's try to invoke this function and
let us see if it is doing its job or not
so my order would be my unique Adder let
me pass one argument of five
and as you can see this is returning one
more function and the function signature
is integer returning an integer
let us print out the value let me use my
print statement
adder and here I want to give my next
number
so I want to add Phi and Phi let us see
what output we should get so I want to
add my 5 with my 5 but minus of 1 so the
output should be 9 so let me save my
file and let us try running it
and here we have the output of 9.
let us go back and let us try to study
what's happening
so what's happening is our function of
unique Adder is returning another
function
so this Adder is referencing the return
callable from this function and the
return callable is this function right
over here so in short add a is
referencing this Adder over here
let us try with one more example so let
me add
four
and three the output should be four plus
three seven minus one six let me save it
and let me try to run it and here we
have the output of six let me put it
back to five and five
now let us move to the last part which
is called as a Lambda
let me put a separator line over here
and let me put some comments so we are
going to learn about Lambda now lambdas
are pretty simple but they are often
neglected
trust me they are not really complicated
it is just a different way of declaring
your functions
let me first type and then I will show
you what's exactly happening let me go
to the top
right over here
now this is a function called as hello
let us see how we can Define this hello
using a Lambda
so I can say my new function called as
hello number two
would be
a Lambda Lambda simply means a function
now this function is not accepting any
arguments so we can just write colon but
this returns a string so we can say this
is going to return
hello world and that's it it's so simple
the entire function can be condensed
into a single line let me copy this and
let me go back to my IPython shell
and let's play over there so let me
paste it right over here and I can
invoke my Hello to just a circular
function and we have the output of hello
world
so lambdas are just your regular
functions but they are declared in a
different way suppose this function
accepts one argument then that argument
will come before this columns let me
take it out and let me show you one more
example
let us go right over here for Zola so I
can say my Zola number two
would be my Lambda now this function of
Zola accepts one argument as name so I
can write name
and this returns a formatted string so
you can just copy
and
paste it right over here and that's it
we have a Lambda function ready
let me copy this and paste it in my
IPython shell let me paste it
and that's it
let us invoke this one Zola to
octallium
I forgot to close the string let me
close it
and we have the output of Zola octalium
it's pretty simple isn't it
let me again take it out
so just for the sake of practice let us
create one function which will act like
a calculator now just imagine your
calculator it's a single calculator but
it can do multiple functions it can do
addition subtraction Division and so on
so we are going to try and mimic the
same functionality by using lambdas so
here let me create my first Lambda by
the name of ADD
so I can say this is going to be a
Lambda
this accepts two number so my number one
and my number two
and this is just going to return the sum
so I can say number one
Plus
number two if you notice we don't use
the keyword of written inside the Lambda
because whatever value that comes after
the colon it's automatically returned
let me save this one
now as a convention the arguments for
Lambda functions are written as X and Y
but you can write num1 and num2 but
right now just for the sake of
Simplicity let me convert this to X and
Y so let me Define
multi select this argument becomes my X
and the next argument becomes my y
let us see how we can add types to our
function
so as we know Lambda is nothing is just
a function and we know the function is
also called as a callable we can say it
is of the type of callable
now inside the first brackets are for
the inputs the next one is for the
output
now let us see what's happening our
function of Lambda is accepting two
inputs this is the first one and this is
the second one and we want to say that
both of the inputs should be of the type
of integer so let's go back right over
here and we can say the first argument
is an integer the second argument is an
integer as well and we are returning a
single value so we can say this function
is going to return a single value of a
type of integer and that's it let us
create one for subtract and one for
multiply so let me just copy and paste
this would be for subtract
I just have to make a very small change
this has to be x minus
and this one would be for multiply again
this is X into
so you can see it's so simple let's
define a calculator on the next line so
I can say Define calc
now let's see the inputs so obviously we
required two numbers so I can say my
first one is an integer the second one
is also an integer
and the third one is going to be a
function let me call that function as
operation
so we are going to operate on both of
this number that's why I'm going to call
this function as operation we can call
anything that you want the type of this
one is exactly the type of this one so I
just have to copy and paste
from here to here
now let's go to the return type
and this is going to return an integer
so what's happening is we have a Lambda
it is taking two integers and it is also
giving an integer in return so this is
what we want to return so this integer
comes from here to here
and inside let me put some documentation
here the written statement is extremely
simple
we simply want to execute the operation
on both our numbers so number one and
number two that's it and we simply have
to return the output so I can say return
save your file and we have a nicely
defined calculator as well let's try to
invoke our function and let's see if we
are getting the right output or not let
us try adding 4 and 5 so I can say I
want to print
the output of my calculator
I want to add 4 and 5 and the operation
here is going to be this add operation
so I can just pass that function right
over here I can say add
next let us do subtract and multiply as
well so this will be
subtract and this would be
multiply
save your file and let us try it running
for the last time
and here is output
4 plus 5 is 9 4 minus 5 is -1
4 multiplied by 5 is 20 well that's it
for this video I hope you really enjoyed
working with functions more you start
practicing with functions more you will
start loving them and once you are
hooked to functions you will never want
to go back again
and if you want to learn the functional
approach of programming
then perhaps python may not be the right
programming language because python is
an object oriented language if you want
to learn more about the functional
aspect then you can learn languages such
as Elixir Haskell and Scala those
languages are built around the
functional approach
welcome to a brand new section this
section is all about object oriented
programming
even though the name sounds pretty big
but the concept is not so difficult some
of the main aspects of object oriented
programming are classes instances
inheritance and polymorphism
so I will be covering all of those
inside this series let's go to our code
editor and let's start creating some
classes behind the scenes I have created
one more folder called as zero six oops
and inside of this folder I have created
a file called as basic dot pi and I have
posted some documentation right inside
this file first let us create a class
and then we will see what is it all
about and after that I will come to all
of this documentation so let me collapse
my sidebar
so let me go below and
let us create our very first class so we
can use the keyword of class
followed by the name of the class let me
just call it as some class I don't care
the name right now
the next line is for the documentation
of the class so let me add some
documentation saying that defines an
empty class and inside of this I don't
want to pass any logic for now I want to
keep the body as empty
so I can simply say pass
and that's it we have created our very
first class let's try to print it out
and see what output we are getting so I
can say
I want to print out
some class let us save it and let us try
to run it and here we have the output
underscore underscore main underscore
underscore dot some class
now this output looks a little bit
cryptic and we will take care of these
things in the future but what this is
trying to say is in the main file
there is a class called as some class so
this sum class means this class
and this underscore underscore main
underscore underscore simply means the
main file
now this is just a naming convention
whenever we execute some python module
python behind the scenes names the main
module as underscore underscore main
underscore underscore so this double
underscores are also called as Dundas
python makes a lot of use of this
tenders and we would be seeing them
shortly let us go back and create some
more classes let me put a separator
let us create a class which represents a
person so I can say class
followed by the name of the class now
remember the name of the classes are in
Pascal case that means the first
alphabet of each word has to be Capital
if you check this class my S was capital
and C was Capital just make sure you
always follow this convention whenever
you want to define a class
now let's go right over here and create
a class of person
let me add some documentation that this
class defines a person now let's see
let's try to imagine a structure of a
person every person has a first name and
a last name so let us give this
properties to our class of person and we
can do that by using a Dunder method
which is called as init now don't fuss
over what is this method what is a class
and whatever I'm going to show you right
now this video is just to show you what
is the class and in the next video I
will explain you all of the things which
are happening behind the scenes right
now just go with the flow the first
function inside your class always has to
be a special function by the name of
Dunder in it so this is how you define
it Define
Dunder
in it
Dunder this is just a naming convention
by python we have a Dunder in the front
and under at the back
there is nothing special about this
function this is just like your regular
function just that we have a different
naming style for this one now since this
init function belongs to a class the
first argument should always be self
self actually acts like a reference it
means the instance of this class again
don't worry I will explain all of these
things in the next video this function
of init is going to accept two more
parameters the first one would be for
the first name of the person
the type is going to be a string next
one would be the last name
again a string and always remember that
this init method returns nothing so the
return type is going to be none and
inside let us see how we can construct a
person here we have to say that cell Dot
first name is equal to first name so
what I am trying to do is I am just
taking the first name and I am creating
an instance variable called as first
name
now this can be anything I can also name
it as
if name and I can write this as F name
it doesn't really matter
the same goes for this one you can call
this ABC it doesn't matter but if you
are writing ABC over here then this also
has to be ABC but as a convention it is
normally cell
and let me change this to my first name
let us create one more instance variable
for the last name so I want to say
for my instance of a person so that
means for self Dot
last name is equal to last name so the
same thing I am taking the last name
from my init method and I'm creating
something which is called as an instance
variable right over here now let's see
how we can work with this class so I
want to say my first person is a type of
person the first name is Lewis
the last name is Zappa let me save this
and let us try to print
first person that's it let me comment
this out I don't want this one and let
me run this file
and here we have one more cryptic output
saying that it is main dot person object
at so and so address
if you have seen my last lecture about
higher order functions you can make it
out that this is a hexadecimal address
for this object let us go back and see
if we can improve this one let us create
one more Dunder method and this time the
name of the random method is called as
underscore underscore r e p r
so this stands for representation
underscore underscore and self always
remember the first argument by default
inside a class should always be self now
this is going to return a string so I'm
going to put a string over here
and let me just say return and I am
going to return a string so I can just
say inside my codes that this is a
class of the type of
person
that's it just save a file and try to
run it so this time we have a much
better output so this underscore
underscore init and underscore
underscore repr these are also called as
magic methods python is always going to
look for this magic methods whenever it
has to create an instance of the person
class let me add some
documentation over here
so this magic method of repr is also
known as the official representation of
your class now let's see one more magic
method let us open up the terminal one
more time and to be frank this output
doesn't make much sense except that this
is saying it is just a class of the
person
it is not giving any details of which is
a person what the first name what is the
last name and so on
but we can improve this by using one
more magic method and this time the name
of this magic method is underscore
underscore Str so I can say Define my
Str
so this Str simply means for the string
representation of the class and as a
convention it has to accept self as the
first argument
this method also returns string
let me add the documentation saying that
this magic methods provides string
representation of an instance I will
explain all of these things in the next
video instance and classes right now
just go with the flow and complete this
video so here I can say I want to return
a string let me construct one string by
using our string formatting
so I can say person
the way to get the first name and the
last name is using this syntax self DOT
first name inside this curly brackets I
simply have to say I want to get
the first name of this instance
so self is acting as a reference it is
telling python I want to fetch the first
name of this particular person only so
let us have the last name as well so we
can say self Dot last name
let us save the file and let us try to
run it
so this time we have a much better
output and this output also makes some
sense that this is a person and the name
of the person is Louis Zappa
let us create one more person let me put
up a comment first over here
so what we are doing is we are creating
an instance of the class of person let
us create one more person so I can say
the second person would be person the
first name could be CC let me get the C
capital and her surname could be
Neutron
let us printed out
let me print out my second person
save your file and just run it and here
we have the output the second person is
CC the first person is Lewis
so I think we have learned enough for
this first video in the next video I
will explain all of these things and
hopefully you would have a better
understanding of classes
now let us try to demystify our classes
so this is the class of person that we
have created in the last video
for this slide I had to slightly
compress the syntax so we can see some
of the namings are different from the
names that we gave the last time
so just go with the flow so this was the
class that we created last time the name
of the class is called as a person and
we have a couple of magic methods inside
of this one
now let's see what's happening inside
our memory
so as usual this is our memory and let's
see what's going to happen next python
will see that we have a class called as
person and it is going to create a class
inside its memory
now this class doesn't hold any data
this class that you can see over here
this is just like a design or rather it
is just like a blueprint for a building
but we don't have the building yet and
how do we know what is the design of
this class we can see the design of this
class with the special method called as
init
this method is also called as the
Constructor or the initialization of our
class so let me repeat
this is just a class it does not hold
any data it is just like a design or
blueprint now let us see what's going to
happen on our line number 15. whenever
we are creating an object of the type of
person
that time we say that we are creating an
instance of the class of person
so let's see what's going to happen
python is going to take the design of
person from our underscore underscore
init method so it's going to take the
design so we have the design
and it's going to create an instance by
the name of person one
so as you can see we have an instance by
the name of person one
so that is being constructed inside our
memory the same thing happens with
person 2 as well python is going to take
the design of person
and it is going to create an instance of
person two so here it is so this is the
basic difference between a class and an
instance class is like the basic
blueprint or the design
and an instance is an object of the type
of class so person one and person 2 are
called as instances the design is called
as a class now if you have seen my
earlier video about higher order
functions you must be knowing that
different objects have different memory
address
so person number one and person number
two are completely different objects and
they have a completely different memory
address just imagine that this is the
memory address for person one
and this is the memory address for
person number two now let's see what's
happening behind our Constructor or our
Dunder init method so this method is
just acting like fill in the blanks so
you can see our Constructor this is for
the first name and this is for the last
name
and you can see right over here first
name and the last name this init method
just acts like a fill in the blanks
so it's going to take Lewis from here
and it is going to put it right over
here
is going to take Zappa and it is going
to put it right over here
so that's what is happening
so if you see inside the memory when the
first instance is created
init method is going to assign the first
name to Lewis and the last name to Zappa
same thing is going to happen with
person number two as well whenever we
are creating this instance the init
method is going to assign
the last name sorry this has to be first
name not last name
the first name to CC and the last name
to Neutron
the last thing that I wanted to explain
is all about this keyword of self
now self only acts as a reference that
means it tells python on which instance
do I populate in the data or if you want
to get the data it simply tells python
from which instance do I have the data
let me show this in action let us go
back to the previous class which is
right over here and on the next line let
us print out the first name for both the
persons so I can say I want to print out
my first person's
first name
and let us do the same thing for the
second person as well
the save a file and let us try to run it
and you can see we have a different
output
let me take it up the first person's
first name is Lewis
the second person's first name is CC the
way python can keep a track of this is
because of the keyword of self so this
first name belongs to the instance of
this one
so let me show in the diagram whenever
we are printing the first name of the
first person the self references to the
instance on this memory address so
python can correctly retrieve the date
of Lewis and that's what we are seeing
on our terminal so let me open up the
terminal and this is what we get and
similarly when we say we want to print
out the first name of the second person
let us go back to the diagram the self
is telling python that this time the
person is actually this one and this
person can be found at this address
so the first name this time would be CC
and not Lewis
I hope now we have a much better
understanding of classes instances
objects Constructor and so on now let us
move on in the next video
we just saw that instances have
different memory address let me go back
to diagram
so here I explained that this instance
has a different memory address and this
instance has a different memory address
now let's see that in action let us go
back to our code
and here let me put up a comment
and I don't want this one so I can take
it out
this one as well and let's print out the
memory address of our P1 and P2 as well
so I can say print my formatted string
and I can say P1 is located at memory
address and if you have seen my video on
higher order functions we know that we
can get the memory address from hex
and then inside we require the ID of the
object
and we require the ID of P1
let me copy and paste it this time it
has to be P2 this also has to be P2
just save it and let us try to run it so
here we can see P1 is located at this
address so here you can see this is four
seven six three f
and P2 is 479 e d so you can see we have
two different instances at two different
memory locations and both of them have
taken the design from the class of
person and the Constructor was our init
method let's create one more function
inside our class
so let us create a simple function for
grid
so I can say Define grid
and as you know the first argument
should always be the self
always acts like a reference and this
one actually does not return anything so
I can say none
and here I can say print
formatted string
let me put the first name
self DOT first name
and then I can print a message saying
that first name says hello that's it
just save your file now just one small
technical detail all of the functions
that we create inside the class they are
called as methods so let me put up a
comment over here so
this is a method that prints a greeting
message
so methods and functions is the same
thing the only difference is that
methods are always tied to some class
that's why they are called as methods
now let's see how we can call this
methods
so let me go right over here let us get
the first instance so we can say P1
and we can call the method by Dot and
the name of the method so we can say I
simply want to invoke the method of grid
on the first person we can do the same
thing on the second person as well so I
can say
second person and let me put up a
command
that's it let me save and let me run it
and here we have the output Lewis says
hello CC says hello
if we go back to the definition of class
you can see we have four different
methods in it representation the string
representation and grid What
differentiates between this random
methods and the regular method is that
python by default is going to search for
this render methods so that it can
Implement its own magic if you change
the name from init to something else
then the class Constructor is not going
to work
so always make sure you get the naming
convention right in it is for the
construction
repr is for the official representation
and this is just for your reference this
is called as a string representation
even though the name starts with an
underscore you can use them just as your
regular function
let's see how to do that let us go right
over here
let me make some space and
let me print out P1 dot underscore
underscore SDR
and that's it
so what we are doing is we are simply
calling the method called as SDR on the
instance of P1 that's it let me save and
let me try to run the file
and here it is we have the output of
person Lewis Zappa so this is absolutely
possible but this is not the recommended
way of doing it so let me put up a
comment
possible but not recommended
well that's it for this one in the next
video we will convert the character from
our game to a class now let's see how we
can convert the character from our game
to a class
What I've Done behind the scenes I have
created a new file called as character
dot Pi inside my zero six folder let us
go back to the folder number five and
inside the game so this is how our
character looks like our character has a
name attack power and life
we can use this parameters to create our
own class so let us go back to our
character.py file let me collapse my
sidebar and let's start creating a class
for our character so the first is the
keyword of class followed by the name
character let us go inside the first
method is always going to be the
Constructor that means our underscore
underscore edit method so we can
write like this Define
my init
remember the first argument should
always be self for reference here we can
accept three different arguments let us
go back to the game
so we need one argument for the name one
argument for the attack power and one
argument for life so let us go back to
our init method and here I can see I
want to accept a name
pipe string
next is attack power
pipe is an integer
life
the type is an integer and this method
always returns none let us create some
variables inside again you have to
follow the conventions
you have to write self dot name
and let us take the data from this
variable and put it right over here so I
can say name remember that you can name
this anything so I can just call this as
n
but you have to change over here also
but as a convention normally we would
like to keep it the same names so let me
go back
the next is for the attack power so I
can say self Dot
attack power would be my attack power
the text would be self dot life
would be my life
let me add some documentation right over
here
saying that this method creates an
instance of character let me add some
documentation for the class as well so
this is for documentation of the class
that this class defines a character
now let us create an instance of this
class so let me create a villain first
so I can say a villain
villain the first one would be a
character
the name would be
Thanos
his attack power is 400 and his life is
1500 let me
print out the villain number one
let us save the file and let me try to
execute this file
and here we have the output but as you
know this is a little cryptic output so
what python is telling that this is a
character object add this and this
memory address but you already know how
we can improve this so let's start
adding some of the dender or the magic
methods the first one I can save is my
repr the first argument is self and this
returns a string
I can say return so this is my class of
the type of character
let me save the file and let me run one
more time so this time we have a little
better output my VLAN is actually a
class of character
let us improve further by using our Str
method so we can Define it right over
here
SDR
first argument is always the self
this this returns a string and let us
construct a string right over here
so I can see the name
it would be self dot name
next would be the attack power
and this would be self dot attack power
next would be life
so this would be self dot life
that's it let me save it and let me try
to run it so this time we have a much
better output the name is Thanos attack
power is 400 and the life is 1500 let us
go back and let us create some more
characters let me put up one comment
over here so while constructing a class
you can actually use key and value pairs
so let us create one more villain and
let's see how we can do this so this is
my villain number two
it is a character and here we can use
the key value pairs so I can say the
name
maybe this time it is Red Skull
the attack power is 300.
and the life is 800 and that's it
let me try to print out the second
villain as well so I can say villain
number two
just save it and try to run it and here
we have the output Red Skull attack
power 300 life 800. now the beauty of
this key value pairs is you don't have
to specify the arguments in a given
sequence you can mix up the sequence but
still we can have a proper instance so
let me show you maybe I can just take
this out and put it here
and let me save this let me try to run
it one more time and still we have the
right output let us go back and let us
try to create some more Heroes let me
create one hero so this is Iron Man
attack power is 250 life is thousand let
me create one more so this time it is
Black Widow the attack power is 180 and
the life is 800 and let us also print
them out let me run the file for the
last time
and here we have the output Thanos Red
Skull Iron Man and Black Widow before we
can move ahead let us take a small pause
and let us think do we really require
classes let us go back to the earlier
program that we wrote
so let me go back to my file called as
basic
and let me collapse my sidebar
so let us ask a very fundamental
question do we require a class
the answer is it depends
whenever you want to have a structure
and a behavior together at that time
using a class makes much more sense if
you require just the data then you can
use any of the data structures you can
use a list you can use a dictionary or
some other custom data structures as
well but whenever the structure and
behavior is tied together that's the
best place to create a class for example
in this file we have a class of person
now let's see what's happening
person has a structure and that
structure is defined by the first name
and the last name
now this person can also have a behavior
a person can greet another person so we
have a method called as greed
so greed Can Be Imagined like a behavior
of a person
a person can have different kinds of
behaviors a person can walk a person can
talk a person can eat
so all of this Can Be Imagined as
behaviors but all of this behaviors is
tied to a structure and that structure
is the First theme last name and maybe
you can have multiple other parameters
such as your age your location and so on
so just keep this in mind classes are
not the solution for everything
make sure you use the right data
structure or the right classes only when
it is required let us learn more about
classes and this time let us learn about
class membership till now we have been
creating variables inside our
Constructor
so for example in our class of character
so we can say surf.name is a member of
the instance of this class
same thing attack power can also be
called as an instance variable let us
create a new class and let us try to
study what is this all about so behind
the scenes I have created a file called
as
members.pi added a couple of comments so
let's try to see what's happening inside
let us try to create a class called as
box
and let us Define an init method this
box has two sides this is my side number
one I can say the type is integer my
next side
also the type of integer
it returns none
let us create the variables inside so I
can say my
side a is equal to my side a and my
side B is equal to my side B now what we
have done is we have created variables
inside our Constructor class now
remember what this method does it
actually creates an instance and fills
in the value so if we refer this diagram
our Constructor is simply filling the
values of the instances so the variables
that create inside they are called as
instance variables let me put up a
comment right over here
now if you go back to the diagram
the data is different for every instance
so for example the first name for person
number one was Lewis
and for person number two it was CC
now let us see how to create class
members let me put up a command so this
class members are defined on the class
scope so this class members are defined
outside our Constructors so let us
Define a couple of class members as well
let us create a variable and we can see
box type and this is going to be a
packaging Carton and the color for this
one would be brown so this variables
that we have created box type and color
this variables would be accessible to
all of the classes please note that we
don't have self over here because we
don't need reference to an instance
this data is available to all of the
classes and all of the instances let us
create a Str method
here I can say Define my
Str
ugan cell
this always returns a string and I can
say
return
my side a would be
my self dot side a
and my side B would be
sorry it has to be self Dot
side B
for this example I am going to skip the
repr but you can write it on your own
let us create an instance called as the
first box and I can say the box side a
maybe it's three and the next is 4.
let us try to print out my box so I can
say I want to print my box
let me save it and let me try to run it
so here we have a box side a is3 and the
side B is 4 now let us try to print the
class variables
from an instance
remember this class instances are
available for all of the instances so I
can simply say I want to print my
box first Dot box type
and let us print the color as well so I
can say the color
let me save it and let me run it so we
have the output it's a packaging Carton
and the color is brown let us go back
and let us try to solidify this concept
of class members now this class members
are available on classes itself you
don't have to create an instance
that means if you go back to the design
we can get back the data from the design
itself we don't have to create an
instance to get back the data now let's
see this in action what we did till now
is we created an instance of the box and
then we printed
this variables right over here but we
can simply say I want to print the box
type from the class of box
let me copy and paste we can also say I
want to see the color
that's it just save it and let me try to
run it and we have the output packaging
Carton and brown
so this time what we did is we simply
accessed this variables from the class
we did not create an instance so this is
what I mean to say when all of the class
members are available to the class
itself and also to the instances let us
create one more box and
print it out so let me print my box
number two
and just for the sake of confirming we
can say my B2 dot box type
and my B2 dot color
and we should get the same output let me
save it and let me run this file for the
last time
and here it is we get the exact same
output let us try to study the next
Concept in our object oriented
programming and this concept is called
as inheritance and polymorphism
what I've done is I have created a file
right over here called as inheritance
and polymorphism
and let us try to see what's going on
just to give you a very simple example
we are all human beings but we are also
animals that means we inherit a lot of
properties from animals for example all
of us have eyes ears hands and legs but
all of us human beings we don't speak
the same language now that's
polymorphism in action inheritance means
we inherit all of the features of an
animal
and polymorphism means even though we
have the same properties but we exhibit
different Behavior now let's create some
classes and see this in action let us
create the first class called as animal
so let us create a class of
animal
let us Define our methods over here
first is the cell
and let me accept one argument for name
one for the age and one for the number
of legs
this returns nothing so I can say none
let me put up a comment that we are
going to create and initialize the
instance variables let's start creating
some of our instance variables so I can
say my self Dot name is equal to my name
then myself dot is is equal to age
then self dot of legs is equal to Magnum
of legs let us also create the Str
method so I can say Define my SDR
it
takes a self it returns a string
and here I can return
let's say we can just return the name
for now so I can say name and this would
be self Dot
name let us try to give animals some
kind of behavior so let us create a
method called as talk on animal so I can
say Define a method called as talk
the first parameter would be self and
this is going to return nothing so none
for now let me put up some documentation
saying that this method makes the animal
talk but let's see what we can do right
now
since we don't know what kind of animal
it is that's why we can't talk yet so
let us print the same thing right over
here
so I can say print
my formatted string
self dot name
can't talk yet so let us go down and let
us create one animal so this is my first
animal so I can say
I want a instance of the class of animal
the name is Robin Age maybe he's 10
years old number of legs is 4 then let
us print out the animal and let's also
try to make the animal talk so
a1.com just save a file and let me run
it so here we have the output we have
Robin and Robin can't talk yet now let's
go back and let's see how we can create
some sort of inheritance
let us create a dog now remember dog is
a kind of animal so you can say that dog
inherits from animal let me create a
class and then I will try to explain
what's happening so let me create a
class called as dog
now here inside the brackets we have to
specify from which class we are
inheriting so dog is inheriting from the
class of annual so this is how it goes
let us create our Constructor right over
here as well so Define init
self now let's see what happens since
the dog inherits from animal dog also
needs to accept all of these parameters
name age number of legs so let me just
copy and paste
and here we can accept some more
arguments as well
so let me create one more argument for
breed so we can accept one for breed let
me get the spelling right let us go down
and let us start creating our instance
variables here at this point python can
do a small bit of magic for us
since dog is inheriting from animal we
don't have to create all of the instance
variables manually instead what we can
do is we can pass the common data to the
class we are inheriting from so we are
going to take all of this data and we
are going to pass this data to animal so
technically animal can be also called as
your parent class or it can also be
called as your super class let me put up
a comment so we want to take all of the
common features and pass it to the
parent or the super class python
provides a keyword called as super so
this super means the class of animal and
now we want to pass all of this data to
one method and that method is called as
init now remember in it is just like any
other function except it has underscores
at the beginning and at the end so we
can call that method as we can call any
other method so we can say super
and underscore underscore init
underscore underscore
and let us pass the common features
which is the name
age and the number of legs now it is the
responsibility of the superclass that
means the class of animal to create
instance variables for the name age and
number of legs
the only argument that is remaining is
for the breed so inside dog we can
create one more instance variable called
as self dot breed and we can assign the
value we can also create extra instance
variable even though we are not
accepting parameters right over here so
let me give you a small example so I can
say self DOT type is equal to dog so you
can see we can create instance variables
wherever we want them so let me save
this
so this is what I mean by inheritance
dog is a class which inherits from
animals and they share a lot of common
functionality that's why we are passing
the common functionality to the
superclass and we can create some
additional instance variables as well
now let's see how we can introduce
polymorphism in this class remember
remember the superclass of animal has a
method of Str so let's override this
method and let us create a different Str
method for dog so let's see how we can
do that the syntax is going to be
exactly the same so we have to say
Define Str takes in a cell
gives back a string
and let me print out a message over here
let us use the formatted string so we
can say
self DOT type
followed by the self dot name
and let us also print out the breed so I
can say the breed of the dog is
self Dot bead
oh sorry we can't print because remember
the Str method always has to return a
string so thanks to our typing my code
editor is catching an error so this has
to be
written not string
let me take out the brackets
now everything looks good now let's
create it all so I can go right over
here so I can say my first dog
is an instance of the class of dog
the name is whiskey
the age I can use my keyword arguments
as well so my age is five years old
number of legs is obviously four and the
breed maybe the breed could be Doberman
let's try to print out our dog so I can
say print
my dog let me save it and let me try to
run this file so here you can see we
have a doberman by the name of whiskey
and the breed is double man now let us
try and explore some more benefits of
inheritance
so you can see we have created a class
of dog which inherits from animals since
dog inherits from animals it also
inherits all of the behavior of animal
the class of dog does not have a method
for talk but the class of animal has it
so we can actually make the dog talk as
well so we can say
D1 dot talk let me save it and let me
try to run this file
and we get the output that whiskey can't
talk it but we can use our polymorphism
and we can make whiskey talk so let's
see how to do that
so inside my class of dog we are going
to create a new method called a stock
and the new method is going to override
the method inside the class of animal
so it's just like creating an another
method so we can say Define talk
it always takes self
this is going to return nothing and here
let's print out
so I can say self Dot
name
says woof and let me save the file and
let us try running this and now we have
the output whiskey is saying woof let us
go back and let us see what else we can
do
let me take out this space this class of
dog it can have its own Behavior now
since this is a dog our dog can also
sniff different items so let's create a
method called a sniff on dog so let us
go down over here so I can say Define a
method called a sniff
the first argument is always the self
now these methods are just like your
regular functions they can also accept
arguments so let me take an argument for
the item that the dog is supposed to
sniff
it is going to be a string this method
is also going to return nothing so I can
just say none
and let us print out a message
self dot name
is sniffing out the item so please note
that here we don't have to use self dot
because item is not an instance variable
item is just an regular argument on a
regular function let us go down and let
us try to sniff so let me say D1 I want
you to sniff for ball save a file and
let us run it so here we can see we have
the output whiskey is sniffing out ball
let us create one more class for cat and
since cat is also an animal cat is going
to inherit animal as well so you can see
we can have multiple classes that can
inherit from other classes as well let
me put a comment saying that this method
of talk
this is the place we are altering the
method and we are adding some
polymorphic Behavior so let me go down
and let me put a separator
and let us create a class of CAD
and creating that class is pretty simple
I just have to copy all of these things
so let me copy let me go down and
paste it right over here let's change
the name from Dog to cat
the type also is a cat this time we
don't want the comment now and the cat
says meow and we don't want this method
because cats are not so good at sniffing
so let me take it out let us create one
instance of our cat so I can say my cat
number one is my cat
the name is Jess
suppose she's two years old number of
legs is four and the breed could be a
Persian cat let us print out the cat so
I can say print
and let us also make the cat talk so I
can say C1 dot top that's it let us run
the file
and we have the output so we have a cat
named Jess the British is a Persian cat
and chess is saying meow
so now you get the idea just for the
sake of practice let us create one more
class for a dinosaur now this dinosaur
is also going to inherit from animal let
me copy and paste this separator let me
copy all of this as well and let me go
down and let me paste it right over here
so since this is a dinosaur I can just
say Dino and this has to be Dyno as well
and since we don't know what dinosaurs
can talk put some random text
now the dinosaur can also hunt so let us
create one method for hunt so let's
create one method called as hunt it
accepts itself
and returns a none
here I can say print self dot name
is out for hunting let's create one
dinosaur so I can say my Dino one is
equal to my Dino
suppose the name is Adam
age could be eight years old suppose the
number of legs are two and the breed
would be T-Rex let's print out the dyno
let us also make the dino talk and also
let us make the Dino Hunt that's it let
me save and let me run the file and we
have the output so this is a dinosaur
Adam is saying something Adam is out for
hunting
so now you get the idea we can have
multiple classes inheriting from a
single class or you can also inherit
from multiple classes as well but we are
not covering that in this tutorials let
me put a separator and let me show you
one nice trick we can also ask python if
a certain class inherits from other
class or not so let's see if the dog and
the cat inherits from animal or not so I
can say print
and we can use an inbuilt method called
as is instance the first argument is the
object that we want to compare so let me
pass my dog and the next argument is the
parent class that we want to compare
with so suppose I want to see if the dog
is of the type of animal so let me save
it and let me try to run it and here we
have the answer it's true and that's
because the glass of dog is inheriting
from animal now here I want you to
understand one point all of the dogs are
animals but all of the animals are not
dogs so please keep this in your mind
let us check if demon
is a kind of dog so I can say is
instance Devon and dog let me print it
out
and yes it is let us do one last time
for our cat so let me copy and paste so
this becomes C1 and
this becomes cat and let us see the
output so here it is C1 is an instance
of cat as well
now let's try to learn about decorators
so this decorators are like the higher
order functions but this higher order
functions are already built into python
this decorators can give some additional
behaviors to our classes
so we are going to have a look at couple
of these decorators some of the
decorators that we are going to see are
property static methods class methods
Getters and finally setters
so I have created a new file called as
decorators and I'm going to work inside
this file for this example let us
imagine that we are working for a store
and we have to write a software that
will manage our stuff now since all of
the staff members are also persons
so first I am going to create a class of
person and then I will create a class of
staff that inherits from person so let
us start with the person first
so I can see the class of person
our Constructor in it
self
and suppose we want to accept the first
name
this is a string the last name this is
also a string
and this returns nothing
inside let us create some instance
variables so we can say self Dot
first name is equal to my first name
as self Dot last name is equal to my
last name
let us also create the string method so
I can say
Str
uck and this always returns a string
so I can say return this is a person and
then I can say my
self DOT first name and
self dot last name let us create one
person and print it out so I can say
this is going to be sorry not permission
I want a person
the first name would be Lewis the last
name would be Zappa
and let us try to print him out
now let me try to run and see the output
so we have the output of Lewis Zappa
till now you are familiar with
everything
now let's go to the example now suppose
you want to retrieve the full name every
time now instead of creating one more
instance variable over here saying that
self Dot
full name is equal to something
something
instead of this we can create a property
and that property will create a full
name for us and we can retrieve it just
as we would retrieve any other instance
variables so let me take out this line
and let me show you how to use our first
decorator so let me go down over here
the way you use a decorator is by this
symbol at the rate and then you name the
decorate so this time The Decorator that
I want to show you this is called as
property
so this is our decorator
and after that let us create the
function so I can say Define
full name
this takes self as the first parameter
and returns a string next line we can
simply
create the full name and it has written
the full name so we can just say self
DOT first name and self dot last name so
what we have essentially done is this
full name right over here this would act
just like your instance variable so just
imagine that here we had one more
instance variable called as self dot
full name so this property will function
exactly like this let me show you this
in action so let me take it out
let us go down and let us try to print
the full name of the first person so I
can say print
first persons full name that's it now
since this is a property we don't have
to use brackets after this one because
remember full name is just like your
instance variable let me try to execute
the program
and here we have the output Lewis Zappa
now let us go back and let's start
working on some other classes but before
that let me put some separators so this
is one separator and this is another
separator
now let's create the class of stuff and
this staff will inherit from person but
let us try to expand our knowledge over
here Suppose there are different
categories in the staff there could be
an associate there could be a manager
and so on so we can have multiple roles
and each of these roles can have
different salaries so suppose if you are
a associate then your salary could be 15
for an hour if you are a supervisor it
would be twenty dollars if you are a
manager it could be 25 dollars
so what we want to do is whenever we
create a new class we also want to
dynamically give that person a different
salary based on his role sounds a little
complicated but don't worry let me show
you how to do this
now since we have to Define different
roles at this time using an enum is the
best option so if you have not seen my
video on enum I would highly recommend
you to go back and see that video so
that was in my section number four and I
think that file was this choices dot pi
so we are going to use this enums in
this file
I want to use enums because I want to
Define different rules let's see how to
do that let me go to the top
and first let me try to import a couple
of things so
from my package of enum I want to import
enum and I also want to import my auto
so now we can define an enum let me
create one called as class role so this
inherits from my enum
and inside this let me put some
documentation that this rule is for our
staff members
now let's create a couple of rules
suppose the first role is for an
associate so I can say associate and let
me write Auto over here the next one
could be a supervisor again is equal to
auto
the last one could be a manager so I can
say manager is equal to Auto let me just
save it and let us go down
and let's start creating our class of
stuff let me put some separators here as
well
okay now let us go down and here let us
start creating the class
and the class is of stuff and this class
inherits from person so here let us
first Define our Constructor so I can
say Define my init
the first argument is always self
now let us see now since stuff inherits
from person person requires two
arguments first for the first name and
for the last name so let me just copy
and paste right from here so I can take
this
and put it right over here
now the next argument that we want is
for the rule remember we want to take
the rule and we would be dynamically
creating the salary depending on the
role
so I can say I also want to accept a
rule and the type would be
rule
this method always returns nothing so I
can say none so inside this we want to
pass the data to our superclass
so let me put a comment and then I can
say
I want my super to initialize with my
first name
and my last name now let us create some
more instance variables maybe we can
accept one more parameter for the staff
ID so let me write it right over here
so I can say the staff ID
would be an integer now let us go down
and let us start creating the instance
variables so the first variable would be
for the staff ID and this is is equal to
the staff ID let us create one more
instance variable called as is
stuff and let us put it to true so
remember we can always create instance
variables even though we are not
accepting them inside our Constructor
method next it could be for the role so
I can say self dot rule is equal to
rule
now for the next one I also want to
record the date of joining for the staff
member so let's see how we can do that
so I can say self Dot date
joined
and this time the value has to be in the
format of date date and time fortunately
python has an inbuilt library for doing
exactly this and the name of the library
as you can guess it is called as date
time so let me go above and let me
import it so here I can say
from
my library of
date time
I want to import
date time now let us go down and let's
see how we can assign the value of date
time so here we can simply say date time
for now so what's happening is the
moment that we are creating this
instance
we can have the date time automatically
assigned to our variable
before we proceed I want you to wait and
I want you to think once we have a staff
member I don't want anyone to
accidentally change the date joint
so what's the solution let us try and
make this variable a private variable
now there is no real concept of private
and public but we have a convention so
whenever we put an underscore this means
that we want to keep this variable as
private you can also write double
underscore or a single underscore it's
up to you normally whenever we want to
enforce that it's a strictly private
then we can use double underscore
but a single underscore also means that
we want to keep this variable as private
so let me write a comment right over
here
so this is going to be our private
member and all of this are public
variables the next thing to do is we
want to assign the salary but the salary
has to be dynamically assigned depending
on the role if the role is often
Associated then the salary has to be 15
if it is the supervisor then the salary
has to be 20 dollars if it is a manager
then the salary has to be 25 dollars
let's see how we can dynamically assign
a new instance variable called a salary
and assign values to it so let me put up
a comment that we want to dynamically
create and assign values
so let's see we can use an if an else
statement so we can check if the rule is
for supervisor or for manager and so on
but we can also use our match statement
so in this example let us use the match
so I can say let us match for the role
the first case that I want to match is
for my role dot associate
so in case this rule is for an associate
then at that time I want to dynamically
create an instance variable called as
salary
and I want to assign the value of 15 let
us also add some type hinting so instead
of 15 it can also be 15.5 15.75 and so
on
so let us declare this instance variable
as a float
now you must be wondering why do I need
to have a type hint right over here but
here we don't have the answer is it's
because we have declared the types right
over here so this first name is a string
so by default this first name is also
going to be a string staff ID is an
integer so here the staff ID is also
going to be an integer and my Pi is
smart enough to infer all of these
things but here since we don't have this
instance variable declared anywhere we
have to be explicit and let us declare
the type is going to be a float here
again let us think about the visibility
I don't want anyone to change the salary
salary has to be privately managed so we
can see I can put an underscore or I can
put a double underscore let us go to the
next case suppose the rule is for an
supervisor then I can say self dot
underscore underscore salary
would be twenty dollars
then I can say if the rule is for a
manager
then I want to assign the salary of 25
let us also Define the string method for
this one so I can say Define my
Str self this return a string
so let me
return so I can say this is a staff
member
the name is
self now here I can use the property
that we have defined for full name
if you scroll little up
we don't have an instance variable for
full name but we have declared a
property and that's what I'm going to
use right over here I want to display
the full name so I'm using self dot full
name next we can also display the ID so
I can say ID is my self dot staff ID let
us go down and let us try to create a
staff member this time so I can say my
staff member is my
stuff the first name is Chico
the last name is Jonas staff ID can be
three two four five let's give her a
role of manager so I can use my enum I
can say the role is role dot manager and
let us try to print it out so let me
print my stuff that's it let me run the
file so we have a new staff member so
you can see right over here the name is
Chico Jonas and the ID is three two four
five let us go back and let us see what
more we can do with our classes the next
decorator is called as the class method
just imagine the scenario that we
already have a person in our database
and this person is joining our shop as a
staff member so what we can do is we can
simply take that person as an argument
if you see right over here we are taking
first name and last name as an argument
instead of this we can take a person and
from that person we can create another
class for the staff
so let us go down right over here
and this is called as class method and
now always remember this method is you
should create an another class till now
we have been working with instances but
what this class will do it will return
another class which is all the type of
stuff itself so let's see how to do that
suppose we want to create a new staff
member from an existing person so I can
say Define new so new is just the name
of the function you can write anything
that you want and since this is a class
method the first argument is called as a
class till now we have been taking the
first argument as self so we can see it
was selled
but since the class method works on the
class that's the reason why the first
argument is a class if you are still
confused then let me go back to my
diagram so this is a class and this is
an instance the class method is going to
work on the class itself that means we
can create a new person from a design of
the person that's what it really means
let us write the different arguments so
obviously we want to create a new staff
member from an existing person so we
need to accept a person next we also
need a staff ID so this is going to be
an integer then we also need a rule the
type is for the rule now here this
method is going to return an another
instance of the class and that instance
is of the type of stuff itself so this
function returns a staff let me add some
documentation saying that this is going
to create a new instance of the staff
itself and let's see how we can create a
staff in this case this class actually
means
staff so here we can see I want to
return
a new staff member
and the first name is going to be the
first name of the person that we are
accepting so I can say
person DOT first name the next argument
is
the person dot last name then we have to
give the staff ID and then we also have
to give role now unfortunately we can't
write this syntax but what we can do is
since this class means staff we simply
have to replace staff
with class and it's the same thing now
the written value is of the type of
staff
but what's happening is we are trying to
return the staff member before we have
defined the class of stuff so in order
for this code to work we have to do
something so we have to go a little up
and we have to say
from
future
I want to import
annotations
so what do I exactly mean to say is
since this method right oh yeah the
method of new is retaining a staff
but at this time python does not know
what the stock because python has not
yet created this class
but by importing this functionality from
futures
we can tell python what's exactly
happening so let us go down and let us
add one person to our staff member
so since we already have a person called
as Lewis Zappa maybe he joins our store
so let us create a staff member from
Lewis Zappa so let me say my staff
number one so here let us create a new
staff member by using this class method
the first argument as you can see it's
for a person so let me pass my first
person the staff ID could be one two
three four and the rule could be the
role of a supervisor now let us try to
print it out let me say I want to print
my
first staff member and this I can say
this is my second staff member
disable file and try to run it so we
have the output the first staff member
is Louis Zappa with id1234 and we have
one another if you are a little confused
then just keep in mind that class method
is a method that returns an instance of
the same class now let's try to move on
and let's learn a little bit more about
classes now since we have defined this
instance variable as private date join
but what happens if anyone wants to see
what is the joining date so we can
create another property that will
display the joining date so we can go
down and let me create a property so
here I can use my decorator called as
property let me Define the property
called as joined
on this text the self and this is going
to return a string
let me put up some documentation saying
that this is for the joining date of the
staff member and since this has to
return the joining date we can simply
say I want to return and here I can say
myself
dot underscore date joined
now if you're wondering why do we have
to do all of these things and the answer
is since this is a property we cannot
assign values to an property at least
not yet in technical terms this is also
called as in getter in short we can
simply get the value from here but we
can't set the value over here later on
when I teach you about Getters and
Setters at that time we can actually use
properties to get as well as set
different properties but for now let us
go with the flow
and let me try to save the file and let
me try to run it let us try to see the
joining date of Lewis so I can say
print Dot joint on
and that's it let me try to run the file
and we have a joining date now this
joining date looks pretty complicated
it's in a different format but
fortunately we can also have the output
which we can understand so let's see how
we can do that suppose I want to see the
date in a format of month day and the
year so let's see how we can format this
fortunately there is one inbuilt method
for our date time and that is called as
string format and we have to use a
couple of keywords right over here so
let me paste it over here so this
capital b stands for the month the
lowercase d stands for the day
and obviously y stands for the year so
let me save this and let me try to run
this file and here we have a much better
output so the date of joining Fort Lewis
Zappa is July the 6th and the year is
2022. let us see the last concept that I
want to teach you in decorators and this
concept is called as Getters and setters
I have already partially explained that
this property right here this property
acts as a getter that means I can always
get a date but I can't set a date but
let's see what happens if we want to set
and value suppose we promote an employee
suppose an associate becomes a
supervisor or a supervisor becomes a
manager that time we also need to
increase the salary so let us see how we
can do that by using our Getters and
Setters now if you remember we have
declared the salary as a private member
but what happens if our HR department
wants to see the salary so first let us
create a property or a getter to see the
salary and then we will see how to use a
setup to set the new salary so let us go
down and let us create one property for
the salary so I can say property and let
me call it as
salary tax the self as an argument and
this returns a string I think I have
declared it as a float yeah it's a float
so this has to return a float
let me put a comment
so this acts like a getter of the salary
and we simply have to return our self
dot underscore underscore salary let us
see the salary of Lewis so let me say I
want to print
stuff one dot
salary and that's it let me run the file
and here you can see the salary is
twenty dollars for an hour now let's see
what happens if I try to set the salary
so if I say my S1 dot salary is equal to
17
let me save it we have an error so if
you just try to hover
it says that property salary is defined
in staff is a rate only so what this is
trying to say is we can only get the
value we can't set and we can't set
because this is just a read only
property so this is the beauty of
Getters and Setters we can't
accidentally change the values but what
happens if we do want to change the
value at that time we need to create
another method which is called as a
setup let's see how to do that normally
you would use a Setter when you need to
do some kind of validation before you
want to set the values now in this case
let us see what kind of validation do we
require if you remember if the rule is
foreign associate the minimum salary is
15 dollars for a supervisor the minimum
salary is twenty dollars now if the role
is for supervisor but if we try to set
the salary which is lower than 20
dollars then we don't want that to
happen so this is a part of our
validation logic and we can use that
inside our setup method the way to
declare the setup method is kind of
weird in Python but let me show you how
it is so the syntax is I want to say for
my salary this is the setup so this is a
Syntax for the setup this simply means
that we are declaring a Setter method
for the property of salary let us create
the function for
salary
obviously the first argument is for the
self and the next argument is for the
amount that is the amount of salary that
you want to give the employee so I can
take one more parameter called let's
amount the type would be of a float and
since this is a setup we are not going
to return anything so I can say none let
me put up a comment saying that this is
our setup method
and inside of this let us see how we can
use our validation logic and how we can
set the new values let's start with the
associate the associate cannot have a
salary Which is less than 15 dollars so
we can say if my self dot rule is role
dot associate
and if the amount
is less than 15 dollars that means it is
going to fail our validation because we
can't give an associate a salary Which
is less than 15 dollars so let me print
out a message saying that error
associate cannot have a salary less than
15 dollars
now what happens inside any of the
methods you have access to all of the
instance variables so if you see I'm
using this instance variable called as
self dot Rule and we have defined this
self dot role right over here
so this is where it is online number 60
but since we are inside the same class
we can have access to all of the
instance variables the same thing is
happening everywhere so for example in
this property of salary I can access the
salary a natural the salary is being
declared right over here either online
66 68 or 70 but we can still access all
of the instance variables let us go down
and let us create the next validation
logic so this was for an associate next
let us create one for the supervisor and
the last one for the manager so we can
say
else if
the rule
is for the role of supervisor and if the
given amount is is less than 20 then we
need to print an error message so we can
say supervisor cannot have a salary
Which is less than 20 dollars let's go
to the next one we can again check if
the role this time
is for the role of a manager
and if the amount is less than 25 then
let us print one more error saying that
manager cannot have a salary less than
so this should be 25
dollars for an hour now let us go down
now what happens if we pass all of this
validation that means we have the right
Rule and we also have the right amount
in that case we can assign that amount
as a salary so here I can say else
if everything is fine
then my salary is equal to the given
amount and let me print a nice message
saying that self dot full name
now has a salary of dollars and
self dot salary and I can write per hour
so remember that this salary is a
property so as you can see the visual
studio code is telling you that this is
a property and this is a get a method
now let me save the file now let me try
to run it if you see online number 120 I
am assigning a value of 17
but the role is for a supervisor and if
you see inside our validation logic
supervisor cannot have a salary of 20
that means we should get an error let me
save the file and let us try to run it
and see if we can get an error and
that's it we have the right output so
it's saying that error supervisor cannot
have a salary less than 20 dollars for
an hour what happens if you try to set
the salary which is valid so I can say
s1. salary is equal to 20 or maybe I can
say 22 so let me save it and let me try
to
run it and we have the right output so
on the next line you can see Louis Zappa
now has a salary of 22 dollars for an
hour let us go back to the file and this
time I want to show you the final
decorator in this section now we have
been inheriting classes for example here
the class of staff is inheriting from
person in some of the earlier examples
we were inheriting classes such as
animals dogs and so on but what happens
if I want to say that you can't inherit
this class whatever class I have created
this is the last and final class and no
one can inherit it we can do that by
using a different decorator but first
let me import that
and that comes from our typing Library
so I can see right over here from
my library of
typing
I want to import
final
and just before the class stack we want
to declare as final we have to use it so
suppose I want to say my class of staff
is a final and no one can inherit it so
I can just say
at the rate and this is going to be my
final class
let me save it and let us give it a try
so suppose let me put a separator over
here
suppose someone creates a class called
as HR
and let us try inheriting from staff and
we can keep the body as empty so let me
just write pass
let me try to save it
now you can see the code editor is
highlighting that we have some issue and
it is saying that the class of stuff is
marked as final and it cannot be
subclassed so let me just comment it out
and I think we have done for this video
let us start converting our game into
classes
so the first thing that I want to do is
let me just copy and
paste it inside this folder let me
rename from 3 to 4 and let me change the
documentation so this is where we are
trying to improve our design by using
classes so let's see how we can start
using classes inside our game till now
we have been using an alias but now what
we can do is
instead of using an alias for the
character we can actually create a class
for character so let us go right over
here and let us create our class for
character so we can see class character
now let's see what instance variables do
we require
now each of the character has three main
things you can see right over here name
attack power and life so we can Define
these as our instance variables so let
us do that
Define init
cell the first is the name is going to
be a string
attack power integer
life is also an integer
this returns nothing
let me write some documentation saying
that this creates an instance of
character
so here I can say self dot name is equal
to the name self Dot attack power is
equal to the attack power
self taught life is equal to
the life let's also create a nice Str
method so we can say
Define a string method for this one
self and this always returns a string
and inside let us make a nice string
representation for the character so I
can say
the name of the character is self dot
name the
attack power
is going to be
self dot attack power
and the life is going to be
self
dot live let me save it next let us see
how we can create superheroes and our
villains
now superheroes can inherit from our
character and our vlans can also inherit
from our characters
so let's see how to do that so let's
create a class called as superhero so
you can say my class of
superhero this inherits from the
character let me put some documentation
and let us write the init method now
since this is inheriting from character
I can simply copy and paste all of this
copy and paste
and this
returns nothing
now inside since we are inheriting we
can use the super keyword and we can say
super
dot init and we can simply pass
the name
attack power
and the life
so the superclass of character would be
responsible for creating all of this
instance variables
next we can also create one more
instance variable called as a rule
so this instance variable can say that
this is a superhero or this is a super
villain
in order to define a role again let us
go back and create a nice enum so let me
go to the top
and first thing that I want to do is I
want to import so from enum I want to
import my enum
and also I want Auto I can say my class
of
character type this inherits from enum
let me add some documentation then I can
say superhero and assign it to Auto then
I can say villain and assign it to Auto
as well so let me save this and let us
go on below
here I can create one more instance
variable I can say cell dot rule and
this would be equal to my character type
Dot
superhero
let us also create the Str method so I
can say
Str yourself this returns a string
let me copy and paste all of this
let me put it here
not just before the name I can say that
this is a superhero so I can say
this is a superhero and put a nice Arrow
now since this line is really long so we
can do one small trick
let me take it down and I want to have
brackets around this so this is my
opening bracket and right over here I
can put my closing bracket
and what I can do is let me cut this
portion out for the life
and on the next line I can simply again
say F and paste it over there
and that's it so this is also a valid
syntax next let us create the same thing
for our villain so I can simply copy all
of this
paste it down
so from Superhero
it becomes my villain
and this has to be my villain
this has to be again my villain let us
go down and we don't need all of these
things because we already have a class
for character
so I can take all of this out I don't
want any of this
now let's see what we can do with life
with life I'm going to do a very small
trick I am going to create a class for
life but all of the methods would be
static that's because I don't want to
create an instance of life it makes no
sense I just want access to Hero life
and we're in life so let me create it
first and then I will try and explain so
here I can say this is going to be a
class of life
and what I want to do is I want to take
all of these things inside
so
till yeah
all of these things goes inside my class
now let's start changing them one by one
now what happens is you can see my these
two variables
these are outside my init method or
rather I don't have a init method over
here and that's also perfectly fine
these two variables belongs to the class
so they can also be called as my class
variables and that's what I want there
is one other alternative approach let me
paste it right over here
that approach is called as data classes
but I am not going to cover them inside
this course you can use this link to
study more about data classes
now let us continue with our journey
I'm going to use a new decorator which
is called as static method so let me
copy and first let me
paste everywhere and then I will try and
explain what's happening since this hero
life and we're in life belongs to the
class I no longer have to use the
keyword of global and hero life
so I can take it out
and now what happens is this hero life
is actually a class member of the class
of life so I can simply say
life dot hero live plus equal to life
so this means that this hero life
variable references exactly this one let
me save it and then I will try and
explain what this new decorator is doing
now if you see I am not taking the
argument as self for static method
that's because this decorator works on
the class directly it does not have to
create an instance let us go back to our
decorators file and there I will try and
demonstrate what's happening so this is
our decorators file
now let me go back to the diagram itself
so here is our diagram again whenever I
am saying that this is a static method
means that we can call that starting
method from the class itself
we don't need to create instances for
example
here in our decorators file you can see
that we have this one date time dot now
no matter whatever the class you don't
need an extra instance we can have a
common functionality
that's what I mean to say by a starting
method so basically static method is
just like any other method but it does
not take a self argument because it
works directly on the class and not on
the instance suppose we can create a
static method called as describe and
that static method will just describe
what this class is going to do so let's
create it and see it in action so let me
go down and just after this property
joint on I can create my static method
so I can use my decorator
of static method the name would be
describe
so again this is not going to take
itself neither this is going to take a
class because this is independent of
everything this is going to return none
let me write some documentation what's
happening so this method is just going
to describe what this class is all about
so I can just print out that this is a
class to
create a path member
now let me go down
and here I can simply call this method
on my class so let me call it at the top
I can say staff Dot describe and since
it's a method I need to use my brackets
that's it let me run this file and here
we have the output class to create a
staff member Now using this same concept
let us go back to our game now here what
happens is we have two class members
hero life and we're in life
I want to get access to this variables
and that's what I'm doing right over
here by using a static method you can
get a little bit more clarity when we
use this method later in this video
for now let us change all of the syntax
so this one also becomes my
static method and I don't want Global
and this becomes my live dot hero live
same thing for this one this also
becomes my static method I don't need
the global I can say
my life got villain life
and
same thing for this one as well
so this also becomes my static method
I don't need the global and this is my
life Dot
that's it just save a file let us go
down
so here what we can say is this is a
list of superheroes so instead of just
character I can say
This Is My Superhero next what I can do
is I can create instances of My
Superhero by using the newly created
class so I can say my Iron Man
is a superhero the name is obviously
Iron Man
next the attack power is
250 and the
life is
1000 so similarly let us create
instances for all of the other
superheroes as well
so here we have we have a black widow
Spiderman and Hulk now since we have
everything in classes I don't require
this constant so I can just take them
out they are not required this becomes a
list of
superheroes
and I have to change this as well
so Iron Man
Black Widow
Spiderman
and Maya Hulk let us go down so this
instead of character we can say this is
going to return a superhero rest
everything Remains the Same so let us go
down to villains this is going to be a
list of our villains
again let us do the same thing let us
create instances so I can say my Thanos
is equal to my villain
the name is
Thanos
my attack power is 400
life is 1500 let us create the rest as
well so we have all of them let us take
out all of this it's not required
this becomes my villain and we need to
change all of this as well
fastest tunnels then it's The Red Skull
and then is Proxima let us go down so
this becomes my villain and everything
is looking good let us go down and let
us see where we need to do some more
changes
this becomes a
superhero and this becomes a villain now
let's see where we are going to use the
class of life and the static methods
that we have created
we are going to use exactly right over
here for the set life and for the actual
attack so here I can say from my life
I want to access the static method
called as increment hero life and I
simply want to pass the life of the
superhero so I can say my superhero dot
live and we can use the syntax because
life is just an instance variable on
superhero so this is the beauty of
working with classes
let us go down again we can do the same
thing we can say
from my class of life I want to access
the static method of increment villain
life
and I want to pass the life of my
villain we don't need all of these lines
we can take them out we can do the same
thing right over here as well so I can
say
live dot I want to decrement my hero
life
let's pass
the attack power of the villain and same
thing below live broad decrement villain
life and let's pass the superhero
attack power
we don't need all of this
we can take it out
let's save our file now let us go to
this line it seems that we have some
error so let's see what's happening
value of superhero is not indexable oh
yeah that's right now since this is a
class we have to say superhero
dot in the name and here also villain
dot name
and now the error is gone let us go down
and here what we can do since hero life
and villain life are now the class
variables of life so we can simply say
live dot hero live
and yet it becomes life dot villain life
and now we have a beautifully typed
object oriented game design so let me
save my file
and let me try to run this
now that's really amazing everything is
working perfect and it seems that I have
also won the game welcome to the last
video in this section this video is all
about the different magic methods that
we can use inside our classes
till now we have seen only three magic
methods one was in it second one was
repr and the third one was Str but
python provides many more of this magic
methods so let me try and cover some of
the most commonly used magic methods
what I've done is behind the scenes I've
created a file called as box
and let us start working with this as
you can see it's completely empty so
let's create a class
call it as box
and
the edit method this box is going to
have two sides so I can say my side a
the type is an integer
similarly we have side B type is an
integer
this is going to return nothing
and
my instance variable so my side a
is equal to my side a and my
side B is equal to my
side of B so let's create the wrapper
method so you are already familiar with
it I am just returning a new string
called as class of box now let me create
the Str method so till now there is
nothing new to you inside my Str method
I'm just returning a nicely formatted
string saying that this is a box and
side a and the value of side B let us
create two boxes so this is my first box
and this is my second box let us also
print them out so I can say
print my box first and print my box
number two as well
so let me save the file and let me run
so till now there is nothing new to you
let us go back now suppose what happens
if you do something like this I want to
say I want to add both of them together
so if I say B1 plus B2 is equal to my B3
and then I want to print my B3 let us
save and let us try to run this file and
see what's happening
it's saying that this is an unsupported
operand and that's because python does
not know how to add one box with another
box but we can implement this
functionality by using different magic
methods
so if you go back and if you say minus
again if you try to run
again we have some sort of an error
because python does not know how to
minus these boxes
and the same thing will happen for all
of the different operations such as
multiplication division less than
greater than less than equal to greater
than equal to and so on but what we can
do is by using different magic methods
we can implement this functionality on
our class so let's see how we can do
this step by step the first thing that I
want to show you is how we can use the
in operator so let me give you a small
example this is my IPython shell
if I say
o in
octolium
so we get a true so let us see how we
can implement this syntax of in for our
box
we can implement this by using another
matching method and the name of this
matching method has to be specific and
the name is underscore underscore
contains underscore underscore
this tricks self as the first argument
the next argument is what we want to
check so let me name that argument as
number
for now let us skip the type and I will
come back to it a little later let us
see what this type has to return let us
go back to my iPad and shell and here
you can see the return type is of the
type of Boolean so that's what is going
to be the return type
so this function is going to return a
Boolean that is it has to return true or
false the logic for this is pretty
simple let me again go back to my iPad
and shell and let me show it first over
here suppose we have a list so let me
call it as L and this is 1 comma 2.
now if I say 1 in my list of L
we get the answer of true if I say 3 in
my list of L we get the answer of false
so what we can do is we can simply
create a list of both the sides so side
1 and side 2 and we can simply compare
that the other argument is inside that
list or not so let's see how to do that
here we can simply say return
if the given number is inside my list
and I can say
the first List member is my self dot
side of a
and my
side of B
now this method works but this is not
foolproof what happens if this second
argument is not a number if someone
provides a Boolean value or some other
value then how we can say the user that
we have an error so for this let me show
you some new syntax so let me go down
let me put a comment now if you remember
when I was teaching you about classes
and instances
we use one method which is called as is
instance and then we could check if the
dog is an instance of animal if the cat
is an instance of animal or not so we
are going to do the same thing right
here we are going to check if this
number is of the type of integer or not
if this number is not of the type of
integer then we can simply throw a
number so here what we can say number
it can be any object we don't know
beforehand what the user is going to
provide so object is a generic term and
if you remember everything inside python
is an object so we can say number could
be any object and now let's try to see
if the number is an integer or not so we
can say if then we can use the inbuilt
function called as is instance
then we can say is my number and
instance of my integer and if not so let
me go up and I can use the word if not
here I want to throw an error so I can
say
raise not implemented error now since
this number is not the type of an
integer we don't know how to do the
comparison so we simply raise an error
in the next section I'll be teaching you
more about errors right now just try and
understand if in a situation we don't
know what to do we can simply raise an
error so that's what we are doing right
over here let me save it and let me show
you it in action so we don't want this
one here I can say is 4 inside my box of
1 and I can also say is
6 inside my box of one let me save it
and let us run this file
so here we have the output let me take
it up 4 in box number one yes and that's
true
six in box number one false let us see
what's happening
so this is our box number one we don't
have a six over here now watch closely
what happens if I write something like
this
I can write a over
let me save it and let me try to run it
and this time we get an error and this
error is of the type of not implemented
error and that is what we have coded if
you go back to our line number line
number 15
since a is a string but we want an
integer so what's happening is in this
line we are raising an error if we try
to evaluate is instance number is a type
of instance it's going to fail because
here the number is actually the string
of a so if not an instance of integer
then we want to raise an error and
that's what we are doing so if we just
open up the terminal we are throwing and
not implemented error so this error
which is called as not implemented error
so this is a standard way of throwing an
error inside this method let's see some
other operators so if I want to say is
my box one
is equal to my box 2. let us see how we
can do this syntax
right now let me take it out
and since this line is always going to
fail let me take it down and let me
comment it out so let me go right over
here and
I want to copy and paste till this one
let me go down
and let me paste
since we want to see both the boxes are
equal or not
the magic method is called as equal
short form EQ let me write the proper
documentation so this
so this checks if both boxes are equal
or not
and this line is the standard check that
we want to have now let's see what to do
right over here this time we expect a
box so let me change the name of the
variable from number to a box let me go
down so this also has to be
box here we want to check if the given
object which we call as box
is an instance of the class of box or
not so instead of integer this has to be
my class of box
so if the another object is also a box
only then we can have a comparison but
there is a small limitation of python we
can't use the syntax directly but we can
use a small hack and let me show how we
can do this
again let me go to the top and I can say
from my future
I want to import my annotations
and now we can use the syntax which is
right over here now let us see how we
can compare both of the boxes
now what happens is the box has a side
side a and a side B if both of the boxes
has to be equal that means both of the
sides should match so that's what we are
going to see right over here I can see
that return self dot side of a is equal
to is equal to
the Box dot side of a
maybe we can rename this variable we can
call this as the other or we can say the
other box
right now I'll just write this as other
so right now we are comparing the self
plot side a with others side a
similarly we also need to compare the
side b as well so here I can say I want
my side a to be equal and I also want my
side B to be equal so I can say self
plot side B
has to be equal to the other Dot
side of B and this also needs to be
changed from box to other so let us go
down and here we can say I want to print
if my box one is equal to my box 2 let
me save this and let me
run this file
and here we have the output false box
number one is not equal to box number
two let us go back and let us try to
implement some other methods let us try
how we can check for less than and less
than equal to so what I mean is how we
can implement this Behavior B1 less than
and B2
or less than or equal to B2 so let us go
up right where and let us start creating
our method let me copy till this line
and let me paste it over here
so whenever we say that we want to
compare if it is less than the magic
method is called as
LT which stands for less than let me
also write the proper documentation so
instead of this we want this one now
let's check if the other box is smaller
or not one simple way of doing this is
by calculating area or you can also use
this syntax but I think using the area
is a much more cleaner method now since
we already have the side A and B we can
define a property for area and we can
use that property right over here
so let me go over here and let me create
a decorator for my property I can say
this is for my area
self
and this returns an integer so I want to
return
my site a multiplied by
my side of B
now this makes things much more simple
so here's simply what I can do is I can
go right over here and I can say return
self dot area
is it less than the others area and
that's it
let me save my file but what happens is
this magic method is only for less than
we also want to compare for less than
and equal to so if you go to this line
number 44 we have an equal operator as
well
so let's see how we can Implement that
and that's pretty simple let me just
copy all of this
and paste it
now this magic method is called as less
than or equal to that means L and E and
on this line we simply have to add equal
to and that's it so let us start
printing all of these things so let me
go down over here here I can say I want
to print if my B1
is less than B2 one more beauty of this
magic method is we have simply defined a
magic method for less than and less than
equal to but python can infer how to
implement greater than or greater than
and equal as well it simply has to
reverse the logic and python does it
behind the scenes we don't have to
create another methods since we already
have these two methods in place
so here I also want to check if my
box of one is greater than my box of 2
we can also use the less than an equal
so we can we can see
if this is my less than or equal and we
can also use the greater than an equal
so this one
let me take out this line let me
comment all of this let me
comment all of this and let us try to
run this one
so here we have the output let us check
if the output is true or not the first
one is is my box number one less than my
box number two
let's see what's happening
3 multiplied by 4 is 12
2 multiplied by 5 is then so that means
my box number one is larger than my box
number two
let's see the statement so this is
exactly opposite my box number one is
larger so this becomes false and that's
what we have over here in the second
line yes my box number one is larger so
we have the output of true
and so on for the line number 53 and 54
as well let us go back and let us see
some other methods as well now let us
see how we can Implement some basic
operations such as addition
multiplication division and so on
luckily writing all of those methods is
just a matter of copy and paste so let
me show you first let us create a method
for addition so where we can add two
boxes let me copy and paste since this
is for addition the magic method is
called as ADD let me change the
documentation and let me also get my
spacing right
and here we simply have to add the areas
that's it let's check what's the error
oh yes now it's saying that it got an
integer as the return type but it is
expecting and Boolean so let's see
what's happening oh yes here we have
written Boolean as the written value but
that's not what is happening area is an
integer so let us update this from
Boolean to an integer so you see there
are so many benefits of having a very
well typed code let us Implement other
methods for subtraction multiplication
and division as well let us create one
for subtraction
and since it is a subtract we can
say that this is subtract let me change
the documentation
and this becomes
minus let us do for
multiplication
and since this is multiplication this
becomes mul for multiplication
let me change the documentation
and this becomes multiplied the next one
for division now this becomes a little
tricky if you think for division it
would be just div you are partially
right but that's not what is happening
let us go back to our IPython shell and
let me try and explain what's going to
happen
so suppose if I say 1 divided by 2
we have the answer of 0.5 this is called
as true division now if I say 2 divided
by 3 we get the answer of 0.6 as well
again you can see this is a true
division
but if you watch closely we have two
integers and the output is a float what
happens if you want to have the output
as an integer as well
in that case we have to use
double slash and then three
so this syntax is called as flow
Division and this syntax is called as a
true division the written value of an
true division is always a float and the
return value of floor division is an
integer so let us go back to our code
and see how we can do this the first one
can be our true division so I can just
say this is my true Division and this
becomes my true division now remember
that the return type is going to be a
float this time
since this is going to be a true
division
let me copy and paste this for our
floor division so here I can say I want
to have my
floor Division and here I want to have
one more slash and that's it let us go
and let us print out all of these things
so let me go right over here and let me
put all of my print statements let me
comment all of these things out and let
me try to run this file and here we have
the output
so B1 minus B2 is 2 let us check if that
is the case or not
so the area of first box is 12 the area
of the second box is 10 and that's what
is happening so 12 minus 10 we get the
answer of 2. and if you check the answer
of all of the other methods obviously
all of them are going to be right
when I was going through the code I
realized that we have a small mistake
it's not really a mistake it is just
about following the best practices of
python so let me try and explain
everywhere we are trying and throwing
this error called as not implemented
error which is absolutely fine but the
guidelines in Python suggest that
whenever we have a binary operation that
time we simply have to raise an error
which is called as not Implement so this
and this are two different things please
keep that in mind so let me Rectify all
of these things
so let me just copy and paste it
everywhere
so all of this let me do my multi select
this becomes my not implemented
this one and this one as well so let me
save the file what I mean by an binary
operation so all of this operations
minus plus multiplication division Etc
all of these are called as binary
operations
but this one when we are checking 4
inside B1 this is not a binary operation
so in this case we are using
not implemented error and whenever we
have a binary operation at that time we
are using just not implemented
well that's it for this video and now we
are officially at the end of the section
and I will see you in the next section
where I will try and expand your
knowledge of error handling in Python
welcome to a new section this section is
all about error handling in Python
now errors in Python can be divided into
a couple of categories
the first category can be thought as
your syntax errors that means whenever
you make some errors in typing those
errors are called as your syntax errors
now fortunately these errors are very
easy to catch and these days we have
much better tooling inside Visual Studio
code and our plugin my Pi or if you are
using an IDE such as pycharm all of
these tools will help you to catch
syntax errors
the second category can be thought as
your runtime errors
that means this errors are not reflected
inside your code but whenever you try to
run it this errors will pop up this
error is a little bit difficult to debug
so as we saw in our last video whenever
we can't handle a situation we were
raising some kind of Errors so when we
raise those kind of Errors at least we
can have some idea what's going wrong
during our run time and this errors in
Python are called as exceptions so let's
see one by one all of this the first
thing that we are going to see is the
most common one and that is called as
your syntax errors so let me go back to
my code editor and what I've done is
behind the scenes I've created a new
folder called as 0 7 error handling and
this is a file called as maths dot pi
now let's see what's happening there is
some red line right here print X and Y
this is an example of my syntax errors
so at least I need to have a comma right
over here or I need to have like my
formatted string so something like this
and this has to be inside my curlies
and this as well
and now if you try and save your error
will go away so this is one of the most
common errors called as a syntax error
now let me try and show you what do I
mean by a runtime error so what I've
done is I've created another file called
as divider and let's see what's going to
happen this time let's create a function
that divides two numbers so I can say
Define divide
the first number could be an X the next
is in y
and this does not return anything
and we can simply print out my x divided
by y so till now everything looks
perfect and we don't have any errors now
let me go down
and let me say I want to divide my
four
by zero now what's going to happen we
can't divide any number by zero it's
just not possible so what is going to
happen is our program is going to panic
and it is going to exit so let me save
and let me run this file and let me show
you this in action so here it is our
program pan it and we have an error
which is called as zero division error
division by zero so this is an example
of runtime errors
there are no visible errors inside the
code but whenever we are trying to
execute this code we have some errors so
let me put a comment over here so this
throws or raises an error and the type
of the error is zero division error if
you open up a terminal that's what we
have so this is a type of error or
rather this is a type of exception in
the world of python let us try to expand
our knowledge of errors
so in this program we saw that when we
Panic we get an error this error is a
very specific one and the name of this
error is called as 0 division error now
python gives us an error handling
mechanism in the form of try and accept
blocks so let us see how we can use that
syntax to catch this zero division error
so let me go back and let me create a
new file and I can name the file as
smart
divider dot pi
so let us create our function called as
smart divider again it's going to accept
X which is integer
Y is also an integer this is
returning nothing
now let's see how we can do a very smart
division last time we saw that when we
divided by 0 we got an error and that
error was 0 division error we can catch
that by using our try and accept blocks
so this is how the try and accept blocks
goes so inside the trial
this is the code that you want to try so
trying the code
and in case this code fails then we can
say accept and this is the place we are
going to catch the specific error
and we have that error then do something
with the error
let us see how we can fill these blocks
so inside try let us see if we can
divide or not so I can just say my
number
is equal to x divided by y
and I want to
print out my number now what happens if
we get the same zero division error so
we can tell python that whenever we are
going to have that error I want my
accept block to catch it so I can say
accept my
zero division error so that means
whenever I get this error I want to
catch that error and after catching that
error I can do something with it so let
me just print out some message
can't divide by 0 use some other number
now let us go back and let us try
dividing by 4 with 0
and let us try to run this so this time
we have a much better output our program
is not panicking instead we get a very
helpful message saying that can't divide
by 0 use some other number so as you can
see we can handle our errors now imagine
one more scenario
instead of 4 I write as a
then what happens let us run and see
what's happening this time again we have
some other error and this time the error
is called as type error and
unfortunately our program is panicking
and it is terminating Midway let's see
how we can handle this situation as well
so let me go back and let me create
another file this time I will name it as
really smart divider and let us start
writing the code for this one let me
copy and paste the code from my smart
divider so
let me take all of this and paste inside
my really smart divider
so since this is a really smart divider
I can say this is my really smart
divider let us have a look at the error
one more time so what's happening is
let me take it down
so what's happening is we were trying to
divide by a
now a is of the type of a string and
fourth is all the type of integer
both of them are essentially of
different types so that's what this
error is saying so we have a type error
let us see how we can catch this error
as well we can chain our accept blocks
so we can say if we have a zero division
error then I want to catch it right over
here but if there is a type error so I
can say accept my type error let me
catch it right over here
and this time I can print out both X and
Y needs to be a number but what happens
if we don't know what kind of error we
are going to get that time we can use
some other syntax and this is called as
accept
exception so now this exception class is
the base class for all of the different
exceptions so just as we saw in our
classes dog was a subclass of animal so
same thing all of these errors zero
division error type error and all of
these things all of these errors inherit
from exception now the same logic goes
over here
dog is an animal cat is an animal same
thing any errors that we get is also an
exception and that's what we are trying
to catch over here here we can also add
an alias so we can say I want to catch
my exception
as a variable called as e then we can
simply print out what happened wrong so
here I can say
oops something went wrong and let me
print out my exception which we are
calling just as e
and that's it this time we have a really
smart divider let's try to invoke it
so I can say my really
smart divider cannot divide 3 with 0 can
you divide
three with four
can divide 3 with a
now let me try to save and run this file
and this time we have the output
so the first time we have a 0 so we have
the output can't divide by zero
second time everything looks good so we
have the answer
third time we have a string so we have
the output both X and Y needs to be a
number we are making really good
progress with errors
and let us learn the last missing pieces
for our error handling
so let me create a new file let me call
it as try
else and finally dot pi
and let me copy all of the code from my
really smart divider and let me paste
into this file let let us call the
function just as divider so let me
take this out
there are two more pieces for this
puzzle so till now we have seen the try
block and the accept block now let's see
the else block now what happens is if
this condition succeeds then the code
inside the else block can be executed so
inside my try block I am just trying to
see if I can divide x with Y if this
succeeds then I can say that I want to
print
right over here the naming is a little
weird but we can't really help it so
whenever a try block succeeds we can use
an else block to execute some other code
as well let me add a couple of print
statements just for the sake of clarity
so else is executed only when try
succeeds so we are trying to see if x
can be divided by y or not and if that
succeeds only then we want to print out
the number now the last piece is called
as
finally
now no matter what happens if the try
succeeds or it fails this finary block
is always going to execute so let me
write a print statement right over here
you may not appreciate the beauty of
this block finally but just imagine a
scenario that you're writing a web
application and you want to write
something to the database or suppose you
are interacting with some other apis and
you want to do some kind of a cleanup
operation maybe you want to delete some
files maybe you want to insert some
files so no matter the outcome if the
operation succeeds or fails we can have
that logic inside the finally block now
let me save this file and let me run
this file
so as you can see
we always have this output of finally so
no matter the outcome we always have
this block let me comment one of this so
that we have much more clarity we try
and run the file so we have a zero
division error and since we have some
error the code inside the else block did
not execute but the code inside our
final block executed and we have this
output right over here now let me go
back and let us drive the second one let
me comment this out and let me try to
run this so now see what's happening
since this operation is succeeding
we go to the else block and inside the
else block we first print these two
lines
so that's what is happening we have
those two lines right over here and
after that we are printing out the
number so which is 0.75
and this block finally this is always
going to execute so that's what is
happening so if you try with this one
you can have the same output so let me
uncomment this so since we have an error
our else block will not execute let me
run this file for the last time so here
it is we have a statement saying that X
and Y needs to be number
the code inside the edge block is
totally omitted but the code inside
final block is executed and we have the
output right over here let us have a
look at the next kind of error and this
kind of error is called as assertion
error now this assert statement that I
am going to show you this statements are
very useful in testing now we are not
going to learn testing in the series but
I just wanted to show you the assert
statement so what I have done is behind
the scenes I've created a file called as
find Sohan so what's going to happen
right now is
Lewis has a list of friends and let us
try to see if we can find a particular
friend in that list or not so let me
name the function as find Zohan
and this accepts a name of the friend
that we want to find so this returns
nothing so we can say none
so this is the list of friends so I can
just copy and paste it right over here
now let us create our try and else
blocks so normally you'd write as name
in my list of friends
and this would give you a Boolean value
of true or not
but what we can do is we can also use
the keyword of assert so what I mean to
say that I want python to assert if the
name is inside the list of friends or
not if the name is not present that
means we can have a kind of error and
this time the error would be assertion
error so let us use the accept block to
catch our assertion error so you can say
or not arithmetic I want
assertion and then we can see let us
print out the name
not found now in case we get a match and
this statement succeeds then we can also
write the else block and we can print
out saying that
found
followed by the name
we can also include the final block
remember that this is always going to
execute let us print Maybe
goodbye that's it let us try searching
for a couple of friends
so I can say find
Zohan and let us try to find for Zohan
himself let me copy and paste
and let me try to search for Sarah and
let us run this file
so we can see
in the first case we found Zohan so we
are printing out fine Zohan the final
block always executes we have so we have
goodbye as well
the second time we could not find Sarah
and it threw an assertion error which
was caught inside this except block
so we have the output of Sarah is not
found
and
the finery block again executed so we
have the output of goodbye till now we
have been seeing how to catch an error
but now let us see how we can actually
throw an error
so let me create a new file right over
here
this is going to be my fine Zohan part 2
dot pi
and let me copy and paste all of this
code from here
now let's get working on this file now
since I am not catching any errors I
don't require this try and else blocks
so let me take it out now if you can't
find the name inside the list of friends
at that time we want to raise an error
so we can say that we can't find the
given value that means we can raise a
value error here we can say if
the name is not inside my list of
friends
then I can raise an error and I can
raise a value error and I can also give
a custom message saying that the name
is not found
and we can also say else in case we find
the match we can simply
print it out we can say found
and followed by the name so let me save
it and let me try and run this file
so the first time we have a match so our
program will not panic but the second
time we don't have a match and our
program will Panic with an value error
so let's see that in action
and here we have it the first time we
could find a match so we have an output
but for the second time our program
panicked and it threw the value error
which you can see right over here so we
have a value error followed by our
message saying that Sarah is not found
well this brings us to the end of this
section as well if you want to learn
more about errors you can go to this
link so this is all of the files from
GitHub go inside this folder error
handling and go to this file readme I
have put up a reference right over here
you can visit this link to learn more
about errors and that's it for this one
and I will catch you in the next section
welcome to a brand new section
this section is all about learning
packages packages are used to organize
our code so let's see how to create some
packages but before that let us see a
couple of examples where we have used
them for example inside our game we have
been importing a random end from random
I also enum and auto from enum what this
means is we are importing something that
is useful from us
from a package or a module and you can
see this gives a very nice organization
so it's very clear from a random module
I am importing something random from my
enum I'm importing something as enum so
you get a lot more clarity inside your
code so let me go inside my zero eight
packages folder and inside of this let
me create a new folder the name of this
one is 0 1
local
modules for the sake of clarity I am
going to open this newly created module
inside a new code editor window so I can
just go inside this
I can say 0 8 packages and I want my
code Editor to open
zero one local modules in a new window
so here we are if we just hover you can
see I am inside my folder01 local
modules suppose you are taking a maths
class and you have to do a lot of
calculations and this calculations
involve squares rectangles circles and
so on so let's see how we can divide all
of this functionality by using our
modules let's say we have to do some
operations on a circle so let's create
the first file
let me call this as
Circle Dot py
and let me create a class of circle and
let us create the init method so I can
say Define my init this takes itself and
this also takes a radius
suppose the radius can be a float value
this returns nothing
and inside we can say self Dot
radius is equal to my
radius let us also create the Str method
so I can say my
Str would be myself
and this returns a string here I can
return saying that my
radius is my
self dot radius now in the same class
you also have to deal with rectangles so
in order to organize our code we can
create another file for this rectangle
we don't have to Club all of the
functionality inside a single file so
let's do that so right over here let me
create a new file called as rectangle.pi
and let us create the class for
rectangle
let us create one more file for dealing
with squares
so I can create another file called as
my Square dot pi
and let me just copy and paste from
rectangle
so let me paste it
this becomes my
Square this becomes just my
side I don't need this
and my
side is equal to my side
this becomes minus square and I can just
say that this is
My Side Y my side and that's it oh I
forgot to put a colon so
so what we did is we segregated all of
the functionality into different files
now technically all of these files are
called as modules inside python we may
call them as files but they are
identified as modules
so what we can do is we can import
functionality from this modules so let's
say we have a file called as geometry
and from that model of geometry we can
import all of these functionalities and
we can work with them so let me show you
all of these things in action
so let me create a file called as
geometry dot pi and here I can see from
my module of circle I want to import the
class of circle
same thing we can do for rectangle and
square so I can say
from the module of my
rectangle
I want to import my rectangle
and the last one from my model of square
I want to
I want to import
Square
so what we are doing is we are simply
importing the things that we want to
work with now this file Circle rectangle
and square they can have multiple
functions or they can have multiple
classes but we just need to import the
things that we want to work with so let
us create a circle
maybe the radius is 5
let us create a rectangle so I can say
my
rectangle let me give some random values
then let us create a square
let me give some random value as well
and then we can simply print them out so
this is my C
and this is my rectangle and this is my
Square let me save it and let me try to
run this file
so as you can see we have the right
output first one is a circle with a
radius of 5 then we have a rectangle and
then we have a square so in this example
what we did is we created different
modules but if you look closely Square
rectangle and circle all of these things
belong together and we can create a
package which I will show you in the
next video we just saw how to create
different modules and in this video I
will teach you how to take all of the
common models together and how to create
a package out of it you must have
noticed that we have a couple of
additional files
let me take it right over here so this
was the folder that we created in the
last video and you can see we have
multiple different folders one of the
first folder that you can see is for
this one this is called as py cache you
don't have to touch this folder this is
just a mechanism by python to speed up
your code just let it be there now for
this video let me just copy and paste
this folder
and let me
rename this to 0 to
package
and also let me open up the folder
inside a new window so I can say code
02 package
so here we are so this is the exact same
code that we created in our last video
now what happens is circle rectangle and
square all of this are similar all of
this are shapes and we can organize our
code in a much better way so let's
create a package which is called as
shapes so packages are nothing they are
just a special kind of directory so let
me create my directory and let me name
it as shapes
after this I am just going to copy my
circle inside my shapes yes I want to
move
same thing for my rectangle and my
Square as well so let me just drag all
of these files inside my folder of
shapes
yes I want to move now we need just one
more file to declare that this folder is
and package and not just an ordinary
directory the way to do that is by
creating a file and the name of the file
is very important the name of the file
is underscore underscore init underscore
underscore Dot py when python sees this
file it considers your directory to be
an package now let's see how we can
import all of this circle rectangle and
square in our file of geometry
so here you can see we have a couple of
errors and that's because we have moved
all of this code inside a new package
and the name of the package is called as
shapes so here we have to say that from
my package of shapes
I want you to go to the model of circle
and you can say that by putting a DOT
so this means from my package of shapes
I want you to go to the model of circle
and inside the model of circle I want
you to import my class of circle
same thing will go with the rectangle
so here I can say
shape slot rectangle and this also goes
to
my shapes dot Square just save a file
and that's it if you try to run the file
here you can see we have a proper output
there is one more concept that I wanted
to explain in this video
so what's happening in this video is
shapes is an isolated directory or you
can say it's an isolated package
which has certain functionality
and we have created a file called as
geometry and this file is interacting
with our package of shapes so
conceptually you can call this file as
your client and the package of shapes as
your API so what we are doing is we have
created a client file which is
interacting with our API
it's a very simple concept now let us
see how we can import functionality from
within a package itself so let me copy
and paste this folder and let me call
this as
0 3
and local package and let me open this
folder in a new window
so I can say code
0 3
now suppose you are inside your package
of shapes and inside this package if you
have to work with any of the modules how
would you do it let me show you with a
small example suppose we have a file
called as shape dot pi and inside this
file if you want to import Circle
rectangle and square you must be
thinking that we can simply say from
rectangle I want to import rectangle
well you are partially right but not
entirely right the way to do it is by
putting a DOT right over here
so this means that from my current
package so this dot means my current
package from my current package I want
you to go to my model of rectangle and
from that module I want you to import
rectangle let's do the same thing for
Circle so I can say dot Circle I want to
import my circle and also I can say from
dot of square
I want to import my Square now let us go
to our client file and let's see how we
can interact with this file so let me go
back to my geometry dot Pi now this
syntax is perfectly fine it's going to
work but let us use our newly created
file so what we have done is we have
created a file called as shapes dot pi
and we have imported all of the other
models inside this file so here what we
can do is we can simply say from map
package of shapes
I want to import the model of shapes so
this shape means this module right over
here and here we can see I want the
circle which is inside my model of
shapes
and that's it let me copy and paste it
everywhere
let me
paste it here
paste it here
and that's it let me save it and let me
try to run this file and we have the
right output let's see if we can further
improve our code so I'm going to copy
this folder and paste it one more time
and let me rename this to 0 4 package
underscore init
and let me open up that folder in a new
window so
my code04
okay so here we are so what we were
doing in the last video is we created a
new model called as shapes and this
module was importing the functionality
from all of the other modules but we can
do better instead of creating a new
module we can simply take all of this
Imports let us copy them and let us put
all of these things inside my init file
that's it just save it and I can't get
rid of this file so let me just delete
this it's not required
now let us go back to our clan file so
this is our geometry here we can simply
say that I just want to import shapes
and that's it
just save a file and everything should
work just as before so let me try to run
this file and still we have the right
output so what's happening is we are
just importing the entire package and
since we have all of the modules which
are imported inside our init method we
can have access to all of them right
over here so this init method just acts
like a Constructor for your entire
package so it's similar to our classes
we were using the same naming convention
to have a Constructor for our class the
same thing goes over here but here we
are constructing a package instead of a
class and that's about it I am so
excited to see you in the last section
in this last section we have two
projects the first one is for a cash
register and the second one is obviously
is going to be our game but this section
marks a fundamental shift till now we
have been thinking and writing with our
types but this time we would be seeing
how we can organize the code in
different layers just in the last
section we saw how we can create
packages packages was one way of
organizing our code but now let's try to
think beyond our packages let's try to
think more about in the architecture
point of view now this concept may sound
a little alien but by the time we are
finished with our projects this concept
would be much clear to you for now let
us concentrate on the first project so
this project is all about a cash
register but before we can jump in and
just start writing our code I want us to
take some time and let us think how we
can design this application so I want
you to take back to the concept of voc
dtp so this is a very simple concept
which I propose for your learning so
this concept stands for your visualize
outline code so this is your face number
one once you're done with the first
phase the second phase would be debug
test and polish let us try to see one
concept at a time
so this is going to be our problem
statement we simply want to make a
simple cache register suppose you have a
shop and you want to create a software
for your cash register so basically we
just want to implement at what's
happening at our checkout counter just
try to imagine what's happening over
there normally you would hand your items
to the cashier the cashier would scan
the item he will generate an invoice the
cashier would accept the payments and he
will hand over the products to you so
out of all of these things let us just
try to concentrate on the cash register
so let us go to our first phase which is
this one visualize outline and code
inside this phase the first step would
be to visualize let us try to visualize
how our application would look like
let's try to imagine what's happening
inside the cache register as soon as the
cash shares scans an item an item is
added to the invoice now what happens if
the customer wants to change the
quantity the cashier can simply update
the quantity and what happens if the
customer changes his mind and he wants
to drop an item then simply cashier can
delete the item from the invoice the
next thing that I want you to think is
an item can also have different
components such as a discount of our tax
which can be added to the invoice now
just to help you visualize how our code
will look after implementing our cash
register I have created a nice
dictionary so let me show you this is
how our final outcome should look like
let me zoom out a bit
okay
so this is our final outcome
if you watch closely it's not
complicated it's just a dictionary
structure we have a couple of keys and
we have a couple of values
let's see what keys do we have the first
key is for the customer the next key is
for the invoice total the next one is
for the items and the last one is for
the purchase date now let's see at the
values the value for the customer is a
dictionary itself the value for the
total is a float now here for the items
it gets a little more interesting this
bracket to this bracket this is the
value and inside this value we again
have dictionaries so these are the
different items so we have one atom for
an apple the next one is for an egg next
one for milk and inside this items we
can add different components such as
your discount
your quantity and your subtotal and for
the purchase date we simply have to
display the date of purchase that's very
easy now the thing is I could visualize
this data structure just because I have
some practice but the same thing can
happen with you when you practice a
little bit more you can visualize this
design even before you can start coding
let us go to the next step let me zoom
in again let us go to the next step
which is outline here what we are trying
to do is we simply want to outline our
structure so if you see right over here
in this step we have a couple of
different objects
first one was for the customer for the
invoice total items and so on so let us
try to outline what component or what
classes or what objects we would require
inside our application
so here I am inside the next step for
outline
obviously we require a customer the next
thing we require is the item that the
customer is buying
and the next thing which I have already
explained we require an invoice entry
why do we require a separate invoice
entry is because different items can
have different discounts or offers or
they could have some kind of Taxation so
for the sake of Simplicity let us call
this item as invoice item so this means
once you have the item Insider invoice
it will have a slightly different
structure and finally we have a place
called as cash register so this object
keeps in record of everything that is
happening on the counter so let's try to
summarize the objects that we are going
to require so we need a customer we need
an item we need one more for the invoice
item and the last one obviously we
require a cash register so till now we
have much more clarity about our
application and the different objects
that would be going inside our
application and you would be tempted to
just open up your code editor and start
writing your code but I want you to hold
your guns let's try to do little bit
more planning so before we can write the
code let us try to describe how our
objects so that means let us try to
visualize how all of these objects would
look like in the world of python so
let's see I have created a couple of
diagrams for you this is how our
customer would look like our customer
would require a couple of instance
variable it could also have some methods
and the type of them and obviously our
customer needs a first name and last
name the type of this one is obviously
is good with string and for the sake of
customer we don't require any methods
now let us go to the next object or the
next class
so this class is for the actual item
itself we need some kind of an
identifier so that every product needs a
unique ID so we can have an ID as our
instance variable
then we also need a name for an item
then we also require a price in this
case let us keep the type as a float
because we may have some decimal places
as well the next one is a little more
interesting we also need one instance
variable for the measurement unit here
the question is how do you measure the
product
it can be in kgs grams liters Etc so we
need some kind of a unit that will
describe how to measure this item now
let's go to the next object or the next
class this is our invoice item this
class is pretty simple it has to accept
one item so I have created one instance
variable for the item and since there
can be some kind of a discount we need
one more instance variable for a
discount and the customer can purchase
in multiple quantities so we have one
more instance variable for quantity now
for this class we require one more
method and that is to have our subtotal
we need some small Maps over here we
need to figure out how much is a
discount and how much is the quantity so
each item can have a different subtotal
and that's what we are trying to
calculate inside this method let us go
to the next and the last class that we
require
and this one is for our cash register so
this class is going to record everything
that is happening inside our shop so
let's have a look at the different
instance variables first obviously it
needs to know who is the customer that
is making the purchase it also needs to
know the different items that are being
purchased it also needs to record the
purchase date and here you must be
thinking that we require one more
instance variable to display the invoice
total well you are right but instead of
just creating an instance variable we
are going to create a method called as
get invoice total the reason is we have
different items and different items have
different subtotals so let us use this
method to calculate the total of all of
the subtotals this is more of a
convenience feature now let's see what
are the methods this class is going to
have obviously at the cache register you
can add an item you can update an item
you can remove an item and at the last
we can also display our invoice so till
this time we have much more clarity on
our application we have a nice outline
in place we know which classes or which
objects needs to go inside our
application we know what instance
variables are required the type of them
the methods that are required for all of
these things so we have a much better
design and a much better Clarity with us
and now we can think of writing all of
these things inside our code editor but
before we can do that I just wanted to
show you one more thing so the document
that I have put together this is
technically also known as a unified
modeling language diagram
well to be precise this diagram is a
little bit different from the document
that I have put you can go to Google and
check it out I have left the links in
the redmi file and in fact free code cam
has a full course on unified modeling
language you can click over here to have
the link for this one the next thing is
just to translate all of this document
inside the code and I have just shown
you once we are done with our code the
cache register would look something like
this
so this is what we are trying and going
to code and this structure that we are
going to code can also be imagined to be
a data structure so now we get it there
is nothing big about data structures it
is just a way to represent our data here
you can see that we have a custom data
structure of the type of cache register
in the next video we will actually start
writing the code and I will see you then
now let's get going what I've done is
I've created a folder called as 0 9
projects and inside this folder I've
created one more folder called as
project one cache register and I also
have this file inside my project so let
me open up this project in a new window
so I can say code
and here it is
so now let's start writing our code let
us see our outline
here you can see that we have four
different objects that are required so
let's start with one of them at a time
let us create the first file for our
customer so it's going to be customer
dot Pi this is going to be class of
customer
and let me Define my init method is
going to be a self and let us go back to
the document and here we can see we
already know the instance variables and
the type the two variables would be
first name and the last name let me just
collapse my sidebar so let's create the
init method for the first name and the
last name so let me go over here so my
first name is a string my last name is
also a string and this returns nothing
here I can say that my self DOT first
name is equal to my first name and then
my self dot last name is equal to my
last name let us create an wrapper
method for this as well so let me say
self this always returns a string and
this can return a very simple string
saying that this is a class for customer
let me add some documentation class as
well okay so this is the class for the
customer details now I'll just create
the Str method so this takes in a cell
and returns a string so we can say I
simply want to return self DOT first
name and I also require myself dot last
name let us go back and see which is the
next item so the next object that we
want to create is
for an item so let me open up my sidebar
let me create a new file called as item
dot pi
and let's see what are the different
parameters required so item requires
four different instance variables ID of
the type of integer name String price
float and measurement unit which is
going to be a string so let me
go back to my file of items.pi
and I can say my class of item let me
add some documentation then let's create
our init method so I can say my init
cell the first one was the ID that type
is integer the next one was name the
type is a string next one was price the
type is a float the last one was
measurement unit this is going to be our
string this returns nothing let us
create the instance variable so self dot
ID is equal to my ID
then self dot name is equal to the name
self dot price is equal to my price
and self dot measurement unit is equal
to my measurement unit let me add a
small comment over here so our
measurement unit could be a kg or ml or
so on next let us create the repr method
so I can say wrapper self returns per
string and I can say return that this is
a class of item next let us create the
Str method so Str self this returns a
string and you can say return then we
can put the name of the item and let's
display the price so let's say it's
going to be dollars and it's self dot
price per unit so we can say self dot
measurement unit let's go to the
document and see which is the next thing
that we want to create so the next thing
is invoice item things get a little more
interesting from here
if you see the instance variable the
first one is an item but the type is an
item so please keep that in mind
and for this class you also have a
method called as get subtotal and this
method Returns the subtotal after
adjusting for the discount and for the
quantity so let's create one more file
right here let me call it as
invoice item dot py let me collapse my
sidebar and let's say this is going to
be class of my invoice item let me add
some documentation let's create the init
file init cell the first argument is for
an item and the type is item but this is
not going to work because we don't have
item in this file let us import it from
the module so we can just go right over
here and we can see from the module of
my item I want to import the class of
item now this will work the next
argument was for quantity and the type
was integer the last one is for Discount
the type is a float here we can do one
more trick we can assign the values
right over here so that means if the
user does not provide an argument for
Discount that means by default the
discount would be assigned a value of 0
so this is a very convenient feature of
python now this is going to return none
self dot item is equal to my item self
dot quantity is equal to my quantity
self dot my discount is equal to my
discount now let's see what else we
require
so we also require a method called as
get subtotal so let's create that method
but before that let us create our
wrapper and Str method so let me write
my wrapper takes itself returns a string
and it can written saying that this is a
class of invoice item the next is for my
string takes the self and returns an Str
and let us create a nice string for this
so we can say the item and let us
display the self now here I want to
display the name of the item and we can
get the name of the item through our
type of item
so we can say self Dot item Dot
name so if you go to the definition of
item you can see we have an instance
variable of name so this is what we are
trying to refer right over here next we
can say the quantity and let us display
self dot quantity then let us display
the discount so we can see this is
dollars
and it is self dot discount we can also
display
the subtotal we have not yet created
this but we will create it shortly so
let me write it first and then we will
create it so I can say subtotal would be
self Dot get subtotal remember we have
not yet created this method but we will
create it shortly and let's do one more
small trick over here
let us display only two decimal places
we can do that by using the syntax so we
can say colon and we just want two
decimal places for our float
uh now this line looks a little longer
so let us try to divide it so let me
take this line and let us put a bracket
opening one and the closing one let me
take it inside and let me cut all of
these things clear and let me go to the
next line and let me paste it over here
okay so this looks much better now this
is complaining because we don't have
this method till now let us go and
create this method so we can say Define
get sub total this just takes the cell
and this Returns the float now let us
see how we can get the subtotal what I'm
going to do is I am going to use a very
simple Trick In fact I am going to
define a private member right over here
so let me put up a comment saying that
this is a private member let me call it
as self dot underscore subtotal now
remember since I want this very able to
be kept as private that's why I'm using
underscore right over here now python
does not have a concept of private and
public but this symbolizes to other
developers that we want to keep this
variable as private now let's just
calculate the subtotal which is pretty
easy so we require the price from the
item multiplied by the quantity and
minus the discount now let us go back to
this method get subtotal and we simply
have to return it so I can say self dot
subtotal the reason why we are doing all
of these things is I don't want any
other developer or any other user to
accidentally change my subtotal I want
it to be kept as private that's why I'm
using this method you can also create a
property called as subtotal which is
also a valid solution you can definitely
do that but right now for the sake of
Simplicity I'm just creating a private
member let us go back to the document
and see what is next so the next one
that we want to create is for the cache
register itself so this is the cash
register note the types that we have
over here customer is all the type of
customer then we have the next instance
variable items the type is in dictionary
then we have the purchase date the type
is date time and we have a couple of
methods on this as well let us create a
new file right over here and call it as
cash register dot Pi let me collapse my
sidebar and we can say my class of cash
register let me add some documentation
that this is the cash register for each
customer then we can Define the init
method so self so as we just saw the
first argument is for the customer that
type is customer we also need to import
customer which we will do shortly we
also need to have one more for the items
and
that is a dictionary
and we need one more for the date
but before we can finish all of this
definition let me first go and import
customer so I can say from the module of
customer I want to import my customer
now let me go down over here this
Returns the none here I want you to wait
and think how to create the instance
variable in this case what I'm going to
do is I'm not going to accept items over
here instead let us create an instance
variable directly first let us say self
Dot customer is equal to my customer
here we can say self dot items is equal
to an empty dictionary just imagine
before purchasing anything the basket is
always empty so that's what we are
saying this has to be items
that's what we are saying since we don't
have any items inside our checkout
that's why let us assign an empty
dictionary to it but here how do we
Define what are going to be the keys and
what are going to be the values of this
dictionary let us write the type in
right where items is my dictionary but
what are the types which is the key and
which is the value let us go back to our
design document and try and see what we
exactly want
this is a small trick right over here if
you see the design of items items is
actually a dictionary and inside this
dictionary we have the key is of the
type of a string so let us go back to
our definition right over here and we
can see the key is going to be of the
type of string
now let's see what is going to be the
type of value so let us go back the
value is of the type of invoice type
so if we remember inside the invoice
item we have fields for the discount
name quantity and we are also
calculating the subtotal so what we can
do is inside the cache registry we can
have the value which is of the type of
invoice item so I can say invoice item
let us go up and let us also import so
that we can use it so I can say from
my module of invoice item I want to
import the class of invoice item so
remember whenever we are creating these
items
the key is always going to be the string
so if you just go back to the design
document
here it is inside the items the key is
always going to be the name of the item
and the value is always going to be of
the type of invoice type let us go back
to the class the next one that we want
is for the purchase date now we have
already seen it earlier we can
automatically create the purchase date
by using our date time library and
that's what we are going to do in this
document as well first let us go and
import so I can say I can say from date
time I want to import my date time and
let us create an instance variable we
can call it as self dot purchase did and
we can generate this automatically by
using date time and we want today's date
time so we can just say now let us go
down and let us create the wrapper and
the scr method so I can say this is my
repr self returns or spring
and I can say return that this is a
class of cash register let us also
Define an SDR method we can say cell
it returns a string here we can just
return and here we can say first I want
to display my customer so let us display
my customer now what's going to happen
right over here is we are simply calling
self Dot customer
and if you go to the customer so let me
open up my customer file the scr of
customer file returns a string in this
format first name and the last name so
whenever we are printing this customer
by default we will get the first and the
last name together
we don't have to say customer DOT first
name and last name it's not required
next let us also display the total
number of items so we can say total
items and we can get that
from the length of our items so let us
go back to the document
here it is so items is a dictionary we
have three keys apple egg and milk so
that means we have a length of three
till now we have been using Len with
lists but we can also use length with
dictionaries as well and when you use
length with dictionary it's always going
to count the number of items so that's
what we want right over here so total
items is the length of my self dot items
let us now implement the different
methods for this one
let us see which methods we require
so let me scroll a little up
so we require methods to add update
remove and so on
first let us see how we can add items to
our cache register so let us go back let
us create a new method called as add
item by default the first argument
itself now let's see which are the
arguments we need to accept if we have
to add an item we need to know what's
the item so the first argument is going
to be an item the type is going to be an
item let us go and import item as well
so I can say from my model of item let
me import my class of item let us go
back to this method now since we know
which is the item we also need to know
how much is the quantity so this is
going to be an integer
and we also need to know how much is a
discount so discount is going to be a
float we can do one more trick over here
if quantity and discount are not given
we can set some default values so by
default the discount would be zero and
by default the quantity will always be 1
so this returns and none so let me write
none over here let me add some
documentation
and let us see how we can write the body
of this function now the first thing is
we would like to add an item to a card
only if it is not existing if we already
have this item inside our cash register
we can simply update it we don't have to
add it so the first check would be for
this one so I can say so I can say if my
item dot name not in my
cell of items first let us type it out
and then I will explain what's happening
so let us go to the next line here I
want to create a new item
but if you scroll up the key is a string
the value is an invoice item so that's
what I am going to create right over
here if you find it a little confusing
just go with the flow and after we are
done typing this function I will explain
what's happening so here I want to
create a new item is equal to the type
is an invoice item so create an instance
of my invoice item and let's see what it
takes it takes an item quantity and
discount that we already have right over
here we just need to pass all of those
inside so the first is for the item
second is my quantity
third is my
discount
the next thing that I want to do is I
want to set the key and value pairs
again let us first type it out and then
I will try and explain so I can say my
self dot items now here the key is going
to be a string so this is the part that
we are working on the key is the string
and the value is the invoice item
so if you refer the document
I want the key to be the name of the
item so that's what we are going to do
right over here
let us go down and we can say that the
key has to be
the name of the item and the value is
the new item which we just created now
let us go to the next line what happens
if this item is already existing inside
our registry
so we can say else we simply want to
print out we can see item dot name
already in card you want to update
instead let me take out one more extra
comma we don't require this one now let
me try and explain what's happening
right over here let us go back to this
document now let's see how the logic
goes
so suppose this is my iPad and shell let
me create
my cache register
for now it can be an empty dictionary
so this is all good
now let us go to this line our cash
register has one key which is called as
item and the value is of a type of
dictionary itself
so let us do that over here so we can
say for my register I want to create one
key which is called as items sorry it
has to be items
and this is
an empty dictionary
let us try to print it out so this is
how our register is looking right now we
can also use the if and in syntax when
working with our dictionaries suppose we
want to check if our dictionary has one
key which is called as items or not so
we can say items in register and that is
true let us check for customer in the
resistor so that's false because we
don't have a key called as customer
inside the resistor we can use the same
syntax when referring to items as well
remember items is also a type of
dictionary let us assign some values to
these items and then we can check for
the if and in conditions
let me copy
all of this I just want this one
and we can say for my directory of
register I want you to go to my
directory of items now what we can do is
since this is a directory we can also
create new keys and new values over here
so here I can say I want to create a new
key
for my Apple
and the value is this one we just copied
right over here so let me just paste it
over here so this is the value
and that's it let me just clear all of
this
let us try to see how the resistor is
looking right now so this is how it is
looking inside the register we have a
key called as items and inside the items
we have apple as of now
let us copy and paste one more product
this one so let me copy this
and we can use the same syntax so I want
to say
register is a directory I want you to go
and find
the key of items here let us create
another key by the name of eggs
and let us assign a value of this thing
to it
and that's it let me clear it and let us
see how our
register is looking now
so here we have it first we have an
apple which is right over here and then
we have an egg now let us check if an
particular product is inside our items
or not
so we can say apple
in my
register I want to access my dictionary
of items
and in this dictionary so from year to
year we want to see if we have any Keys
called as Apple we do have so the answer
of this one should be true
and that's it we have the answer of true
let us try to search if we have milk
inside our items or not so let me just
go and change this
from Apple
will false we don't have milk inside our
items now if I just flip the statement
so if I say milk
not in now let's see what we get as a
response so the response is true milk is
not in miter is free
now since my milk is not there inside my
register only then I would like to add
it if it is existing then I would simply
like to update it now let us go back to
our code and try to
relate what's happening so let us have a
look at this line at line number 24. I
am just trying to check if an item is
existing in our items or not on line
number 26
so items is our dictionary the key is
going to be the name of the item so
that's what I've taken right over here
and we are assigning this item
to the key that we just created and we
have a beautiful structure in place but
this function is not at complete the
moment we add one item we also need to
upgrade our total otherwise our logic
would be wrong so let's see how to do
that in order to show the totally
inverse value
we would also require one more
additional instance variable so let us
create one private this time so we can
say this is a private member and I can
say self plot invoice total
initially let us set it to zero I want
the type to be a float
instead of an integer
now what happens right over here
whenever we are adding an item
we also need to increase the invoice
total that's pretty simple so we can
simply say self Dot underscore invoice
total plus equal to and we can say my
new item
dot get subtotal
remember when we created this invoice
item
we implemented this method to calculate
the subtotal and why do we need this
method because we have to adjust for the
quantity and discount
and that's what we are using right over
here so this method gives us the
subtotal for the new item which we
simply want to add to our invoice total
but the issue is this method is not
reliable what happens if you have a typo
instead of plus we have minus or we need
to do some other validation logic before
we can increase the total the answer is
let us create one function that will
increase the subtotal so let's create
one method right over here so we can say
increase the invoice total the first
argument would be obviously the self now
let's see what argument should we take
if you go down we can get the subtotal
if we have the access to our new item
the type of this new item is an invoice
item so that's what we need to get right
over here so this function accepts an
item which is or the type of
invoice item and this returns nothing
let us add a documentation saying that
this increments the total inverse value
each time an item is added let us go
down and let us take this line this is
what we are exactly doing right over
here
let me paste it and let us change the
name of the variable because the
variable we are calling it as just the
item over here so this is the item let
us go below and use this newly created
function here we can say I want to sell
Dot I want to increment my invoice total
and I simply need to pass the new item
inside of this so new item the last
modification that I want to do over here
is I want to keep this method as private
I don't want any other developer to
accidentally change my logic let us go
down and let me update this syntax as
well now we have a beautifully typed and
a much more stable code and while we are
here let us create one more method
to decrease or decrement the invoice
total whenever we are deleting an item
from the register we would also need one
method to decrease the subtotal so let's
do it right now let me copy and paste
all of this
the name changes from increment to
decrement this also changes to decrement
and this becomes removed
and this becomes
minus equal to and that's it let us
create the next method to update our
card the logic is somewhat similar to
this one so let me copy and paste all of
this
this has to be update let me change the
documentation so this becomes too
update an existing item and this one
becomes not in the card
and do you want to purchase instead now
let's see the logic for this one we can
update an item only if it is existing so
let's do that right over here so let us
change from not in to just in so if we
have that item only then let us try and
update it but before we can update that
item we need to get the old atom back
and we also need to decrease from the
invoice total so here we can say that my
old item is equal to my self dot items
and I want to retrieve a specific item
and this item would be
my item dot name so let us go back to
our IPython and let's see what's
happening over here
we are just trying to retrieve a data so
this is our existing register and
suppose we want to get all of the
details for X suppose we want to update
the discount or the quantity and so on
before we can update we need to retrieve
it first so I can say my
egg details
first I want to go to my register now
since this is a dictionary I want to
access my key and the name of my key is
items
and inside items I want to access
another key this time the name of the
key is X we can see right here we have a
key called as X
so this will retrieve the value for this
one
let us see what's happening
oh there is a syntax error so this has
to be a square bracket let us try to
print the egg details now
and we have the details in place and
that's what we are doing right here we
are simply trying to retrieve an item
from its key now remember the keys are
always string values so if you go right
over here we can see item is a
dictionary
and the key is a string this string is
the name of the item so that's what we
want
after we have the old item we also need
to decrement its value so we can say
self I want to decrement the value and I
simply need to pass an item so let us
pass just the old item on the next line
we are going to create a new item with
updated quantity and discount and we are
going to add that item back to our
register so all of this logic Remains
the Same let us go to the next part and
let us see how we can delete an item but
first let me go back to my iPad and
shell and let me show you how to delete
an item from a dictionary let me clear
all of this and let us print our
register one more time
so you can see resistor has a key of
items and inside these items we have two
another items one is for apple and one
is for our eggs suppose we want to
delete Apple
let's see how to do that the way to do
that is by using a keyword called as
delete
and after this we simply need to specify
which key we want to delete so I want to
say I want you to go to my register from
register I want you to access my items
and once inside my items I want you to
delete my key of Apple
and that's it now we should try to print
a resistor and you can see we have
deleted Apple let's use this syntax
right over here to delete an item from
our register right over here let me copy
and paste all of this
let me take a little up the name is
remove we don't need the quantity and
the discount we just need to know the
item that we are supposed to delete let
me update the documentation so this is
going to be removed item from our cache
resistor we don't require this as well
now let's see the logic we can delete an
item only if it is existing and that's
what we are checking over here so we
need this logic in place since we are
not creating any item we can delete all
of these things here we are retrieving
an item the next line we are
decrementing the invoice total now we
simply have to delete it from our
dictionary and we have already seen the
syntax so we can say I want to delete
from my items and the key would be my
item dot name and let us see what else
is remaining
it will go back to my document
and we have to implement this methods
get invoice total and display which are
pretty simple let's create the first one
we can say get invoice total this takes
a self and this returns a float let me
add some documentation and here we
simply have to return cell dot
underscore invoice total the last one is
to display our invoice so let us create
some pretty looking output so I can say
display my invoice takes the self and it
returns
nothing let us try to visualize how our
invoice would look like
now this is the code from my GitHub
repository I am inside my projects and
project number one if I run this file I
have a output
and this is how our invoice would look
like so on the first line we would like
to have a nice separator followed by the
customer details and followed by the
date of the purchase so let us go back
and let us do all of these things
here we can create a nice separator line
by using a print statement
and I would just like to say that this
is my separator multiplied by 70 times
so what this is going to do it is going
to repeat this symbol for 70 times
before this let us insert a blank line
so we have a nice spacing in place
next let us see what we want we want the
customer details and the date so we can
just go back and
here on the next line I can simply say I
want to print self and if you see our
Str method that's what we are doing
right over here
so this is our string method customer
and followed by the total items
and that's what we want right over here
the next line is for the date
so let us go down
and on the next line we can say I want
to print my date and we already have it
so I can say self dot purchase read now
remember in some of the earlier videos
we formatted this date and time
according to the month day and the year
that's what we are going to do right now
as well
so I can use the method called as
string format time and let us give us a
format so this format stands for the
month the day and the year let's see
what we need next
we require one separator and after the
separator we require all of the items so
let's get back and let me copy this line
from here let me change the separator
from plus to our Dash and in the next
line we want to print all of the items
that's pretty easy so I can just say for
my item in my self dot items dot values
let us print out the item and this has
to be brackets because we want to get
the values out of our dictionary next
let us see what we want
so we require one more separator total
price and one last separator so let's do
that
let me copy and paste this right over
here
on the next line we can see that my
total price would be in dollars
serve Dot get invoice total and let us
display only two to seven points so I
can say colon and I want two decimal
points for my float
and that's it let us go back and check
oh no we require one more separator
so let me copy this and
paste it right over here now we have a
way to display our invoice as well we
are using multiple print statements but
if you want you can use a template or
you can also use a multi-line string as
well but this is much more simple for
now now let's get back to our document
so we have everything in place
let us check what's remaining so code we
have cache register in place now we just
need to find out a way to interact with
our cache register so that means we just
need to create a client that can
interact with our resistor so let me
create a new file let me name it as the
Vista Dot py
so this would be our clad file and here
obviously first we need to import our
cache register so let me collapse my
sidebar and I can save from the model of
cache register I simply want to import
my cache register and then we also need
a customer so I can say from my model of
customer I need customer the last thing
I want is the item so I can save from
item let's import
item let's create the first item so let
us create milk so we can say milk is an
item let's give it an idea of 100
name would be just milk
price could be 4.5 dollars and the
measurement unit can be a liter let us
create our customer as well so I can
save my customer one
is my customer
the first name is Lewis
the last name is Zappa now this customer
is going to the store and making an
purchase so let us create a cash
register for Lewis so we can say this is
my cash register number one we simply
have to give the customer and that is
our customer number one let us try to
print out our cash register right now so
I can say print my cash register one
let me save it and let me try to run
this file so right now the customer is
Louis Zappa and the total number of
items is 0 and that's true because we
have not yet added any items so let's
get back and let's make Lewis purchase
something so here we can see that
my cash register one I simply want to
add an item and the item I want to add
is my milk now you can give some
additional arguments as well the
quantity and the discount right now let
us go with the default values
and let us try and save and run this
file
now we can see we have one item on our
invoice
let us go back
let us create some more items let us
create one as egg so I can say item the
ID could be 101 the name is egg the
price could be 99 Cents for one egg
the measurement unit is for a piece then
we can make one for Rice we can say item
id could be one or two name is arise
price could be four dollars for a kg
let's create one last one maybe for an
apple we can say
item ID could be 103
the name is Apple maybe it is for 5.67
dollars
for a kg now let us make Lewis purchase
some other items as well suppose Lewis
also wants to purchase eggs so we can
say
cr1 dot add items so Lewis wants to buy
some eggs suppose this time he is
purchasing 12x
and for quantity of 12x there is a
discount of 50 cents that's it let us
save the file and let us try to run this
so this time you can see we have two
items in our invoice
a little better way to display the
invoice could be by using our inbuilt
function so let me take it out
and let me say cr1 dot I want to display
my invoice
now let us try to run this file
so this time we have a much better
output so we can see the customer is
Louis Zappa there are two items this is
the date of his purchase and these are
the items remember for the egg we
specified the quantity was 12 and there
was a discount of 50 cents that's what
we have over here here you can see we
have only one item so the subtotal is
450 for this one we have 12 items minus
the discount and so the subtotal is
right over here and right over here we
have the total price as well let's try
to play a little bit more with this one
let's try to upgrade one item so suppose
Lewis thinks that 12x are like a lot and
he wants to buy only 10x so we can say I
want to update my eggs
and this time the quantity is 10 but
fortunately the store is in a good mood
and the store is offering a discount of
say one dollar so let us save it and
give it a try so you see we have an
updated quantity of 10 discount of one
dollar and we also have an updated
subtotal as well and automatically the
total price also gets updated
let us go back and let us try to add one
more item suppose this time Lewis wants
to buy some rice
maybe he wants to buy three kgs of rice
and there is a 75 cent discount on this
one
so let me save this and let us run the
file
so this time we have three items and we
also have rice in our items as well let
us go back now let us see if we try to
add an item which is already existing
then what happens so let me copy and
paste this one
save and let us try to run the file so
here you can see we get the prompt say
that rice is already in card do you want
to update instead so you can see all of
our code is working beautifully and if
you see right over here nothing is
changed everything is just as before let
us go back now what happens if we try to
update an item which does not exist so
suppose we say that we are trying to
update an item maybe we are trying to
update
for apple and the quantity could be 10
the discount could be zero
so let me save it and let me try to run
this one so again we get a nice message
saying that Apple not in card purchase
instead and if you see the invoice it's
just as before there are no changes to
our items
so let us go back
so right over here we can say that
we want to
remove eggs
and let us try to display our invoice
after repoing as well so let me copy
this
and let me paste right over here let me
run this file
so here you can see this is the earlier
invoice in this invoice we have eggs and
and this is the next one when we remove
we don't have eggs in our invoice
so you can see we can also remove an
item from our invoice
I also wanted to show one more trick
right over here
we can also create an alias for
customers Suppose there is a big
application and there are two files and
inside both of the two files we have a
class of customer then we can create an
alias so we can just say that I want to
import customer as my customer and we
simply have to update one line over here
so this instead of a customer this will
be called as
my customer
just save your file and if you try to
run it everything works smoothly let us
go back and let us create one more
customer just for the last time so we
can say my customer 2 is my customer and
first name is Chico her surname is
Neutron let us create a cache register
for this one as well so this is going to
be my
cash register for my customer number two
suppose she is purchasing some milk and
the quantity could be four liters here I
can also use my keyword syntax so I can
say my quantity would be
4 4 and suppose we have a discount of 10
dollars let us try to add one more item
so this time she wants to buy some eggs
and the quantity is 25 next she decides
to update the quantity of x
so next time the quantity is 48 now
fortunately the store is offering a
discount of 12 on the quantity of 48.
Chico also wants to buy some apples so
let us buy some apples as well and let
us display the invoice
that's it let me save the file and let
me try to run this file
so here we have the invoice for Chico so
Chico has three items milk egg and
apples for the milk the quantity was
four liters the updated quantity for X
was 48 and for apples it was 8 and this
is the total price now we have a
beautiful program in place let us go
back I wanted to mention one point over
here if you see the code inside my
GitHub so this is the code downloaded
from GitHub my GitHub file has a couple
of more methods for example if you go to
cash register I have a couple of extra
methods so all of this is extra and I
had to create this methods because I
wanted to see the output in a dictionary
format
so if you go to this document
I wanted to have the output in this
format
so that is why I had to do a couple of
more work
and that's the reason why you can see
all of these methods but I am not going
to explain all of these methods inside
this tutorial if you want you can give
it an attempt and try and study what's
happening but to just give you a short
idea I am converting everything to a
form of a dictionary and finally I am
exporting that dictionary to a Json
format that's why I can have a nicely
formatted output now if I go to this
file register so this is on my GitHub
code so here I am using this method to
Json to have a nicely formatted output
now if you run this file I can get the
output in the way I desired I hope you
learned something new in this video now
this video had a lot of Concepts and it
was very densely packed so if you don't
understand any concept you are not to be
blamed it's quite natural that it will
take you some time to understand maybe
you have to go through this video a
couple of times you would also need to
have some better understanding of how to
work with your dictionaries before you
can understand what's exactly happening
in this code so this project is going to
test all of your basic understanding of
python up till now now the next game
would be much more easy to implement and
I'll see you in the next video I am so
happy to see you in the last part of
this entire tutorial
the last part is all about our game
saving zotan and in this final project
we would be actually implementing how to
think in layers first we will write all
of the code and then I will try and
explain why we did what we did so for
starters I have created a folder called
as project 2 savings Orton as you can
see it's all empty so let me go and let
me copy my file it's right inside my
section number six
let me copy this
and let me paste inside my project
number two let me open up the project in
a new window so I can say I want to open
my project number two
and that's it we have a nice and clean
slate to work with and this is our
existing code now let's begin till now
we have seen how to organize our code in
different modules but for this game we
are going to create a package of game
and that package will contain all of the
logic and everything that goes for
creating a nice game so here I am going
to create a package called as game and
as you know making a package is very
simple it's just like creating a
directory
so let me create a directory let me call
it as game and let us create our init
file
so that python knows that this is a
package
now let me drag and drop this file
inside my package
yes I am want to move now let's begin
with our code so let us get started let
me open up this file and let's see the
first one we have for the character type
so what we want to do is we want to make
our game as modular as possible so what
we are going to do is we are going to
take out everything and everything goes
inside its own module so inside my
package of game let me create a module
by the name of character type dot Pi I
simply have to copy and paste everything
so right from here I need the Imports
let me take all of this let me cut it
out go to my character type and paste it
let us see what's next
the next one is our character so let's
create one more module inside our
package of game
and let us call it as character dot Pi
again I simply have to cut all of this
so let me take everything from here
let me cut it out and go and paste right
over here let us go back
the next is for the superhero so again
let us create a new file
superhero dot pi and let me take
everything from here let us cut it out
go to our superhero file let me paste
this and we can see we have a couple of
errors and that's because we need to
import character and character type so
let me go to the top
now here since we are working inside a
package we need to say that from the
current package the module of character
I want to import the class of character
the same thing for character type as
well so from the current package I want
you to go to a model called as character
type I want you to import my
character type now if you save all of
the errors will go away let us go back
the next one is for villain so again go
back right over here
let us create a new file called as
villain dot pi and
let us take all of these things
let us cut it out and paste it right
over here also let us do our Imports so
from director import character
from character type import my character
type let us go back
so the next one is for the life let us
create a new file called as live dot pi
and
let me take all of these things
till till the last till yeah
let me cut it out and
paste it right over here let me save it
let's go back to this file and if you
see this file is pretty much empty now
so let me delete all of the blank lines
from here I don't require all of these
things
let me take out the documentation as
well because we already know what it's
all about don't require this as well so
let me go on the top so we have a much
smaller file this time and let's see how
we can improve even further but before
we can go a little further I wanted to
add a couple of more classes the first
class that I wanted to add is for a
player it would be so nice to have a
player so let's create a very simple
class for player so let me say my player
dot Pi this is going to be my class of
player I can Define my init the first is
obviously the self next could be for the
first name this is string next for the
last name this is also a string and this
returns nothing I can say self DOT first
name is equal to my first name and self
dot last name is equal to my last name
let us create the wrapper method so I
can say retr and sell this returns a
string and it can return saying that
this is a class of player
let us create the string method as well
so our self this returns a string so let
me just return the first name and the
last name so I can say self dot my first
name and self dot my last name that's it
and this time we are going to have one
more class and that class is for the
game State just imagine when we are just
starting the game we can have a
different state maybe initializing when
we are playing the state changes from
initializing to in progress and at the
last the state can change to either win
or lose so we can keep a track of the
state by creating a new class so let us
create a new module right over here
so this is going to be called as my
gamestate dot Pi for this I am going to
use the enum so I can say from my enum I
want to import enum and auto then I can
say my class of game state which
inherits from enum let me add some
documentation first one we can call as
initializing so set it to Auto next one
for in progress again set it to Auto the
last two would be for the win and the
Lost
let's take a moment to review what we
have done up till now we have created a
module for each of the objects inside
the game but if we have a look at all
our modules they are basically
structures for something for example
character this is a structure for
something character type again a
structure for the types of characters
game State the types of game state that
we can have
for player again we just have a
structure the same thing for superheroes
so this is just a structure for
superheroes and so on so technically we
can call all of these structures as
schemas so schema simply represents a
structure and that's it so let's create
another package inside the game of
package called as schemas and let us put
all of this functionality inside that
package so inside my game let us create
one more folder by the name of schema
and to make this folder a package let me
create file inside of this it has to be
again init underscore underscore dot Pi
so let me collapse all of these things
on the top level we don't have anything
we just have a package of game inside
the package of game we have another
package called as schema now let us move
all of the schemas into the right
package
so my character type my character
game State live player
superhero and villain all of these
things will go inside my package of
schema
yes I want to move everything
so let me collapse my schema right over
here
so inside my package of game we have
three things
first one is an another package of
schema
then our init file and last one is our
game file now let us go back to our game
file let's see what's next
here we can see that we are retrieving
all of the superheroes or we are
retrieving a single superhero normally
in an application you would have a
database where you will store all of the
superheroes and all of the super
villains and that database could be
controlled by something which is called
as a models so just to get a field of
models let us create one more package
inside game
so inside game let me create a folder
called as models and inside this folder
let us create a init file to make it
unpackage let us go back to my games
file now what happens in an application
whenever you want to interact with a
database so you can imagine all of these
things to be a part of the database
because this is the place where we are
storing all of our data so normally a
model would do all of these things for
us so let's go into models and let us
create one model for our superheroes
so this becomes my superheroes dot pi
and let us create one more model for our
villains so this would be my file for
villains dot pi and let us start writing
up a code inside of this so first let me
go to my superheroes so let us declare a
class called as super hero model
and let us create the init method now
this init method does not take any
argument because we don't need anything
and this returns nothing now for the
instance variable we can simply return
all of the superheroes or a single
superhero so let's see how we can do
that we can declare an instance variable
called as self.all and we can return all
of the superheroes but let's see how to
do that for now let me assign it a blank
list let me go back to my file of my
game here I just want to cut out all of
this functionality for get all
superheroes and get superhero
let me cut it out go back to my models
file
and let me paste everything right here
now since this belongs to the class I
want to take it inside so
let me take it inside the class
and since now these are members of the
class the first argument has to be self
and here as well the first argument has
to be
self now let's see what to do next now
this method called as get all
superheroes it returns a list of
superheroes so this means that this is
the schema of the superhero
so let's import it let me go to the top
now what happens is we are inside the
package of models and the schema of
superheroes resides in some other
package called as schema which is right
over here so here we can say from
my package of game I want to go to the
package of schema and from here I want
to go to the model of superhero and once
over there I simply want to import my
superhero now you can see all of the
errors are gone
let me save this the next thing is this
is complaining because we have not given
the tides for this one so self dot all
is going to be a list of all my
superheroes right now it is blank but we
can easily get it from this method so I
can say
this is just myself dot get all
superheroes and that's it so what this
method is doing is it already has the
data for all of the superheroes
on this line it is creating a list
and on this line it is returning that
list so we have access to all of the
superheroes now what happens here is
since we have an instance variable
called as self.all we don't have to
expose this method to everyone and so we
can make this method as a private method
and you know the way to make it private
is by putting an underscore so this
syntax has to be updated right over here
so this also becomes my underscore now
let us go to this one
so this has to be my self dot underscore
get all superheroes and in fact we don't
require this line at all because this
time we already have a class and we
already have access to all of the
superheroes inside our instance variable
called as self dot all so what we can do
is we can take out this line
and here we can simply check for the
length of
self dot all and this also gets updated
to self dot all
and everything is looking beautiful
let us also create the string method
right over here so we can say Define my
Str
ICT self and it returns a string as well
now let's see what we would like to
display now since this model represents
our data we can simply print out a list
of our superheroes
so let's do that over here so what we
can do is we can simply print out the
names of our superheroes inside a list
let's see how to do that first let us
create a list for all of the names so
this can be a list of string and let me
assign it to a empty value then let us
just populate this list with all of the
names of the superhero so I can say for
my superhero in my self dot all I simply
want to append to my list of names so I
can say name dot append and each time I
want to append the name of my superhero
so I can say my super hero and his name
and let's see we have an error missing
written statement oh yes we are not
returning the list so we can say return
my list of name now we have one more
error and this error is because the
return type is a string but we are
returning a list so let's do one thing
let's use our formatted string so I can
use my formatted string and let me put
this inside my curly brackets now
everything is looking good let us repeat
the same thing for our villains as well
so let me copy all of these things from
this file go inside my models then to my
villains and let me paste over here so
this becomes my villain this becomes my
villain
this also becomes my villain
Everything Changes this also becomes my
villain again
here we have a
villain
let's change
this one as well and this also needs to
change so this will be villains we don't
have this method as of now but let us go
to the games file and let us copy
everything right from here so let us cut
all of these things
and go inside our villains model
let me
paste everything over here and let me
take everything inside my class now
since this belongs to a class let us add
self then this becomes a private method
then we need to add self over here this
line needs to go this line becomes my
self dot all same thing over here this
also becomes my self.all and this is
just for our super villains everything
is looking really good so till now what
we have done is we have segregated our
code as per it functionality wherever we
had only the structure all of those
files wet inside my schemas and where I
have to interact with my database or my
data those files went inside my models
now let us go back to our games file so
this is my game file right over here
let us start deleting all of these
things which are not required
so let me take it up if you see we would
have a bunch of Errors now let's try to
work on this file now this file is all
about the game and the actual logic so
this is the place where we are actually
implementing the game so the first thing
that I want to do is I want to rename
this file now since this file is all
about implementation I like to call this
file as just impl so which stands for
implementation you are free to name this
file whatever you want you can call this
file as your logic your brain or
anything that you want but for me
implementation makes much more sense now
let's see what we can do inside this
file first let me close this folder and
this one as well and let me only open
this file so this is where we are
working right now our implementation is
all about a game so the first thing that
we require right via is we require a
class of game this class will keep a
track of everything it will keep a track
of which player is playing the game what
is the game state is the game in
progress or someone has won or someone
has lost what is the state who are the
superheroes and who are the super
villains and this class is also going to
control all of the methods that we have
defined over here so it's going to
control our attack
and our win or lose as well so let's
create a class so this class is like the
implementation of the entire game let us
create a class called as game let us
Define the init method it takes a self
now this init method only requires a
player we will just take one player and
we will initialize a blank game in
return so let's accept one player the
type is a player now remember inside our
schemas we already have a player which
is right over here so let's go and
import the player from our schema and we
need to do one more change so this is
not a single schema this is key Mars so
let us add an s yes we want to make some
changes now since we have changed the
name of the package let us go to our
models
so by default Visual Studio code is
going to do this for you but if it is
not happening inside your IDE then make
sure this is schemas and for villains
this also needs to be schemas so let me
go back to my implementation of file so
here on the top I can say that from my
current package so remember right now we
are directly inside our package of game
so let me collapse my models and schemas
so you can see our file of
implementation is at the same levels as
our models and schemas and game itself
is a package so we can see from the
current package
I want you to go to the package of
schemas then go to the model of player
and import our player let us go to this
line right over here so our init method
returns nothing now let's see what kind
of instance variables do we require
first let me write all of the instance
variables and after that we can populate
them the first one would be for the
player and we already have the data
that's right over here cell dot player
next I want to keep a track of the game
state so I can say self dot state would
be my game State we will import that
shortly let us create the next variable
first we also need to keep a track of
all of the superheroes and all of the
super villains so let us create an
instance variable for all of the
superheroes let me get my Spring right
this has to be my superheroes and we
need one more variable for our villains
now let's see how we can populate all of
these things for the state we already
have a game State defined inside our
schemas so we can say
from the current package go to schemas
go to my
game State and import my game State now
let's see the first time we don't have
any data so we can assign the state to
initializing so we can just say my state
would be game state DOT initializing
now let's see for the next one we can
get all of the superheroes from our
models so let's go and import our models
as well
so I can say from my current package
go to my models go to my superheroes and
import my superhero model let's do the
same thing for our villains as well so
dot models dot villains import
the villain model and here we simply
want to initialize it so this becomes my
superhero model this becomes my villain
model now just remember when we created
the model so if you go over here and if
you see the superheroes you can see the
Constructor does not accept any argument
so that's what we are doing over here we
are not giving any arguments because it
is not required and with this we can
easily have access to all of the
superheroes and all of the super
villains as well let us create the
wrapper and the stream methods for this
as well so we can say my wrapper method
takes a self this returns a string and
let it return that this is a class of
game next let us create and string
method as well this returns a string now
let's see what we would like to return
maybe we would like to return all of
this details on separate lines so let's
see how to do that so I can say I want
to return a formatted string let me
collapse my sidebar for a while now and
let me take it up so the first thing
that we want to display is obviously in
the player and you can say self dot
player now we want to display lay the
state on a next line we can use a small
trick over here we can say backslash and
N so this is going to create a new line
for us automatically and on the next
line I would like to display my state so
I can say the state would be my self Dot
let me put a comma here as well so on
the next line I would like to display my
superheroes oh I need a code right over
here so I can say my
superheroes would be my self dot
superheroes let me get my spelling right
let me put my comma and we require one
more line now since this is getting a
little long let me split this so let me
put a brackets and let me take it down
and let me add one more formatted string
right over here and this would be for
our villains so we can just say that
self dot above valence let us go below
and let us take all of these things
inside our class of games let me copy
all of these things the method of attack
the method of
similar attack and we also need this
method of win or lose till this point I
want everything inside my class let me
take it inside let me save the file
and now we don't need all of these
things because right now we are just
creating a package and we will see how
to use this package in the future so let
me take it out and you can see we have a
bunch of Errors so let's try and work
with our file
so let's work with this one so this is
the place where the attack is taking
place so I can just say in this block is
for the attack now since this belongs to
the class of game we can write self
same thing will happen with our simulate
attack as well so I can just write self
right over here so let me save this
again this one this also has to take
myself looks good now let us go back
now let's see how the attack is going to
take place now let's fine tune our
attack Logic Let me put some
documentation so whenever we start an
attack we can change our state from
initializing to in progress inside this
we can say self dot state so when we
start an attack it changes to my game
State DOT in progress then let's print
out a nice line saying that start in
attack and if you want to check the
state we can simply print out the state
as well so you can just say my self dot
state so let us go down now let us have
a look at this line at this line we are
trying to get a single superhero but now
we have this method inside our model so
let me open up the file inside models if
you go to our superhero
now we have created a class called as
superhero model and inside this class we
have a method called as get super hero
so let us try to reference this method
right inside our implementation file so
what we can write here is we can simply
say that we want to go to the self dot
our superheroes so remember this
superhero is actually the superhero
model
let me show you one more time so you can
see this superheroes is actually the
superhero models so we can access this
method right over here get superhero and
that's the way we can get our superhero
let's do the same thing for the villain
so I can say my self dot villains dot
get villain let me collapse my sidebar
now let's go to this line land number
43.
so since this method belongs to the
class it has to be self dot now what
this method is doing it is actually
doing the attack so we can have a little
better naming convention so we can just
change the name from simulate to do the
attack let me change right over here
also and we can do one more thing we can
mark this method as private because this
is all about our internal logic no one
has to know how we are doing the attack
it's up to us how do we implement the
logic this also needs to be my double
underscore you can write a single
underscore it's up to you so this simply
means that this method is just private
to this class now we have a bunch of
other errors for superhero villain and
life as well so let's import all of this
and all of the errors will go away let
us go to the top and here we can say
from my schemas from my superhero let us
import my superhero schema the same
thing we can do for the villain as well
so from dot schemas dot our villain let
us import the villain schema and we can
do the same thing from dot schemas dot
my life let me import my life and let's
see what's happening next
so you can see lot of the errors have
gone
now this is a pretty easy error to fix
we just have to import final and that's
it but let's not do it right over here
let us create a new file called as
constants now let me explain why do we
require a new file called less constants
there may be times where we can have
multiple constraints for our game for
example let us go right over here in
this method of attack you can see that
we have hardwired the value right over
here three so we have three over here
because we have
four superheroes and we have two over
here because we have three super
villains so we can think that all of
these are simply constraints for our
game but we can make our game much more
modular what happens if you want to
attack four times five times or what
happens if we have multiple superheroes
or multiple super villains we need to
have a very easy method of doing all of
these things so for this convenience let
us create a new file inside our game
inside my package of game I want to
create a new file called as constants
let me add some documentation you can
imagine this file to be just a helper
module and that's what this is doing the
first one was for the number of attacks
so we can just say the number of attacks
and we can assign a value of 3 over here
now let us go back to our implementation
file and instead of hard wiring 3 over
here let us import that and let us use
that constant over there so we can say
from current package go to the model of
constants and import my number of
attacks so let us go down and let us use
that right over here now we can increase
and decrease the number of attacks as
desired let's go little down over here
let us do the same thing for this one
let us take it out so these values are
never going to change they are going to
be constants no matter what so let me
cut it out let me go to my constants let
me paste over here let me fix the indent
now if you already know that we don't
require a final keyword because when we
name all of this in uppercase by default
my Pi or our IDE is going to treat them
as constants so we can take this one out
and this one as well and in fact we
don't require string as well because our
IDE would be able to infer all of those
things let us go back to our
implementation and let us imported so
let me go to the top so from constants I
also need to get my winning message and
also my loss message let us go down
now since we already have access to
winning and the losing message we don't
have to do anything let me take out this
line This is not required now let's see
what's happening right over here here we
also need to update the state of the
game suppose we are winning then we can
say self dot the state would be my game
state DOT win and in case we have lost
then we can say game state DOT lost so
now we can keep a track of the state of
the game at any given point of time
there is one last thing to do in this
file
and that is right over here
so here if you see we are using 3 and 2
because we have four superheroes and we
have three super villains but what
happens if we decide to add a couple of
more superheroes or a couple of more
super villains so let's try to make this
code a little bit more modular as
possible so what we want to do right
over here is we can simply say I want to
have the length of my self dot
superheroes dot all minus of one now
remember your index is always one less
than the length and that's what we are
doing right over here let us do the same
thing here as well so I can say the
length of my self dot my villains dot
all and I want to minus of one the last
thing to do inside this package
is to create a file and let us create a
file let us name it as game dot py now
this file will have a single line of
code so first let me write it and then
let me explain what I'm trying to do so
I can say from the current package I
want you to go into my implementation
and I want you to import my game as well
as my player and that's it so what we
have done is we have created an API
which means your application programming
interface so whenever some other
developers have to interact with their
code or if they want to play your game
they simply needs access to just this
one file game.py they don't have to
import any of these things models
schemas constants implementation nothing
of those things are required all of
those things are our internal
implementation the clients don't need to
know all of the logic they simply have
to consume our logic that means this
simply have to consume our API so now we
are getting logic we have been creating
our application in different layers so
this was a layer just for our schemas
models was just a layer for our database
or rather data in our case and this game
this file acts as our API now let us
create a client file and let us play our
game so outside the game let us create
our client so let me call it as main dot
file so by convention main is always
going to be the most important file or
the place where our program starts and
as a convention we require a function
which is called as main so this is the
place where python will start all of our
execution so this file can also be
thought as your client let me put up a
documentation so this file or rather
this model is just as a client it is
going to consume our API game and that's
it let us import our API so we can say
from my package of game I want you to go
to the model of game and from here I
simply want you to import my class of
game and player now this looks a little
odd game dot game but what we can do we
can improve our design with a small
trick so let us go back to our package
of game and let us go back to the model
of game let me copy this single line and
let me put it inside the init file so
this init file is for the game so I can
just put my edit file right over here
now I don't require this module let me
take it out
yes move to trash let me add some
documentation over here so since we have
this inside our init file we can simply
write
from game
import game and player it becomes so
simple now let us go back to our API
file which is this one now the beauty of
creating apis is with time your game is
going to evolve and sometimes you may
have some breaking changes so this was
our first version maybe you can have a
version 2 or maybe you can have a
version 3 but at that time the client
does not need to update his code we can
refactor all of the code inside
but the skip is API file the same
so you see we have a lot of advantages
of breaking our application into
multiple layers now let's get going to
the last part and let us create the main
method where we can actually play our
game unfortunately this is the most
easiest part let me collapse my sidebar
so this is returning nothing so I can
say none let me put some documentation
this is the place where our game begins
Let Us create the first player so we can
say my first player is my player and
Lewis the last name is Zappa now let's
create a game for Lewis so we can see we
want a game for our player number one
here let us just check the state of the
game and since we are just starting the
game our state would be initializing so
let us just check if that's the case or
not I want to see the state of my game
one so game one dot State and the last
thing to do is we need to invoke our
main method so let me save the file and
let me try
running it beautiful so as you can see
we have the state of initializing and
that's what we expected right
now let's start with the attack so here
we can say I just want to have my game
one dot attack but before that let us
try to print the game itself so let me
say print I want to print my game one
let me comment this for a moment run the
file and this is how your game looks
like the player is Louis Zappa state is
initializing this is the list of all our
superheroes and these are all our super
villains beautiful isn't it let us go
back and let us have the attack first so
we can say I want to have my attack and
after the attack I want to see if I have
winning or if I am losing let me save it
and let me try to run the file amazing
so we have a very beautiful output
unfortunately we lost and Thanos killed
our Avengers but it is such a beautiful
experience let us go back and I want to
make one last Small Change what we can
do is we we can create something which
is called as method chaining that means
what if we have a syntax like this game
one dot attack and here we can just say
dot win or lose so this will look so
neat and nice let's see how we can do
that and it's very easy to do it let me
open up my sidebar now remember all of
the implementation happens in a single
file so it becomes very easy to find out
where do we need to make our changes and
all of the changes happens in this file
for implementation now since we want to
have method chaining we simply have to
return the game so that means on our
method of attack we simply want to
return the game itself so I can say this
method is going to return my game let me
collapse my sidebar and I also need to
return so at the bottom right over here
let me go on the next line I simply have
to say that I want to return self now in
order for this syntax to work we need to
import one more thing so let me go to
the top
the first thing that we want to do is
from future I want to import my
annotations now we can use this syntax
let us do the same thing for our method
of win or lose so this returns a game
and at the bottom let me just say let me
return self beautiful let me close this
file and let me go to my main file we
can assign the game back to our variable
so I can say game one is equal to my
game one now let us print the state one
more time right over here so what's
happening is we are starting with an
attack and then we are checking if you
are winning or losing initially the
state would be initializing and after
the game it could either be win or it
could either be lost let me take this
little up so the first thing that we
want to do is we want to print the game
then the status then we play the actual
game
and let us have the state back again so
let me save this and let me play this
game so here it is
so this is our game right here the
player is Lewis state is initializing
superheroes super villains beautiful
then we are starting the attack after we
start the attack the state changes to in
progress this is how the attack is
taking place but unfortunately Thanos
has killed Avengers so our final status
is game State lost so let us play one
more time let us see if you are winning
or not
no lost no lost again lost lost oh this
time we are winning it's so amazing so
here you can see that when we won the
game our state is game State win it's so
damn amazing
let us create one more player and let us
play the game for the last time
so let me go right over here and let me
create one more player this player would
be Chico Neutron and let us go down over
here now just for the sake of nice print
route let us print a blank line before
the next game so here we can see my game
number two would be my game and this
time we can say my player is going to be
my player number two and we can start
playing the game here itself so we can
say dot attack and after the attack I
simply want to check if I am winning or
if I'm losing this method chaining makes
our game so easy to use so let me save
the file and let me play the game for
the last time oh I think both of us lost
Kiko also lost the game and uh Lewis
also lost the game let us play the game
one more time no
oh yes at least this time Lewis has won
the game before we say we are done let
us have a look at last time now there is
no more coding left I just want to show
this file and this file is called as
thinking in layers so let me collapse my
terminal my sidebar and let me put this
in my preview mode so this is the last
thing that I wanted to show you let us
try to conceptualize what we have
learned so far in this video by making
this game so what we did was we divided
our application into multiple layers now
let's see what we exactly did you can
imagine the first layer was our data
layer and the packages were responsible
for our data layer live inside the
folder or rather the packages of models
and schemas the visibility is private
and the role is internal so what happens
is whenever we want to interact with the
database whenever we want to create a
structure all of that code will go only
in this packages the advantage is when
we have multiple people working on the
same project all of us can know where to
find the data the next layer can be
thought as our business logic layer and
this layer is represented by our
implementation and we have all of our
implementation inside this file I
ampl.pi again the visibility is private
and the role is internal that means we
as the developer of this game or of this
Library only we can handle this file the
next layer can be called as an API the
package of game can be thought as our
API remember we added a couple of files
to our init method and our client can
simply import all of those things from
our package so essentially what is
happening is our API is acting like an
interface between our internal logic and
our consumer so the visibility of our
API becomes public and our main dot Pi
file can be thought as a client because
the client simply consumes our API and I
hope this gives you a much better
understanding of why we divided our code
so much and why we created so many
packages
now that was such an amazing amazing
effort and I would like you to
congratulate yourself
this was a pretty tough and a very
intense course for beginner and you
definitely deserve much needed
appreciation you have done an amazing
job
wow that was one really awesome journey
and I am so happy to see you at the end
of this course
now remember that the course is just
ending but your journey is just starting
and you have to do a lot before you can
really understand python the first thing
that you need to do is you need to solve
a lot of problems
and I also have a couple of topics that
you can see if you want to progress in
Python
so
and here they are so this is what you
should be learning next have a look at
how to handle files and folders
iterators and generators form a very
important part of python especially when
you are working with classes and you
want to create it labels
so make sure you have a look at them
then list comprehensions are also very
useful
the next point about data serialization
and deserialization
now this is very important when you are
working with web applications where you
have to convert your Json data or if
you're working with some other data
types such as if you want to convert
your CSV file or Excel files to pandas
data frame and so on the next is
decorators we already had a small look
about decorators but decorators is a
pretty big topic the next is about your
object oriented programming in which I
would like you to have a look at
abstract base classes and also oops in
this tutorial we saw how we can inherit
from a single class but in practice you
can inherit from multiple classes you
can also create classes that act as an
interface so there is a lot more to
learn about oops as well the next point
is about multi-threading and
multi-processing and the next one would
be your concurrency and async IO now
python has been a little notorious when
it comes to concurrency but lately there
have been a lot of development
especially with the async iOS and tax
so if you want to make concurrent
applications in Python I would suggest
you to learn a little bit more about
concurrency the next one is testing now
without testing none of your
applications are going to be complete
python ships with a testing framework
which is called as unit testing and
there are a couple of other testing
Frameworks such as Pi test the next
would be web Frameworks if you want to
create web applications or if you want
to create apis then I would suggest you
to have a look at Django flask and fast
API and last if you are interested you
can always try learning machine learning
and deep learning so this itself is a
very huge Topic in Python and again I
can't stress enough that you have to
solve more problems and finally before I
say goodbye I would really love to hear
from you you can visit my website or you
can tag me on Twitter or obviously you
can check me out on YouTube as well
see you and let the power of python be
with you